[Music]
e
for
[Music]
it's Flex Ley Santo he's still perfect
here in Toronto will anybody be able to
stop that man we're going to have to
wait till after the survival stage to
find out and of course Hikaru Nakamura
is literally fighting for his life Will
he win to stay here at the Champions
chess tour Final in Toronto he's going
to have to do it against the youngster
the upand comer Dennis the Menace
lazovic will he break the heart of fans
and send Hikaru home and Ali resa fuja
is fighting for his life against Magnus
Carlson will the future be fuja and will
his future stay alive here in Toronto
he's going to have to beat the goat the
number one and highest rated chess
player of all time let's hop in the car
let's get on the road the show starts
right
now you've heard the sayings The Road
Less Traveled rubber meets the road I'm
on the road to nowhere that need to get
up and go to just shut up and drive to
Parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid gotten
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curves Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
w we see a reaction Magnus Magnus Mouse
slipped oh my gosh look at yudin's face
some have pulled over but some what is
he doing slammed that foot to the floor
and just kept going any second Nakamura
is the winner not AB Maxim vaj the
Frenchman he wins the AI cup after six
stops along the way it's time for the
greatest proven ground and online chess
to drop that final pin in the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to end it
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close fight it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
[Music]
now whether by car by plane or by train
all roads lead to Toronto the CN tower
looking pretty as usual although the sky
is a bit gray and that might mean some
murky chances some murky things ahead
for a couple of our players we're going
to see who's alive and who's no longer
here not literally but with me here is
ky literally in studio as well as Levy
Rosman Gotham chess it's time for us to
dive right into the last day of round
robin play and the survival stage but
Levy first welcome we're so excited that
you're here and you've been watching at
home I have so help us know that from
you the fan at home what has been your
biggest takeaway to this point well I
guess there's two takeaways but let's
just say I'm really excited to see how
chess develops as an eport as a as a
media product I'm super pumped about
that it's been awesome watching it as a
fan and also uh complaining internally
about little fixes things that we need
to but it's important right it's
important for the future so that I've
enjoyed a lot in the chess has been
spectacular it's incredible to see
Wesley running perfect and it's crazy to
see Hikaru fighting to fend off
elimination so insane KY yeah what has
the vibe been here that Levy's been
missing bro The Vibes have been great
first off the food is amazing here
always in Toronto but the second thing
is that out there in the playing
atmosphere is very very important it's
been nice camaraderie you can tell that
yes okay there's so much going on
there's so much stress there's a lot of
money on the line there's a lot of you
know hey I'm the best guy here I want to
play you know a lot of Pride and Etc but
they're out there actually analyzing
games with each other NRE backck and
Wesley so we're talking about a game
that they played oh yeah A4 you should
have played A4 there and I'm like you
guys got another game to play I'm not
trying to help you at all like I want to
beat you like so it's really nice it's a
cool chill Vibe but it's also that might
also be a Wesley Vibe too that guy is
just he never stops having a good time
never stops smiling but awesome and on
the note of Wesley's Vibe as we take a
look back at what day three brought
brought a lot of Wesley a lot of other
drama as well let's let our recap tell
the tale and we're around move 50 now so
they will get increment shortly that
being said there's still two pawns left
and white king is about to run in oh oh
and the bar's going up Suddenly n Beck's
King is infiltrating going after the G5
Pawn make a move 4 seconds aaru he
panics and puts the Knight and loses
upon Pawn he needs to move he needs to
speed up and both players are so nervous
they're living on that increment right
now the pawn A4 is Ed the white king is
going towards the queen side 85 is going
to drop oh andar Nakamura he gets up he
resigns not Abdul satov he reacts he
knows he's done it so just leaving the
bishop on C4 to allow tension and what a
move by Wesley so jumps in with a night
check and that night is on pre Wesley
playing for the win I mean it's just
shock Magnus is reeling with Tru this is
a free porn I think you can just take
this you can drop the White Queen back
if you need to
but uh this is just going to end in
Checkmate Magnus is down a queen as well
this is an absolute Gem of a game from W
he's just in snaring this King The King
has no moves if he gets to deliver one
check it's over he's also up a couple
pawns what a beautiful beautiful game a
tactical Skirmish that has gone his way
the thing is when you're playing Magnus
gson you can have a winning position but
you have to beat him in every move and
Wesley s has done it Magnus Carlson
resigns Wesley s takes the armag and
look at him Karu I mean he just cannot
believe it not a single match is really
going his way he got that one win over
fuja but besides that it's been all his
opponents just taking full points
against him there's going to be a killer
blow any moment that black king hiding
in plain sight is three pawns
temporarily the advantage what can just
move the queen to any safe Square Park
it on E6 today is not his day he will
have to to win tomorrow he gives up he
resigns shake hands and Fabiano Carana
gets another win in the
bag
for any fans who maybe have been hiding
under a rock it's important to see those
standings and be reminded that both
Wesley and Magnus have already punched
their ticket to the semis regardless of
their play today and of course we go
down to the bottom right there we see
the two players in red as fate would
have it are playing each other fighting
for their life and we start with aaro
Nakamura we saw the Armageddon recap
there going down for his fourth
Armageddon match in a row to Fabian
Carana but Levy nice sweater thank you
does aaro need to change his sweater
it's been the same outfit I I mean I
can't comment on that that's not the
question I was expecting I was going to
bring up the fact that yeah it is it is
a really shocking tournament events I
think it's very important when we talk
about Hikaru and let's say if he's
losing four matches it's not to take
anything away from his opponents they've
obviously played incredibly well they've
been clutch it's really the fact that in
some of these matchups hikaru's
equalized he's gotten to a point of
equality a point of being able to fight
for a win or a correct result in an
Armageddon and it's gone wrong every
single time and that is the most
shocking CS that clutch time decision
making he hasn't been himself yeah it's
very difficult to see I mean look at
that on the screen when do you ever see
like is maybe this a problem with
production is is his all these losses
here and hi Caro's face is there I don't
understand it it doesn't make sense to
me I don't know what's going on Danny
help me please yeah it's it's uh not the
stat you expected to see and they all
came as black too I I'm I'm trying to
unpack some of these things cuz as Levy
said it's not like hikaro is getting
blown out right he's losing armag get in
battles the type of format where you
favor him and I still would regardless
of the play here probably against almost
anybody in the world right I mean he's
normally so clutch and so good in those
spots the little details have not been
going his way but all right we know that
we're talking about him not to pile on
the bad news hikaro knows it but because
he has so many fans out there the
pineapple crew Everybody is rooting for
him the sunflower gang and almost two
million of them actually what is this
man they didn't tell me they putting
this on the screen hey get YouTube Subs
on there man we we worked really hard to
find the one way we could still rank you
behind any other streamers and creators
in the
world one word why is there a space
between the SC else we list anything
else you list YouTube you list Tik Tok
anything else Gotham number one but
there you go when it comes to live
streaming followers and car Nakamura has
almost two million of them everything's
going to be okay love me but all right
but seriously he's got a lot of fans out
there everyone's rooting for him
unfortunately for hikaro even if he
beats l it may not matter we're going to
talk about that a little bit but let's
talk quickly about lavic the kid
everyone's talking about Hikaru tale of
the tape what do you think the kid is
bringing to the table uh well I do just
want to say this is the matchup I
believe of the oldest and the youngest
player in the event to his credit hikaro
is 36 years of age and he is still an
elite rapid Blitz and classical player
and Dennis is 17 so we're seeing NextGen
versus I mean hikaro at the age of 19
was already like 2730 before lvic was
even born hikaro has to win to stay
alive that's that's the story right win
or go home that's it Danny are you
winning or you going home Danny what are
you gonna do Dann I mean I'm gonna be
here no matter what whether like we're
handcuffed here but no I
mean lavic wasn't even alive there for
for when hikaro was already doing it at
the top that's what's crazy to think
about but all right let's talk about the
other pairings we've broken down the
stakes of Nakamura versus lvic of course
there are three other matchups so and
Carana Vash lrav versus Abdus saurov
we're going to get to both those later
but I think when we look at the pairings
KY the next one I want to roll right
into is Carlson versus fuia because as
we've now said a few times even if fuia
wins well actually if fuja wins he
controls his fate why so let's focus on
that mindset right you show up maybe
you're playing the goat doesn't matter
if you win you're still here that's true
that gives me some more motivation but
you also have to know that this
generational battle here with Carlson
and fuja I mean you if we remember
Carlson was like Hey I'm only going to
play the world championship if it's with
fua right so when fua shows up I think
we see that that next level Magnus shows
up too to show assert the dominance hey
I'm the number one player and I want to
show you this for a very long time young
fell yeah Magnus has said an interviews
he thinks Fu's ceiling is ridiculous
I've never heard him talk about another
player quite like that he says like fuja
is the man I mean he's been obsessed
with chess since his younger days and he
just loves that passion that Ali Resa
has for the game and the funniest thing
about today's matchup is if Magnus
Carlson does not show up to the playing
hall wowu or lvic match up doesn't
matter anymore and they're both
eliminated I don't see Magnus yet we got
like minutes guys got some time this is
crazy speaking of Magnus obvious maybe
he's watching right now and maybe he's
still considering it but let's bring up
the stats and show you that the dude had
look the dude's great no matter how you
break it down we're always looking for
new interesting ways to say the same
thing here we see Magnus Carlson's
accuracy including Armageddon versus the
field and then excluding Armageddon
versus the field both of them are pretty
dominant I guess that's an that's an
Acure kicking that's a that's a
straightup act kicking if you're if
you're M I know that didn't work but I
did it anyway KY Magnus is delivering an
accuracy kicking to the to the field
yeah that's ridiculous that's 6% there
without Armageddon that's crazy I mean
that's insane you know 96% I mean
basically everyone else is like okay if
people in to round down it's like 89 I'm
like a you know in class I got a B well
I got a a I got a A plus and that's what
Magnus is playing at that type of level
there that is insane to C I was also
thinking about that I was also was when
I saw 97.0 3 I I was like A+ right know
what I'm saying back in the day I'd be
like hey teacher I got a 96.6 maybe you
could and they were like nope you got a
A I was like family's going to be
unhappy about that but you know what 97%
is ridiculous uh some might even call it
interesting and uh you know Magnus uh on
fire you don't you don't get much better
than 97% I like that the accuracy goes
down a little bit in Armageddon because
you know he's playing some goofy stuff
just a little bit still the kind of
accuracy that slide is literally just to
be like yeah he's the best like I don't
even know why it's like I said we're
finding new ways to say how good Magnus
is all the time but all right the next
match up to preview Notre Beck abaturov
versus Maxim BOS the grav these are a
couple of world champions rapid and
Blitz being the former titles they won
Abdus aov leads 5-2 head-to-head Cy I
couldn't believe that when I saw this
stat I'm like wait are you sure it's not
the other way around that's crazy to
think about mvl is such a strong player
we know him for all his tactics what he
does what what he plays his openings and
Etc just a very creative strong
aggressive player but Abdu saurov in a
way actually is a very aggressive player
too as well as we know I didn't know he
was going to be five to two here so I'm
like man I mean NV going have to turn it
up a little bit bro cuz I am not into
what I'm seeing on that screen there I
don't like that Abus T was a private was
my guy my question is how many of those
are online so how many times have they
played online versus and they probably
played a lot onl think they played a
couple times in the tour this year I
don't know for sure but go ahead no I
was just going to say no Beck's amazing
and he's probably and he's he gives
interviews where he says he wants to be
the world champion and he wants to be
the go and everything and you know not
to spoil any any upcoming you know
content with the guy but I'm a tough
match up today's biggest matchup that's
like a tossup to me is this one like
will noer backck prevail or will NV say
I'm too experienced and I'm going to get
the job done wow all right speaking of
experience in getting the job done
Fabian caran and Wesley so have been
doing that for many years fans of
American chess know this rivalry well
well excuse me let's bring up the tape
you've got Carana at 31 years of age and
Wesley so not too far behind him they
have played a lot of chess games but so
lead 17-1 despite 21 draws which just
shows you again Levy I'm going to throw
it back to you cuz you asked him in the
interview to bring the day to a close
what is it about the rapid time control
that just brings out the best in Wesley
yeah for chess fans that might not be
familiar like they played a in a
tournament recently and it was a
classical chess tournament and I believe
Fabiano Uncorked some crazy opening
preparation and completely vaporized
Wesley and that's what you have to do
against Wesley in a longer time format
but you don't have 90 minutes here you
have 15 minutes and so you don't want to
necessarily give away some opening
secrets that you want to use in a later
tournament like the candidates which
Fabiano is going to play and Wesley
might play depending on qualification so
Wesley has major advantages in these
formats he just plays everything he
knows super well yeah and then he can
adapt to any style of opponent and he's
going for a perfect score so this is a
really interesting match up to me very
interesting I also like the fact that on
the stats it says 21 draws Danny I'm
tired of drawing you I don't want to
play that many games and keep drawing
also with with hikaro he drew like what
50 games mvl was like 30 draws right so
I think one of his strategies is
actually making it you know not boring
but playing to my solidity being very
solid not making any any bad moves
really playing as best as I can drawing
games and making you make some mistakes
cuz when you make mistakes I'm G to
pounce immediately it's been very good
from Wesley no Wesley has been
unbelievable I mean he has won every
single match six you literally can't get
any better than that uh he sacrificed
multiple pieces against Magnus and and
he went for a checkmating attack that
was ridiculous and Fabiano is also doing
very well I mean to he could tie Magnus
and get to that second third place tie I
think he can't really make it he's got
kind of guaranteed a survival stage uh
spot but we're looking at a potential 7
and0 run for Wesley who has struggled
this year yep yeah that does not make
any it's wild and I want to just
reiterate that last point you made
because we talk about how Wesley doesn't
beat himself he gets other players to
beat themselves against him because of
the frustrating accurate draws we talk
about but the game against Magnus
yesterday really opened up a door of
what's going to happen here in Toronto
how does he feel and when he's in this
city cuz that's the type of Wesley so
game that should be scaring everybody
when you're taking an attack to Magnus
like that but all right the games have
been wild and uh we're constantly
thinking of ways to make it even more
wild so we talked about Wesley taking it
to Magnus Kaa took it to the roof this
morning Danny Toronto is looking
beautiful this morning as we head into
day four in the CCT finals and we are
flying high with excitement having seen
14 out of 24 matches go to armagon so
far now some players like Wesley so like
Carlson pressure is off for them in the
seventh and final round today but for
other players like hiar and Nakamura
well pressure is very much on he will
need to win to have a chance to go
through well it is actually a little bit
cold Danny so I'm going to come back in
and join the excitement for day four in
the CCT finals back to you
guys I'm not going to lie it did look
pretty cold up there glad you wore a
sweater today yeah I wasn't up there but
I'm just saying in the background I hope
nobody was changing butt naked in those
windows that's the New Yorker and you
right there that's you guys are insane
for that I'm about like what got cameras
up there man KY you're not cold in here
we're all feeling pretty warm yeah it's
pretty warm it's pretty nice you the CH
the chess is about to get hot so on that
note before we get to predictions we're
going to remind you again what is the
format here in Toronto how are we moving
these players from the round robin to
survival to the semis and ultimately to
the championship match this video is
going to break it down for you one more
time the Champions chest T finals are
here eight players who have earned their
Spot Will face off in an epic battle to
determine who will be this year's
champion of champions up for grabs will
be $500,000 in prizes with first place
taking home $200,000 for the victory the
action opens with an eight player round
robin the top two finishers Advance
directly to the semi-finals while the
bottom two are eliminated the remaining
four players will do battle in a double
elimination survival bracket again the
top two players Advance while the bottom
two players will be eliminated the final
four Champions are headed to a single
elimination bracket the winner will be
crowned our champion of
[Music]
champions it's prediction time you know
the drill that means we've got Kaa back
on the desk and for the first time we've
got a full we've got a full Quorum here
four people but before we dive in and
tell you what we think is going to
happen happen in the last round of the
round robin let's show everyone the
results and remind them of where we
currently sit uh because Kaa after a
very strong performance yesterday jumped
out to jumped out to Le yeah look at
that you guys you guys are the experts I
don't know what you guys are what are
you guys up to I got a double double at
least I guess I guess we should have
been asking Levy what he thought at home
cuz Levy you you got a big mountain to
climb right now man I'm undefeated
that's how I like to look at that I'm
undefeated Undisputed
zero predictions wrong and zero predic
right I me that's a percentage you can
you can definitely take home with I
guess so anyway time to jump in we got
to start at the top everyone knows it's
AAR nakamura's chance to win or go home
literally unfortunately for him his fate
isn't even in his hands but we'll talk
more about that later we start with
Hikaru versus Dennis your thoughts
winner go home I mean at this point look
you know he was up last night playing a
lot of Blitz I saw it as soon as I got
back last night I was watching him hey
car's live I was like wow he's playing
chess right now so he's getting it out
I'm going to go with hikaro today he's
got to win yeah I mean plain and simple
you got to go with Hikaru he's the
favorite if you put aside even all of
the negative results of the event yeah
he's still the better rapid player way
more experienced so I'm taking hikaro
yeah I kind of want to disagree there's
so much emotion in play here for hikaro
Nakamura but I just don't see him losing
so I will also say hiar I I agree and
also it's not because he's all the
reasons everyone here said but I also
agree with KY I think the blitz last
night wasn't wasn't even so much an
expression of frustration I think Karo
was playing on chess.com to try to rev
the engine and get going here finally
right all right we move to the next
matchup which as we said also has a big
a big story to say in terms of whether
hiar was still here Magnus Carlson
versus Ali Reser fuia what do you got
there well Magnus uh if even even mag I
have Magnus in my pck but Magnus also
said about the hey I want even play the
world championship if it was if it's not
Ali Resa so I think he always feels that
challenge when he sees Ali Resa I have
to still be the dominant player I know
you are up and coming but I'm still
Magnus I'm going to show you that so I
think it's going to be Magnus okay one
storyline that we've been discussing is
the fact that Magnus Carlson could
literally not show up today now I think
he's contractually obligated to show up
but if he does not show up he stays
second place no matter what
mathematically and only hearu is
eliminated or or lavic right I guess the
winner of that match although I think if
Hikaru is the winner he qualifies and if
lavic doesn't there's some tie breaks
there but uh my pick is Magnus because
as you just said I think he does show up
to play against fuja I think Magnus
wants to win as many matches as possible
so Magnus I am going to disagree with
you guys so two things here so Magnus
has he car's Faith In His Hands he said
yesterday H I asked him how will you
feel if if a car is knocked out well
great basically is what Magnus is saying
I think he wants to be a little bit of a
stist here he wants to take this to
Armageddon and I'm not saying he's going
to lose on purpose but verua is a great
player I think he's going to win it it's
like Harry Potter Deathly Hollow right
in in the in in that room I forgot what
it's called the room of what and then
you know it's like Harry and malo's
about to fall off the thing and then
Harry comes back and and then he grabs
him going SA or not I think heting but I
want to go back to the point the reason
I'm going to take Magnus is because I've
also been playing through the meta here
that unless Magnus literally doesn't
show up which would be the biggest story
controversy talk about a direct
statement to your rival in terms of how
you feel as long as he shows up the
moment Magnus sits at that board if it
was any other format that allowed him to
draw his way if he could just accept
peaceful results and leave Hikaru at
home he might be more likely to do that
save energy there's other reasons he
could use that excuse but the fact that
we will have Armageddon no matter what
and once you're playing Armageddon I
don't see Magnus not being able to let
the competitor in him take over and He
does care about beating Alli reses so
I'm also going to take Magnus there
although I do admit this
is how interesting is this going to be
today we can we can all agree on that so
maybe all right then we have the battle
of the other two Americans we've talked
a lot about Hikaru Fabian Carana takes
on Wesley so will Wesley remain perfect
or you got Fabby well I mean when in in
Toronto it's like flexy Serrano that's
just how you say it that's how it is the
man is just he's a machine the only
other machine besides Magnus where You'
be like half man half what is what is
this player doing it's got to be Wesley
okay all right so I have like two mini
predictions and then an actual
prediction Fabiano Carana just took down
Wesley so in the tournament that they
played in St Louis it was a super
convincing game like a beautiful game
from Fabiano so if we were just picking
chess this was maybe day one or two I
might take Fabiano but I got to root for
the Perfect Score yeah right so I'm just
rooting for Wesley to go 7 and0 against
this field CU that would be the most
gangster performance maybe of 2023 so
I'm picking Wesley all right something
like K Fabian corana did in 2014 seven
in a row so I also believe in the
perfect Wesley Soul score also the fact
that Fabiano knows that after round
seven he's going into um the elimination
the winnner bracket he knows he has
another game coming up so that's why I
think Wesley so will win this one I'm
going to take Fabiano for the same
reason though I think Fabiano was
showing up today with more to play and
he wants to get his engines revved right
away and I think no matter what no
matter how you cut it Wesley would love
to be perfect but I just feel like
Carana is playing with a little bit more
motivation at this point and if this one
goes to Armageddon which I think it has
decent chances to do so I think Fabby
Builds on his success from St Louis and
and remains remains hot against Wesley
all right one more match to predict here
we have Notre Beck versus max B lra
there are actually a little bit of
stakes here for the record to let
everyone know if Maxim bash lrav were to
lose and Dennis loic were to beat Hikaru
and fua were to beat Magnus MV would go
home wow so Maxim is not playing with
house money at this point if he loses he
does have a chance to go home but with
that who you taking which is why
actually I chose mvl for this one of
course norback has been going crazy he
been swinging he been fighting that man
know what he doing norback is not he is
a problem basically and he's not to be
messed with you know to be feared to say
the least but mvo actually is ready to
play he did lose lasic I think he's over
there by now but he understands look I
got to win I'm playing notb and I'm
going to do it today okay yeah I have
mvl I just think he's a little bit more
exper it's a weird matchup like every
other match up today it it feels like
there's something to it the Perfect
Score will Magnus even show up hi Caro's
got a win to to save his chances um but
here I think it's just purely a matchup
of experience and being here before it's
actually a match up of two world
champions mvl is a world Blitz champion
and no deck is a world rapid chion at
some point the only other two players in
the event not named Magnus Carlson by
the way to win that world rapid and
Blitz one or the other but I I just
think mvl to experience I'm picking him
all right I'm just going to base it off
interviews yesterday Notre Beck was so
happy he was just the happiest guy here
so I'm going to pick him in this one
okay I'm also going to take Notre backck
I just think he's been playing better
chess and I think the thing about Maxim
not to say he can't find it at any
moment you never know what these guys
form is temporary and sometimes it shows
up Maxim is also a very shrieky player
and when it's not going well we saw him
lose to Magnus not just losing to Magnus
but he kind of got destroyed I feel like
Maxim is struggling a little bit right
now I think Notre Beck is going to win
this match and really have some momentum
as he takes one of the higher seeds
moving into the survival stage we're not
we're not supposed to argue on this
panel I don't think it but got destroyed
in the Armageddon against Wesley
yesterday with when he had white he also
got he also got I feel like they both
they both had very armd I mean yes it's
you're not you're not wrong and and I
think look there's a reason we do
predictions to sound like experts who we
are not and some got an next and you're
winning I haven't got one wrong so
you're batting with a perfect score as
well all right this has been awesome as
usual fans this is your call to action
to tell us why we're wrong get involved
in chat or social media and make your
predictions but right now it's game time
so we're going to throw it across the
pond to you Oslo Tanya Robert and David
take it
away hey guys uh you're absolutely right
Donnie the chess is about to get hot
today some players are happy some will
be heartbroken eight players four at the
end of today will get eliminated and a
certain Hikaru Nakamura does not have
his Fate In His Hands today Robert
nobody expected hikaro to be at the
bottom of the standings in fact he was
one of the favorites entering the
tournament but right now we see hikaro
fighting for his very life he needs to
beat Dennis lavic maybe some other
Domino need to fall his way as well but
hiar has worked out for him David what
do you think is that at the back of
magnus's head as well maybe we did hear
Magnus with a cheeky comment yesterday
saying he wouldn't be too disappointed
if Hikaru didn't make it but ultimately
I think out there in the studio in
Toronto they are right Magnus is a
sportsman he believes in Fair Play he
will play his best and he'll want to win
his game he doesn't want to lose
momentum and he won't care about the
other results if he plays Hikaru later
in the tournament so be it yeah and of
course the other matchup which is so
critical for the standings is uh Ali
Rosa fuja playing Magnus and also Maxim
vasher lra against Abdus satro from
Maxim so important to win all the games
count this is the final one of the round
robin which will decide who are the two
players who get eliminated and we are
about to get the game started in Toronto
here we go here we go and it is the
highest Stakes match of the round it is
Hikaru Nakamura against Dennis lazic
Hikaru starts with white he starts with
the Kings E4 and The Bishop's opening uh
Landing this bishop out early um a
surprise Robert it looks like a quiet
game to start this one maybe hiar is
going back to his roots because growing
up he played these types of openings all
the time then when you get to the upper
echelons of chest you have to go
Mainline Theory so he's going into a
quiet variation we don't see tension
perhaps he'll thrust his F Pawn forward
and then he'll play into more of a
Vienna style and with that night
developing to E2 we could very well see
that yeah it feels like Karu just wants
to get a position just wants to get a
game
no fireworks he wants to play himself
into form he will need to and uh
remember Dennis lazovic when he has
white is almost unbeatable he hasn't
lost a single game yet with white in
this event so this is the one Hikaru
needs to strike this is the one he needs
to pounce on and uh quick trade of Pawns
there in the center white gets castled
um yeah you mentioned hikaru's youth
this is a position I experienced many
times in my youth but it's R to see it
at the top level uh Dennis lasic though
has come prepared it's a strange Dynamic
right now because it's game one of their
match it wouldn't seem like a must-win
but for Hikaru as you just said Dennis
lazik does not lose with white so you
can be assured that Dennis might just be
able to solidify make a draw in game two
and in Armageddon hi car every single
Armageddon he's played in that's not
going to feel good as you may Venture
into that stage of the match so right
now in game one it seems like a solid
setup for Black Hikaru is the one on the
clock David I have to say I think that
Dennis should not be unhappy about how
this opening is developed yeah I think
Hikaru would have been hoping for a
surprise using a weapon he hasn't
dabbled in too much of late but Dennis
lavic hasn't blinked hasn't flinched
he's reacted really nicely here that
trade of Pawns in the center means that
black has actually more space in the
middle of the board and uh okay asking a
question now of Black's start squ Bishop
whether Dennis trades off for wh Knight
on C3 whether he Retreats I think he's
in good shape and uh yeah great start
for the youngster Hikaru looking pretty
chilled for now but I'm sure we'll see
him Focus as the stakes get higher as
the game wears on and for he can take
that Knight with his Bishop I would not
do that because you don't want to create
imbalances unnecessarily that's what
hiar wants he wants an position where he
can play for those tactics for
uncomfortable unknown position for
Dennis La I would Retreat the bishop
right back in front of the king your
setup is really healthy it's solid
there's nothing even under attack so I
think that he should Retreat rather than
capture yeah big big decision here uh
depends on his Ambitions we're about to
see a decision from Dennis lavic he
follows your advice Robert always a good
sign and uh yeah healthy position we
should mention Hikaru hasn't played that
badly in uh normal time as we say it's
just the Armageddon that's let him down
um so right now he should still take
some confidence and uh okay quick trade
of Pawns and motoring forward f for
forward he's going on the attack hikara
Nakamura and I remember a game between
denil dubov and hikara where dubov had
the white side of a position like this
and won a really nice game against
Hikaru and you said that Hikaru has not
done badly in the two game match is it's
Armageddon where his struggles been in
fact Dennis lazic has gained the most
Fay rapid rating points in this hi car
has gained the second most behind him so
that's a surprising stat I'm sure for
the audience you got a surprising result
or maybe not such a surprising result
Wesley so and Fabiano Carana and their
first game in a draw I'm going to admit
this I'm expecting them to just go
straight for the Armageddon and go into
the sudden death we will keep an eye on
what they do but of course now Hikaru
Nakamura has got one eye on his game and
the other one on another game Magnus
Carlson with the white pieces taking on
Ali RZA fuja and look at that we've got
a position where Kings have castled on
opposite sides that's already a
reflection of uh the mindset the two
players are coming in we're going to
have fireworks on the board and in these
positions it's often about who gets the
central break in is black able to strike
with E5 first or does white get a
successful E4 going on who gets it in I
must say Tanya this one feels like
Magnus is playing fast and loci he's
taking massive risks castling Queen side
just on the last turn is reckless um I'm
not a big fan but it means that Magnus
is Out For Blood he wants to go for
Glory despite the wipe of the eyes there
looking a bit tired to start this game
and okay fuja just quietly plays a pawn
move and this means that probably white
is the first to strike Tanya I thought
black should be aggressively
energetically trying to throw pawns
towards the white king breaking the
center one of those ideas this one feels
slow this one feels yeah a bit too
tentative I like Tanya's suggestion of
black pushing the Kings Pawn forward one
now I think white should do that because
you get this Dynamic where black will be
cramped and typically when you have a
cramp position you want to trade a bunch
of pieces that light Square Bishop on C8
that is not going to be a good piece for
the rest of the game unless black can
someh push more pawns and initiate some
trades I really like this position from
Magnus Carlson he strikes first and now
aliv Za fua he doesn't have an attack on
the queen side he made later after worry
about his own King yeah especially in
the position with uh these positions
with opposite side castling as we saw
Magnus here going to the long side it's
all a race it's always about time you
cannot waste a single move so uh just to
point out Tanya's ideas E5 C5 even
taking on this Square throwing these
queenside pawns forward so many options
A6 feels so I want to say complacent it
feels like ala thinks he has all the
time in the world but magnus's last move
reminds him that actually big threat on
the board Pawn coming to E5 with a nasty
Fork on two black pieces and just to
show the outcome of what we think is
about to happen um it is all about this
problem child the bishop on C8 and also
reminder of Black's kingside no
Defenders around there big checkmating
threats on the cards Whit King is
actually for now maybe the safer of the
two uh so yeah just one move it looks
like not too much has happened but
actually dramatic stuff in favor of the
world number one and sometimes it's
these kind of defining moments that when
you look back you understand that you
made a move like A6 and this uh just
made everything go your opponent's way
and it's Ali rzan now who does respond
with a central break but just one move
before had he done the same it would
have been initiative Ali Resa but now
we've got this massive tension on the
board so many pawns can be traded off
the center it's a big decision which one
would you go for well I like White's
position I would probably take with the
E4 Pawn on D5 but I want to give a quick
shout out to Mickey Adams who recently
won the London chess classic and it's
not just about that success going
through his games over the years I was
wondering where did did his opponents
even go wrong where were the mistakes
and it's those small moves like that
black pawn push ala pushing Spa to A6
before it's not doing things in the
needed moment and I think Mickey Adams
he has made a whole career punishing
people for those hesitant decisions I
think Magnus he was first to pounce in
the center now it's about to explode but
I do think he's happy that he can start
the captures yeah he will start the
captures white has three Central porns
black has two often a good sign as well
fua he's pretty much sacrificing a porn
as far as I can see white will have a
bit more control white is quicker but
lines will open up meaning that White's
King may be exposed so an important
decision
meanwhile okay for a second I got
excited I saw an evaluation bar shoot
off in the Nakamura against lazic game
but uh no it was uh just the engine
trying to get a handle on that one um
yeah key moment for Magnus Carson
central face off Central pressure and uh
I think he should be capturing as you
say Robert right now you don't want to
maintain the tension too long uh too
much longer one big big problem for
aliisa is that Bishop on C8 it's stuck
behind a knight if you could put a rook
on the C file a rook barreling down an
open Line towards a queen and king that
usually is a recipe for success and on
the other hand you look at magnus's Rook
on D1 there are a lot of piece in the
defile but there's going to be some
tactical melee in the center here and I
think that Rook is perfectly placed
against a black queen down the file okay
we do see a trade in the center there
Magnus just wiping some dust off the
board very calmly and uh yeah this one
we will come back to you yeah we will
come back to this one and now for Magnus
Carlson it doesn't matter the result of
this match for ala of course it matters
a lot the other player who secured a
spot in the survival stage is nbec Abdus
satro but he's fighting against Maxim
vasher graph who's got everything on the
line and the current position that we
have to me it looks that NC has
channeled his inner Alpha zero the H
Pawn has landed on H6 so making sure
that Black's King side is quite cramped
up the king will be facing a longtime
back rank threats there are weaknesses
along the dark Square good full central
control the activity of the pieces I'm
liking Abdu sat's position here I can
tell Tanya you uh you've played this
type of thing before this type of idea
um and this is also the downside Maxi
Vash lra we've talked about it in the
past less so in the last 12 months but
he's extremely predictable he's loyal to
his first love the grunfeld defense this
opening but it means his opponents can
prepare specifically prepare deeply and
look at this the evaluation bar shooting
up in White's favor after this last move
we're at move 18 but nobec already has a
3 four minute time Advantage he has a
fantastic position Black's Bishop in the
corner on h8 is soon going to be locked
out in any middle game end game um even
trading off the Queens here it looks
fantastic for white Pawn Center control
and look at the speed with which he's
playing nck Just fantastic fantastic
confidence here yeah but the players
they don't get the evaluation bar so
they don't know that it's this much
better for white the big problem is that
Bishop that's next to the king it could
get locked back there and you may think
there's no attack there no queens that
pawn on H6 it's a thorn in Black side
because they're all sorts of back ranked
Checkmate ideas and I would start maybe
with the move Bishop to G5 here I think
you would attack this Rook on d8 and
there are going to be some tactics watch
out for that final rank white could push
that P up to E5 next to really shut that
Bishop in the corner and I feel like
you're having all the fun as nck you
have to time things correctly but this
position just looks very Pleasant for
white yeah this looks strategically
almost winning maybe we even add uh kind
of kicking back this night first of all
and now a to E5 and I mean this bishop
is never going to move for the rest of
the game imagine a white knight somehow
sneaking in as well so many weaknesses
in the black Camp not too many positives
to speak of Maxim vasra in big big
trouble big trouble and if Maxim vasra
loses this match to nbec and Dennis La
wins his match against tar Nakamura
there is a situation in which Maxim
could be the one who gets eliminated so
Maxim at the back of his mind is
thinking about this other game that we
are going to bring up now Dennis lawick
with the black pieces so much on the
line at stake for both these players and
you look at the position the bishop
there that Dennis has pieces centralized
the Rooks about to line up on those
Central lines to me it looks like Dennis
should be happy pleased with the opening
outcome you said so much on the line and
there's so much on the Eline look at
that three minor pieces in a row but the
Knight on E5 perfectly situated defended
by a and the Queen Bishop F4 it's a good
developing move it doesn't threaten
anything I think that Dennis should be
really happy with his position and even
more so with his clock management Dennis
has struggled with the black pieces when
he's been the one in time trouble right
now he actually has a lead on the clock
his position is healthy his King is safe
David I don't know about you but I feel
like it's hard for me to see where he's
going to go wrong yeah uh Hikaru is I
think pretty much at this point forced
to try and play a long game
strategically black is doing great black
has the bishop pair we might well see
Hikaru chop off that black knight in the
center next turn at least one positive
uh in the end game with black having a
isolated Pawn in the center I think he
has to try it he has to hope that two
white Knights can face off against the
two black bishops but objectively I
think uh we're all pretty much in favor
here of lazovic position um Nakamura
yeah just yet to find that form still a
draw not the worst result of course it's
not drastic right now but okay he throws
his Knight in the center first um but
yeah in terms of the starts this game
great for black you know that hikaro
really wants to take this game he
doesn't want to chance it in Armageddon
Armageddon has been his worst enemy he's
0 out of four all with the black pieces
meanwhile Dennis lavic he won a match in
Armageddon against Maxim Vash have a
very nicely played game with the white
pieces here for Dennis just keep
everything under control keep steady in
the clock and I just don't even see a
threat in the near future that white can
go after and perhaps aaru is trying to
create those threats on the king side
looking at a move with that Queen
landing on either the G3 square or the
H4 Square I like G3 more feels a lot
safer and The Rook from aan can join the
attack on that Central File eventually
threats of the bishop Landing up on 86
he's hinting at a development like that
is this something that Dennis needs to
keep in mind to start thinking about
kingside safety yeah it's definitely
possible and uh actually I did find one
way to blunder as Dennis lavic uh loose
pieces drop off and blacks Bishop on E6
is a bit loose I was trying to reot that
I was wondering the best Square for it I
was thinking actually maybe park it on
C6 it's a beautiful diagonal and then I
realized after Bishop to D7 whoops I've
blundered The Black Queen which has no
safe squares the queen would be trapped
in the center of the board so I would
have blundered this one away against
Nakamura it does show there are traps
there are pitfalls that need to be
avoided uh maybe the bishop can somehow
come over to this Square on G6 um just
to show Tanya's idea there are always
threats against the black king on the G
file so maybe just parking the bishop
back I'm not sure whether you do it
immediately on G6 would at least keep
things nice and safe offer some
stability um this might be my uh my
recommendation but certainly not oneway
traffic um definitely black at the
moment has one or two things to answer
before uh kind of claiming that Bishop
pan Advantage long time Dennis is
committing a lot of time to this moment
and Bishop D7 that Bishop E3 there that
was a queen trap that nobody saw coming
but that goes to show there are pitfalls
in a position that looks very Placid so
this is a situation for Dennis he needs
to improve this location of his Bishop I
like your Bishop F5 we'll see where he
goes but right now he is down about 2
minutes on the clock and that's been his
really big problem in some of these
games of the black pieces is the clock
yeah he's his only Achilles heel he's
been so impressive Dennis lck it's just
with black in those end games when he
has no time and that's the one thing he
has to avoid Nakamura will have been
watching those games with interest and
uh he will be aiming for that a bit
later in the game so the quality of his
play has been so high but what you're
mentioning right now about his nerves
undertime pressure and is that something
that comes with experience it definitely
does the more Armageddon matches you get
into just the more games you play
overall against the elite of the elite
chess players you start to gain
confidence you start to uh just gain
that much needed practical experience of
how do I handle myself in these critical
moments and Dennis he's acquitted
himself quite nicely throughout this uh
tournament thus far but he's got a lot
on the line if he wins this match he
could still make it out of relegation to
elimin ation territory I should say and
fight for the survival stage yeah we've
been talking so much about Nakamura
getting himself out of trouble surviving
Clinging On to uh his participation in
the tournament but Dennis lazovic to
kind of reach this point in the
tournament to still have a chance that's
an achievement in itself should be
celebrated he should take a lot of
confidence but of course he's not even
going to be thinking about that he wants
more he wants to stay in Toronto and uh
yeah a win for him in this match as
unlikely as it may have seemed before
the event uh yeah it would save him
potentially um if results go his way so
10 T position but 3 and a half minutes
in the tank does show that maybe the
nerves are starting to creep in right
now it is a t position and we're getting
help from Toronto as Levy is with Fabby
talking about all the action that's
happening on the
board thank you Tanya yes I'm here with
fabbi on o Carana Fabby what went into
the decision to draw with Wesley in
about 5 minutes well I think it was less
than 5 minutes but I really wanted to
talk to you love that's why really yeah
that's the that's the reason I you
wanted to talk to me about my prediction
oh well we can we can talk about that
later I don't want to call you out on
air but yeah yeah I predicted that that
well I didn't predict okay listen in my
defense my lawyer is like standing on
the other side of the camera I just I'm
rooting for a 7 and0 you know what it's
like to go 7 and0 True uh we don't want
to reminisce here the whole time about
2014 but that was pretty badass uh how's
the experience been in Toronto so far
this year it's been nice you know I last
year I was here doing the commentary and
it's nice to be on the other side of
things cuz I I I like to compete I like
to to play like to yeah yeah I just you
were here the whole time and we had you
commentating yeah yeah which was fun it
was a nice experience but I I do prefer
to be on the other side of things um I
mean it's a great format uh it's it's
very competitive there's no draws you
you either win or or you lose you go
home quickly if you don't play well not
you um well hopefully not but I'm still
I'm still in danger today let's say can
I ask you how your thoughts on things
like the survival stage where like okay
you make third through six but you don't
Auto qualify for anything you have to
fight for your life chess is always
playing now with these different types
of formats what do you what do you think
about all that well I mean at the end of
the day there's going to be one winner
and everyone else will be either a
little disappointed or perhaps a lot
disappointed and I think that's that's a
good thing that you have to fight for
for one spot I mean I you know I I grew
up with the well first with the Swiss
format but then very often with the
round robin format which uh is what
chess is usually accustomed to and I
don't think that there's anything wrong
with that but uh it also has its critics
for uh you know perhaps producing too
much safe play or or not enough
combativeness or players who are perhaps
just looking for uh the best Equity that
they have maybe that includes taking a
draw and here there's there's nothing
else besides winning or losing so um
yeah every match produces a winner yeah
speaking of how you feeling about uh
hikaro versus lvic hikaro overall the
performance is shocking I would imagine
to you who has played hikaro for I don't
know 10 or 15 years at this point but
also this match situation where he has
to beat lavic and then rely on Magnus to
beat alza yeah well I think I might have
played Hikaru for even longer than that
because we grew up in New York together
and okay he's a bit older than me but we
were just kids when we first played the
first time uh of course yeah Hikaru uh
this year has been um like clearly top
three in the world in terms of
performance so to see him in bad form
like this it's it's a surprise but it
does happen we we've all been there
you're in very good form or you're in
very bad form you don't know exactly why
um he still has a chance he's playing
really poorly I have to say uh by his
standards but also in general clip that
uh well I I I think he would agree with
this also I I mean it's just he he's in
bad shape he's really not playing well I
felt it yesterday even though the match
was close I still feel like in the
Armageddon he he was just not his usual
self whatsoever and he still has a
chance that's a good thing for him that
he just has to win this match and then
Ali Reza has to has to lose has to
speaking of I mean I think we're going
to we've we've got up on the screen I
mean both games are very tense we have
both games up any impressions of the
Magnus game that we're looking at here
well Magnus in the opening was playing a
bit fast and loose we have to say long
castle in the uh in some sort of
setup um very unusual
it's it kind of worked out okay for him
like he didn't get a bad position but
okay his King is always going to be in
some sort of danger so for ala it's it's
a pretty ideal scenario because if he
wins then he's a big favorite to to win
this match and normally at the start of
the match we would consider him at least
somewhat of an underdog maybe not a huge
Underdog but definitely the two matches
that hearu needs to go his way um there
is a favorite and it's Magnus and Hikaru
right so he can at least look to that
for confidence but um Magnus is is not
trying to play it very cautiously he's
he's definitely going for a full-fledged
fight last question one word answer this
type of position between Magnus and fuja
whose style does it
favor
you know I it's more than one word Fabby
you give me give me Al let's Okay Ali
Reza you heard it right here from the
man himself Fabiano Carana I think we're
going to be throwing it back to alsoo
thank you Fabby thanks thanks thanks
guys fast and lose is Fab's verdict on
magnus's opening approach David called
it a reckless earlier on uh and we see
the SE file that Fabby was talking about
will always give f fja the upper hand on
getting to the king first but now that
Magnus has managed to create this hook
on the king side fuja has made the move
86 there are also ideas of trying to
push the gep PA eventually down the boat
but how difficult is that to actually
achieve well it's one of these funny
positions where white is actually up a
pawn if we do some quick counting that
D5 Pawn that's an extra one but perhaps
White's best option will be to pick up
that pawn and throw it off the board to
open up the file for The Rook so this
was a sacrifice from aliisa when he to
strike back in the center I do agree
with fabbi that this position is very
much up Ali raza's wheelhouse it's his
style completely but he's down a pawn so
he needs to prove that he has sufficient
compensation he's down a pawn he's got
half the amount of time as Magnus it
does feel like Alara it is his type of
position he normally thrives uh when
it's a bit imbalanced where he can start
kind of attacking the opponent's king
without too much worry but right now I
do worry that he's uh been a bit
negative with his time usage and okay a
big decision Tanya you mention mentioned
throwing the white G Pawn off the board
up the board you don't even need to
anymore you've opened up the G file Al
has helped you open up the G file and
okay he's got some ideas of his own
White's knight uh the remaining Knight
now is pinned but I mean it's basically
someone's going to Checkmate someone
it's just about who gets there first um
what do we think of this I must admit
I'm surprised by this last decision it's
complicated here because both players
have pinned Knights that Bishop on H4 is
pinning the Knight to the queen that
Knight on C3 is pinned because of that
Rook on C8 and one really big question
is how big of a threat is Bishop takes
Knight on C3 right now I don't think
it's a game Ender and if I'm white maybe
I try to distract that Bishop either by
bringing a rook to E1 to attack it
directly or throwing away a pawn with
Pawn F4 I don't care about those double
pawns but I'm going to force the issue I
see the Eva bar doesn't react suggesting
my mooves isn't so bad but I'm trying to
force Ali to make a big decision do I
restore material quality by taking the
pawn or do I take the Knight to shatter
the structure in front of the white king
yeah and uh if you do take the Knight
you mentioned it might not be such a
threat because W King does have a safe
hiding spot uh in the corner and for now
due to the fact this is pinned uh Black
Knight cannot come and grab the vital D5
Pawn he goes for the other option you
mentioned Robert so same idea uh he's
just asking a decision of this bishop
and uh in Practical terms I like the
fact Magnus played that quickly he's
saying okay onus is on you it's your
decision burn more time on the clock
please and uh still anyone's game now
and the one thing you never want to do
is capture that H Bond besides the fact
that you open additional files you also
probably end up getting that Bishop in
some trouble and allowing white to
really break through on the king side
and I could understand the hesitation
that uh Fabby had when he was talking
about the style of the position because
Magnus is such a universal player but I
really want to get straight to this one
we've been talking about Dennis lazic
style positional strategic technical
this is none of that he's going for
blood hair I've said it every single day
we talk about these matches almost as if
Dennis laic doesn't exist is this he's
just the the player that maybe someone
will beat or otherwise they might go to
Armageddon Dennis lvic he means serious
business he is a rising star just 17
years old and in this position he says
take my Pawn on A7 I don't care about
that pawn over there I sacrifice that
for an attack and that white king it
doesn't really have many pieces
shielding it that G5 Pawn may go down to
G4 Rumble all the way to G3 there could
be checkm attacks soon to meet the white
king yeah this is scary and Hikaru is
going for something that normally I
would say don't try it at home this is
too risky uh disconnecting your queen so
far from your own King means that any
attack uh against his majesty there in
the corner might just be decisive and
the queen is simply offside I don't yeah
I don't see why Hikaru is doing this
it's not a must-win situation yet but it
feels like he's going all in this is a
very critical position and we're going
to Deep dive into it but while Hikaru is
having think David let's just use a
couple of seconds to actually do a quick
action replay play to see how we got
here because Dennis has sacrificed the
pawn for all the initiative on the king
side how did he manage to create this
yeah we lost left the position around
here after a trade of dark Square
Bishops an attack now against this white
knight forc the Knight to retreat and
Dennis said okay f for forward uh Hikaru
threw his F Pawn forward earlier now it
is lavic pushing on the side he's
stronger black has three pawns on the
king side white only has two White's
King lacking a bit of shelter therefore
White's Queen dropped back and now the
Black Knight coming in the dream square
is an out post on E3 anchored supported
by a pawn and Hikaru said okay after
offering this night trade after it was
rejected why not you might as well
suffer for something he went and took
this Pawn but this Pawn is irrelevant
Until the End Game who cares if white
has a four versus two majority on the
queen side and uh look at this last move
Pawn to G5 yeah this is just so scary
tan you mentioned a threat just to throw
this Pawn down the board and I mean I
don't see any natural moves for white
that is the problem if for example you
put a knight on an outpost in the center
what could be more natural the pawn
simply steps forward again and here
there's all I mean here I blunder a pawn
but here there's all sorts of tactics
the black queen is coming in the black
porn is coming forward White's King is
wow we're heading in this direction
actually wh's King I was going to say
it's not long for this world yeah this
looks very pleasant for Dennis and if
colors were reversed if hikaro had the
black pieces we'd all be talking about
oh hikaro is going to crush him now
hikaro is a tenous resourceful Defender
he instead of going back jumps forward
though that Knight it might get trapped
over there if the bishop slides out of
the way and that pawn push goes to H6
your knight no longer has any free
squares to go to give me that piece so
Bishop D5 it might induce C4 we're
getting really into some concrete lines
here Bishop takes Knight on e4 Knight
takes Knight on e4 in this kind of
circumstance will the Attack lead to a
Checkmate for black or will white say ha
I'm still up upon Pawn you haven't
proven anything yeah and I think Dennis
he's about to make a decision he might
even fall back with the bishop because
the night that you pointed out is
actually very precarious he goes for the
idea of Bishop D5 Hikaru has to push the
C Pawn to force a trade on e4 he's
reaching out for this one if Dennis wins
this I mean we're looking at a very big
scenario of him having a real shoted
qualification massive opportunity for
Dennis lazic he won't get a better
position than this against Hikaru with
black and uh yeah we have reached the
position we did predict uh from a while
off and now the big question is which
Pawn to push you have to thow something
towards the black uh towards the white
king do you lift your Rook across go for
the king this direction so many tempting
moves but the window of opportunity is
closing because White's Queen will soon
come back to the center combined with
her Knight he needs to strike Now or
Never Dennis one defensive resource that
hiar might rely let's say you have Queen
H4 just something like that white May
sacrifice The Exchange Rook takes Pawn
allowing your Rook to be captured but
that Queen which is offside now comes
back to the center Queen takes Knight on
E3 suddenly white has two pawns and a
knight for a rook that's an even
material balance the position remains
chaotic but this could be hikaru's best
chance to survive only chance yeah and
this is very likely to happen but Dennis
his clock is ticking down and now
playing on Instinct in a position that's
full of calculation full of tricks and
traps that's going to be a hurdle that's
going to be a tough one he needs to
speed up Hikaru looking pretty confident
still uh despite the fact his position
is hanging by a thread and I think that
confidence stems from the situation in
the clock when you got seconds on to
play with it becomes about intuition but
this is a position that has to be based
on calculation you have to figure out
the resources like the one that you
pointed out where white sacrifices The
Rook gives up material but neutralizes
the pressure and Dennis needs to make a
move he does it he does make a committal
choice of pushing the gep pa the evalar
doesn't like it Hikaru adjusts pieces
but it does pose direct questions of how
do you respond on the king side does
white have time to actually capture this
G3 Pawn I think the answer is no if
White's Kings shelter disappears The
Black Queen will come in uh within the
next few moves there will be a Checkmate
I think we have to show this there might
only be one or two moves to survive here
for Hikaru and it might be based on what
Robert mentioned a sacrifice of The Rook
because uh right now PA takes Pawn would
backfire seriously black simply
recaptures and who cares after for
example uh a rook trade if the Knight
drops because it's all about the black
queen coming in and delivering the kiss
of death this would end in a nasty
Checkmate the queen pawn and Rook
cutting off the king Escape would be
decisive so uh right now Hikaru has to
go for that the other the idea we
mentioned earlier Rook takes pawn and
coming back with his Queen when it's
anyone's game he has two pawns maybe
even a third Pawn in the near future
because this is a double attack uh let's
check back in Dennis he's going for the
attack but Hikaru should be able to fend
it
off wow big moment and big moment here
Magnus Carlson has he just made a big
blunder I see the evaluation bar I see
the bishop on E5 is hanging Black's
Knight on D5 cannot be picked up White's
King looks absolutely in the open
White's Pawn structure destroyed big
Advantage ala winning Advantage for alza
this actually reminds me of the game
where Fabby had the white pieces against
Magnus where some of his pieces were up
in that corner and others were over here
that's what's happening there is not a
coordination no Harmony between White's
pieces the king is open and then Knight
on D5 it looks loose looks like going be
captured two different ways but you
can't get away with it because your Rook
on E1 is in sight of the queen on A5 and
you can't stick with the pawn cuz your
queen is lost Magnus knows he's in
trouble he's shaking his head he knows
that this has gone all down and do you
think this comes down to that Reckless
opening play that you were talking about
earlier David yeah it's uh who the style
of position favors and that is Alara
Magnus did have an advantage as recently
as two three moves ago maybe even a
decisive Advantage but he wasn't
comfortable you can tell that on the
clock times Magnus down to just a few
seconds now and uh he did play a tactic
in the wrong order now dropping back
with his Bishop this was an erroneous
check actually the black kings safer in
the corner and uh suddenly fuja look at
the evaluation bar he has a winning move
but I will say we have the evaluation
bar it's winning for black objectively
it doesn't look that clear there is no
immediate knockout I think some of the
more obvious choices have some counters
for example if the Knight jumps forward
leaping into White's position I think
that Bishop on E5 which is under attack
in multiple ways it will slide back to
create a pin and then we will have some
Chaos on the board so I do think that
there's a lot more in this position that
meets the eye oh this would be a yeah
really nice resource easy to Miss Robert
this pin allowing a queen trade and
white would actually be doing pretty
well in the end game if Queens disappear
so black has to go for checkmate I'm not
sure what that entails but it's all
about keeping pieces on and going for
the white king and now aliar under a
minute on the clock is he also
considering just grabbing that Bishop on
E5 because notice and he doesn't do it
he goes for a more direct line he hits
the queen we see the evalar shoot up has
Ali Roa lost all his Advantage it looks
that way suddenly white with this
Counterattack against the loose black
queen is keeping things together no time
to take this white Rook on D1 because
the queen tension here and maybe he was
relying upon a check but now the white
Bishop saves itself and uh in this
position notice how this black Bishop
lacking squares white Bishop on the long
diagonal targeting the black king
suddenly things are turning suddenly
it's chaos yet again and both players
under 20 seconds now wow the stakes are
high in all of these games yes and it
looks like Magnus Carlson is out of big
trouble for now so we will check in with
Hikaru Nakamura who was also in trouble
and Hikaru has taken the decision that
you were pointing at he has sacrificed
his exchange picked up that big big
stallion on E3 but Dennis doubling up on
the f file there's a big threat a back
rank mate back rank mate uh Hikaru has
avoided that he's giving the white king
some breathing space one safe Square now
so it's Queen and Rook versus queen and
Knight but white has three extra pawns
big threat of Checkmate Black's Queen
coming to the H file CaRu stops that any
check to the white king will be deadly
but for now it's impossible I think
Hikaru actually is uh survived the worst
he definitely has survived the worst and
Dennis he keeps sliding his pieces in
ways that confuse the dgt board but he
is not confused he brings his Rook back
he's trying to help Shield his King that
Rook can slide over with the check I
think that with Black's pieces so nicely
centralized he's doing fine but white
does have it appears three pawns and a
night for a rook it's actually extra
material for white extra material for
white and big moment Hikaru is in check
now if he brings his King back to the H
file we might see the position almost
repeat itself Dennis lavic trying to ask
for this repetition now but Hikaru says
no draw for you he doesn't put his King
back on G1 repeating the position he's
pushing forward going for Black's Rook
there pushing again night check
threatened wow Hikaru showing his
ambition and I do like White's position
White's Knight is just as strong as the
black Rook but that Rook if it slides
forward and gets to the AG file there
could still be checkm inting ideas or if
you get that Rook to the final rank
Dennis giving check he probably will
bring his Queen back it feels hard for
denn to lose just because his King is
quite safe the king is safe but Hikaru
Nakamura cannot be feeling safe because
aliar fuja takes down Magnus cson in
their game one Hikaru has to win this
match to keep his Road in Toronto going
this is a big moment he is getting
ambitious he does feel the momentum has
shifted but is it going to be enough the
Knight with and three pawns versus The
Rook that's the big question Hikaru
keeps avoiding these rep repetitions
keeps avoiding the draw but you cannot
push too hard that's happened to aaru so
many times already this tournament he's
pushed for a win when the pos position
demands safety and he's got to be
careful now he's going for an attack
against the black king White Queen
trying to come up to the H6 Square to
deliver a check Dennis guards some
squares nice defensive move the black
king will actually hide safely in the
corner and Hikaru comes back with his
Queen this is so tense it feels like
someone is about to make a mistake but
Hikaru for now keeping control the white
king needs to move both players down to
about 5 seconds so a blunder could
happen at any turn here's checks against
the white king it's only a single check
you can't get that rook in the game
quickly enough but I like how Dennis he
backtracks he Retreats he knows he needs
to keep his King shelter offering the
trade of Queens as well white has a lot
of Pawns so uh trading the Queens should
be fine but the Rook versus the Knight
still that's the main Dynamic yeah and
that Knight on e4 is worth that Rook it
is taking away so many key squares
defending that G5 Pawn Black's Rook
struggling to create counter plate to
create threats against White pawns and
it's the Knight that jumps forward picks
up the B7 Pawn the queenside pawns are
going to start marching up the board
right now this practically has to be
Advantage Hikaru definitely an advantage
for Hikaru without the Queens on the
board but the good news for Dennis is
that the white king can't easily join
the action because that G3 Pawn if that
one is given up black still has a rook
Pawn to create as a passer so here comes
Dennis's King into the center but
apparently that was a mistake wow the
black king he walks into a night Fork oh
my my goodness and Dennis was defending
so well but Hikaru he kept up the
pressure oh my God and Hikaru gets the
dub in Ali Raa wins against Magnus
Hikaru beats Dennis
lavic what an end to that game and
there's one more still on as Abdu satov
is fighting against Maxim vagra opposite
color Bishop a repetition Abdu satov
declines yeah here white is a pawn to
the good but the problem is with
opposite color Bishops the drawish
tendency is High black if he can trade
off enough pawns if he can prevent white
from creating another pass Pawn should
be safe here and I just don't think it's
quite enough actually it's level pawns
now and uh yeah this one should be a
fortress for black still some care
needed but Maxi Vash gra is going to
guide this game towards safety he's been
in trouble the whole time but Abdu stov
unable to land the killer blow no
durbeck would need to teleport his King
from D4 all the way over to G7 win that
H7 Pawn not going to happen you see the
coordination of blacks pieces cutting
off the the white king from moving
forward the king and Bishop do a perfect
job together opposite colored Bishops
mean you can't contest it it looks like
it should be a solid draw here for
maxim um n back keeps trying but it's
not going to be enough the white Bishop
stops the apron from advancing Black's
King and Bishop enough and there we see
handshakes their first battle ends in a
draw a relief for maxim Vash lra but
there's no relief for Hikaru Nakamura if
Ali Resa draws the next game against
against Magnus Carlson it's the end of
the road for Hikaru while Maxim's
chances still stay alive there is of
course a big game two coming up what a
dramatic round one Robert yeah so much
has been said about magnus's accuracy
his lack of blunders pretty sure he
blundered pretty badly and it couldn't
have come at a worse time for Hikaru
Nakamura because Hikaru he needs to win
his match and get some help he's winning
his match but not getting the help and
this is where we are one more the final
game rapid game of the round robin is
coming up Dennis lvic has to win to
force an Armageddon weso Fabiano Carana
I think this one's going straight into
armag we can expect a second Quick Draw
between these two Ali Resa fuja with the
black pieces takes down Magnus Carlson
in a crazy crazy game meanwhile Abdus
satra Maxim Vash lrav also ends
peacefully David what was the stand out
moment out of all the action that we
witnessed well one of the standout
moments was that final move with
Nakamura and lavic the night fork
blundered in the end by lavic but we
didn't see the end to Carlson against
fuja so I'm going to show you that right
now it was a blunder from Magnus Carlson
very
uncharacteristic and uh it was actually
after he'd survived a really difficult
position he'd got the Queens off white
here has an extra Pawn white also has
the bishop pair uh active Rooks but
Magnus Carlson retreated his Bishop to
D3 this was a mistake because the bishop
can simply be captured and at the very
end black brings his Rook across too
much pressure now on this pinned Bishop
it fell off the board and Magnus very
shortly resigned instead if Magnus had
played a move like Rook B7 guarding
against that idea covering the B file
then likely Magnus would have won and
Hikaru would have been much safer in the
tournament this is based on the fact
that if the black move uh black Rook
moves away then a nasty check another
check and we would have seen a back rank
check Magnus Carson went from winning to
losing in one move we left right as that
was happening and for Ali Rea fuja it's
how success is happens when you are
putting pressure on the clock there's
pressure on the king there's pressure on
the clock and we typically think of
magnus's King when the King was toppled
by Ala fuja what a game and that means
that alira needs only a draw to secure
his chances and ruin hikaru's dreams of
staying in the tournament while the
heavyweights fight it out we've got some
really Co cool lightweight posters for
you guys to decorate your life with
these incredible incredible displates
from uh chess.com loving the one in the
middle and you are getting a very cool
33% discount by using the code chess on
display.com chess that's where you can
find all of these cool very cool
displayes for now we're going to go into
a very short break but on the other side
we've got Hikaru Nakamura fighting for
his tournament life as he faces danis
lavic his fate not in His Hands
subscribers stay with us there's some
cool behind the scenes just for
[Music]
you everyone has a lucky mascot right
you guys or just me I don't know no just
you luck mascot David um I I don't have
it here with me in Norway actually but I
have a Pikachu like a big Pikachu that
it's been at the end of my bed uh in
England for like 15 years it's a nice be
admitting these things Pokemon fan yeah
Pikachu I Choose You Pikachu uh no what
even I'm not that
nerdy how about a chess set with only
Pokémons that would be super cool who
would be the king and the queen
Professor Oak Professor Oak would be uh
would you be the
king Misty would be my
queen anyway all right back to the
chest what is your favorite
Pokemon
Psyduck oh okay with me y good one
Magnus
[Music]
now can Hikaru hold the draw that's the
question now Fabiano cannot lose this
game he's a por up 10 seconds D yeah two
pawns up wow but a horrible Pond
structure yeah but it's all about the
white dwn if he keeps the Central Pawn
alive he
might oh my God you said they don't
blender checkman in one and car
immediately does your commentator's
curse a one Checkmate and that is going
to cause Hikaru the whole
match Aragon is coming up and let's
reveal the bids from hikaro and Magnus
look at
Hikaru has bid 8 minutes and 59 seconds
beaten by 1 second Magnus Carlson biding
8 minutes and 58 seconds and this is
hikaru's reaction when that bid came
in it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
thing
a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
CCL spring 2024 registrations are now
open register your school to stake your
claim at the
$25,000 price fund visit our website
goes.com for more
information and this is where it's
happening the skies are gray the action
is black and white the big question what
is going on in Magnus colson's mind
right now and we've got Kaa on the
ground asking the big
question eventually a lost four mnus
crws but what a game what did you think
about that yeah obviously it was too
complicated
at least for me to play with so little
time um I think I was doing well for
quite a while and then I um
miscalculated and I was definitely worse
to
losing uh but then it turned around
again and I was better but we both have
very little time and then I just
panicked with a few seconds uh left so
that was yeah that was a bit unfortunate
for sure what do you think about ali
reso's play in this game um
no I think he plays like he often does
uncom
uncompromising chess Not always
completely correct but uh very very
challenging um and um yeah I mean that's
that's the way he um that's the way he
placs in in general I think many people
wondering your motivation your uh
mentality heading into this match with
ala definitely um ambition in the start
of the game there can you sort of reveal
to us what is your
um mentality in this match yeah I asked
Peter for advice before the round like
what should I do in such a situation and
uh he said that uh he recently heard
from Ramesh that uh what you should do
um in general is to challenge yourself
do what makes you um the most
uncomfortable and I thought the most
uncomfortable I could be was playing a
very sharp position against Alesa so I
thought that would be very um very
useful training for me very cool and
game two will be must win to take it to
um to Armageddon What can we expect um I
mean I'll try to I'll try to push of
course um and yeah I mean it's really
unfortunate to lose the first game but I
can't do anything about that now we look
forward to game two thank you Magnus
thank you all right wow Magnus will push
in game two let's see what happens back
to you guys it's definitely energetic
combative play there between Magnus
Carson and ala fja David what do you
make of that advice to challenge
yourself um challenge yourself yes but
uh to make yourself feel uncomfortable
in one of the biggest tournaments of the
year I'm going to question that one
normally stick to what you know best
well it did backfire in this one Magnus
Carlson has to win on demon to take it
to the Armageddon and Hikaru Nakamura is
definitely rooting for Magnus here
Hikaru needs a draw is he going to be
distracted with what's happening on the
Magnus board well it's hard when Fate's
out of your control so for hiar nakur
he's had a bad event now he doesn't
control his own destiny uh but he can
only focus on the game in front of him
what happens between Magus and Al is up
to those two players so be it it is a
big final rapid game coming up and
Magnus Carlson Ali RZA fuja are ready to
go fuja with the white pieces but when
you're in a must-win situation playing
against Ali Resa at least gives you the
hope that there are big chances of
getting a dynamic position you know he's
not going to have solid approach he
never does have you ever seen him play a
solid game David uh I can count maybe on
my hand on one hand how many times I've
seen allesa play for a draw um yeah
allara normally plays principal chess
aggressive chess and uh creative chess
and that's why he has so many fans out
there Magnus meanwhile not looking the
most energized I've ever seen but uh he
will be trying to cook up a strategy to
create winning Chances with
black this is a big game for more than
just the two players in front of our
screens right now uh and of course uh
the other big fight also between Fabiano
Karana uh and nbec Abdu satov sorry I
stand corrected against Wesley so now
for these two players they've already
made it through Wesley will go into
semi-finals at pole position for Fabby
he does make it to third fourth spot and
Robert that's also very important talk
us through that yeah if you finished in
third or fourth place you play against
each other and that gives you two lives
in the survival stage the loser of 3
vers four plays the winner of 5 vers six
it's kind of like the NBA playing
tournament for those of you who are
basketball fans out there and for Dennis
lvic I mean he can't even think that far
he's just saying can I win this one game
with the white pieces and give myself a
fighting chance and Dennis with the
white pieces needs that Fighting Chance
and of course Abdu satra will take on
Maxim Vash lra for maxim also a very
very critical uh matchup he needs to get
the dubb in he needs to get the victory
for his shot at the survival stage so
much on the line for these players what
is going on in their minds right now in
these just seconds before first moves
yeah normally the top players they
approach nerves uh in one of two ways
either they just sit there try to will
themselves to focus try to block out all
the noise or as we saw with Maxim Vash
before he took his chair they walk
around they joke they have a chat
distract themselves completely
um so we will shortly see the games
begin but uh nerves are definitely
jackling in that playing Hall nerves are
on tensions on we can feel it all the
way across in Oslo and we're still
waiting for Hikaru Nakamura to arrive on
his board but the other players they are
ready to go it is time to get the first
moves in where is
Hikaru is a mystery where is Hikaru
nakur and here we see the Arbiter Jud
there saying Dennis you should start the
clock the games have commenced Hikaru is
late that's the first time all event
we've seen someone late to the round so
I have no idea where he is but I'm sure
there's a good reason oh my gosh I
haven't seen that happen before and it's
a rapid game it's 15 minutes with 3
second increment and Dennis did not want
to start the clock he wanted to wait for
Hikari to be on his seat I never enjoy
pressing the clock when my opponent's
not there some people like yes I get
extra time I me I'll beat them on the
clock now if it's uncomfortable for me
to start a game without an opponent too
nice Robert too much of a too much of a
sport man here though Dennis has been
asked to start the clock and the clock
is ticking Hikaru nowhere in sight
awkward moment but I'm going to ask I
mean does hikaru's absence have anything
to do with what happened in magnus's
game I don't think so and I feel like
people are playing up this notion that
Magnus wants to eliminate Hikaru but by
eliminating Hikaru he accepts Ali reaza
in the field and I know Hikaru has the
big audience there's so many people out
there cheering for him he's this huge
twitch presence but is Ali Raza any
weaker than hikara Nakamura in this
format I don't really think so it's kind
of a a coin toss so Magnus I don't
believe is actually rooting for hikara
to exit this field because that means Al
Ra's inclusion yeah Magnus wants to win
Magnus will play that next game Nakamura
he can be angry that Magnus bled he
could be frustrated disappointed but
he's got to focus on his own game he has
to get the job done here to have any
chance where is he he has to show up
he's preparing for Armageddon you know
he's just saying oh spot some time get
ready in case of an Armageddon match oh
my goodness and what is that that's
that's got to be over a minute now yeah
time does fly and uh yeah we want to see
moves we want to see chess Dennis lasic
wants a proper game as well he won't
want to win like this where is Hikaru
Nakamura I don't think there's a default
time what you see on the clock is what
he has left Hikaru to get a move down to
get into the tournament Hall and this is
so uncomfortable for Dennis as well just
sitting and waiting for his opponent
it's unfortunate you just want to play
the game and so he's just sitting there
enjoying his lead on the clock but
waiting for Hikaru Nakamura to show up
and the game to really begin yeah it
might be mind games uh we do know great
world champions of the past including
Gary Kasparov and others see like to
appear later and here we see Hikaru he
does enter fashionably late uh just a
couple of minutes disappeared he's
basically playing Armageddon now yes I
think we're all relieved and happy to
see Hikaru is on the board and
immediately sits down and makes his move
he starts with Knight to F6 and the blit
say out his second move as well with a
headshake what's going on in it's hard
to tell but what do you think is
happening to hiari right now what's
going on in his mind well he'll be
trying to focus now uh hopefully we get
a word from the ground out there in
Toronto a bit later on uh about why
Hikaru was delayed to the game but a
fast start he knows his opening Theory
and uh he did spot a couple of minutes
to Dennis but not terminal nothing too
dramatic so at least we have chess we do
have chess and we have a central break
on the board this is the Nimo Indian and
Hikaru strikes with the dynamic C5 and
another break in the center it is all
theoretical so far it is yeah so for
Hikaru all he needs to do is make a draw
with the black pieces he would be okay
with that but he's really just caring
about that game between Magnus and ala
it doesn't matter if a car wins his
match if ala does the same because he
will not make it through to the survival
stage so you asked the question what's
hiar thinking about where has he been
his head his heart has been with that
other match that's out of his control
yeah well and he continues to play out
so perhaps also preparing mentally for
this one as he blitzes out his first few
moves also gains some seconds on the
clock meanwhile our first result is
already in no surprises there Wesley so
Fabiano Carana ends in a Super Duper
Cooper Quick Draw and goes into
Armageddon yeah I think you said enough
Tanya the less said the better about
that clash between weslio and Fabby uh
right now it's rare I actually should
mention to see Fabiano agree such quick
draws but Armageddon guarantees some
drama at least for later and helps us to
focus on the key matches which will
decide who stays in Toronto meanwhile
this opening still very balanced still
well-known stuff um we're now around
move 10 and uh Hikaru he's catching up
on the clock uh he's got a very solid
position it's going to be tough for
Dennis to break this one down Dennis has
accepted the iqp the isolated Queen Pawn
uh so he will try to attack the black
King later on but he has to figure out
how he has to break those defenses not
an easy task and we know that Dennis
likes having the I queen Pawn he's done
it in several games in this event so
it's a position he's comfortable in and
for hikaro you see he's looking behind
him he's like what's going on in that
game between Magnus and ala can Magnus
do me a huge salad yeah and we will
check in on that one shortly Magnus has
played quite a combative opening over
there but yeah Hikaru he should be going
to check later f focus on this game W
just as I say that he gets up but I was
going to say focus on this game first
and he goes to check out the other board
and maybe we should to as Dennis lavic
takes the first real think of this game
Let's Do It Let's head over to where
Hikaru has just headed over to and it is
this game Magnus Carlson needs a win to
take it to Armageddon and to offer a
helping hand to his good friend his good
rival Hikaru Nakamura now there have
been trades in the center perhaps we can
it it looks like a non-standard Sicilian
to me David we can back up and see how
we got here yeah let's uh backtrack
we're only at move nine in this one
Magnus has been playing Super quickly up
to this point uh let's go from the start
uh quick action replay here it was the
Sicilian Defense one of the openings
that is uh most widely employed at the
top level in a must-win situation it
leads to Fighting Chess no Force draws
uh no solid lines here for white maybe
apart from this one a bishop B5 check
this is uh giving black a few options
but not declaring any action in the
Center yet and I just want to mention
this move after a pawn pushing forward
asking the bishop to take this Knight
Magnus plays Queen takes bishop and I
last saw this in a game with Magnus
Carson he played it as black in a mwin
situation against Maxi Vash gra years
ago on the grand chest tour uh he
employs it again and uh he was not
successful in that game winning with
black but look at this it's imbalanced
black does have a backward pawn and the
square in front of it is a nice juicy
Outpost for White's Knight but black has
the bishop pair a bit of a threat on the
board as well skewer hitting the queen
hitting the Rook which Alara needs to
deal with and at least there's enough
imbalance here to give Magnus long-term
hope yes so alizza he slid his Rook on
over to D1 to avoid that threat but I'm
totally with you as far as being in a
must-win situation this is pretty much
an ideal start to a game 10 moves in you
have the bishop hair there's no Clarity
there's no easy way to liquidate to
simplify trade everything off so I think
that Magnus has done the right thing and
I'm also looking at the clock the clock
was not his ally in that first game
against Ali Rizza he's said to Kaa well
I struggled with just seconds on my
clock it was too much to calculate for a
blitz scramble and here he's ahead by 3
minutes he has a healthy position he has
the experience that ala may not and we
know that ala he's 2,800 at his Peak but
he also just isn't as old as Magnus he
can't possibly have the experience that
the former world champion does yeah I
like Black's options as well if you get
time to put a Pawn on H6 bring the
Knight out to F6 push your pawns on the
B file uh push the pawns on the queen
side great chances longterm so Alara has
to act fast uh he's not acting fast on
the clock and Magnus will be gaining
confidence every second that ticks away
maybe hearu taking a peek at this one
feeling a bit more optimistic as we see
ala prevent any queenside porn advances
but this does give Magnus time to
develop his pieces and once he gets
castled we'll see a fighting middle
game and that's uh the big aim right now
for Magnus to get those kingside pieces
into the game meanwhile these Sicilians
I've always understood that the the
fight is around that D5 square if white
is able to plant a piece there in a nice
comfortable way white is better if black
is able to get the D5 break in black is
absolutely fine which makes me think
that there can be long-term plans for
alira here to try and reroute that night
from F3 to find a good way to arrive to
D5 one of the ways that you can do it
that I see David is to go D2 F1 E3 it
looks like a lot of time spent on it but
given the fact that Magnus is behind in
development on the king side is this a
that could be on Ali resa's radar I
think so for sure and I that's why if
I'm Magnus I might not waste the time
with H6 I understand that white likes to
play Bishop G5 and Knight F6 was just
played by Magnus but after Bishop G5 I'm
removing my knight from the attack I'm
going Knight D7 let's reroute that pony
maybe it's Knight C5 maybe it's Knight
B6 up to C4 just to ask some important
questions on the queen side and I can
kick your Bishop out of there remember
this is a must-win game if Magnus loses
or he draws it's the same match result
play H6 play G5 throw some pawns forward
this really is the type of game you want
when you're in must-win territory yeah
Magnus Carson using all of his
experience to guarantee this fighting
imbalanced position and uh he's looking
very relaxed right now up on the clock
as well good news for Hikaru
Nakamura all right let's do a quick
check in with Maxim Vash lra against
nbec Abdu satra speaking of knights
arriving on good squares I really like
how Maxim has planted his Knight on C4
yes not backc has got the bishop a but
it's really not the most ideal Bishop a
the position isn't as open to see the
activity meanwhile we also talk about
Pawn breaks it looks like if anyone can
break in the center it's got to be Maxim
and once he gets a successful E5 in it
would perhaps potentially lead to
structural weaknesses for naach I play
this opening from the black side my
entire childhood all the way up to
becoming a Grandmaster and I can't tell
you the number of times at a position
just like this and how bad it is it's
not fun to play from the black side your
Bishop pair is not really an advantage
in the position white has such firm
control over the center and controls the
pawn braks like you said all right well
we will get back to this it looks like
Maxim is in driver's seat so far out of
the opening let's head back to our big
big matchup for the round robin stuning
to see who gets eliminated and there
have been a lot of Trades symmetrical
Pawn structure heading for a draw David
good news and bad news for Hikaru yes
he's closer to the draw objectively he
should be fine the bad news is it's not
going to be much fun and white is maybe
on the better side of this equal
position due to the fact White's Bishop
has more potential White's Bishop eyes
the black porn in the center both sides
have isolated Queen pawns this time uh
on the defile and White's Knight might
do some hopping around but ultimately
Tanya I think your instincts are correct
no real weaknesses to speak of once
black drops his Bishop back to F7 kind
of challenging that diagonal and uh yes
it's up Dennis lazovic allei this type
of slow maneuvering strategic game but
it's hard to imagine Nakamura losing
this one it is a nice slight Advantage
for white no risk in the position Rook
C1 going to an open file that Rook can
jump all the way forward to C5 to attack
that weakness on D5 so I like the way
that Dennis is handling it it's going to
be a long grinded out battle and it's
going to revolve around can he actually
put enough pressure on that D5 Pawn or
will black be able to stabilize trade
off the pieces then for sure we would
see a draw yeah I think he needs to
maybe throw his H Pawn forward later on
if he wants to win this game he needs to
do something a bit spicy uh because if
Hikaru is able to put Rooks on the open
files trade off all the Rooks I think
those are the key pieces if Rooks
disappear or Queens disappear it's going
to be a draw he needs to keep the heavy
pieces on and apply some pressure but
we're talking about small margins here
and uh this game has been fairly
balanced up to this point talking of
something else that's fair great air
quality out there in Toronto right now
shout out to air things uh for that
device but yeah it's not as hot on this
board as uh the stakes are potentially
not as hot as the Magnus Carlson game is
looking right now and and uh either way
both players will be hoping to maneuver
that to their advantage nice Knight
Dodge there I think Bishop to for Knight
trade would have been uh great for lavic
so Nakamura keeping the right pieces on
the board yes he is uh keeping the piece
that can put potentially the pressure on
White's Central deep on and it's the
kind of position that Dennis would be
very proud of and pleased about but
given the matad situation he needs more
so uh this looks like it's going to go
hikaru's way the other match uh All Eyes
On alira fuja right now who needs a draw
to seal the deal for himself and also
Mark the end of the road for Hikaru
Nakamura and some moves have been made
on the board the Knight has arrived on
F6 so keeping that control on D5 and I
do see white is going for the plan that
we mentioned earlier yes although the
white Bishop on E3 kind of gets in the
way of that maneuver uh that you
mentioned Tanya I loved your kind of
Knight dance kind of you got to go back
to go forward sometimes in life in chess
and uh that white knight now on D2 is a
bit stuck and uh okay he secures his
Center White's E4 Pawn was slightly
vulnerable in certain positions but I
just don't see what white does next for
black it's simple you get the bishop out
you Castle the king bring Rooks to the
center maybe try and break open the
position for your pair of Bishops but um
yeah for ala the F uh the kind of the
plans are far less clear and I think
that the time is going to play an
important factor because Alara he's down
about 5 minutes here black can break
open center right now with Pawn of D5
I'm actually not sure I would go for
that if this were round one of a long
tournament maybe but Magnus needs to win
the game and D5 does start off trading
pieces in the middle I wonder if he's
better suited to play Bishop E7 castles
King and play around that square just
give him long-term chances to make Ali
R's decisions much more difficult so
he'll burn his clock yeah but it's that
moment right objectively and this is
what we were talking about earlier as
well black wants to try and get a
successful D5 break in in Sicilians that
is the big Sicilian dream and now Magnus
has that opportunity objectively might
be the best but as Roberts pointing out
it leads to a lot of trades in the
center but it could potentially lead to
an end game where anyone playing for
Advantage perhaps could be Magnus with
the bishop a do you think he's going to
go for this at this point David it's on
the board by the way he answers it
before David does yeah I was going to
say once Magnus spots her way to a path
towards a long-term Advantage here he's
most likely likely to take with the
queen uh he always goes for this um I
was lucky enough to film this chessable
course and uh make this book with Magnus
about grinding out these small long-term
advantages and it's one of those grindy
positions Queen takes Knight on the
board normally trading off pieces we
assume leads closer to a draw but if you
have enough imbalances here and I see
two of them uh then you can create
winning chances it's all about whether
Black's Bishops are longterm better than
White's bishop and Knight and it's all
about whether Black's kingside majority
the four versus three on the king side
uh whether that can be turned into a
pass Pawn in the meantime white does
have three versus two on the other flank
but uh harder to push those little
soldiers over there um so okay a
decision ala pausing I don't really see
any way to keep the Queens on the board
there's also pressure on this Pawn so
you cannot really run away from this
trade but uh yeah I like magnus's
position it's not much but it's
something and it's magnus's style and
not Ali razes Fabiano was asked this
question by Levy in game one whose style
was that tactical position it was more
of Ali raz's alley he said I think
everyone in the world would agree
including ala this is much more a Magnus
position he can grind like a grandm
David shout out to you and he's got this
position that he can't really lose
unless he blunders horribly he has a
nice four on three as you're pointing
Pawn pushes King can stay in the center
you have to love that Bishop dominating
the Knight I always say a pawn three
squares away from a knight dominate it a
bishop uh three squares away from Knight
dominates it even more taking away all
of its forward jumps yeah a small but
stable Advantage for Magnus Carlson and
if we see Hikaru come and take a look
again at this board a bit later on
Hikaru might be filled with hope and uh
look at the clock times as well he's got
double the amount of time Magnus Carlson
he's got a small advantage and okay
Alara brings the Knight into the center
this will not avoid a queen trade and uh
still yeah I think he's just done
everything right momentum black but this
is an interesting decision by Ala
because if Magnus was to now go in for
that Queen trade to me it looks like
it's forcing a structural change because
after Queen takes Queen Rook takes Queen
you actually see the pawn is hanging on
the open file so alira would be forced
to recap the queen with his own pawn and
how would you assess that structural
change going into the end game it's not
aesthetically pleasing but I think that
after you take with the pawn you're
going to push that pawn one square up to
trade it in the center that's what alz
is banking on I'm not quite sure if he
gets away with it because black can play
F5 that was the start of one of David's
plans just gaining space where you have
an extra Pawn that Knight has to drop
back to a sore like F2 and white is not
going to lose the game in the next few
moves but you are worse you are passive
and we have seen the queen trade we have
the position I'm wondering if Magnus
will strike with F5 or if he's going to
play with a steadier hand and perhaps
develop his pieces yeah just looks so
beautiful for black F5 on the board no
hesitation there the White Knight
actually chooses C3 but I mean look at
what a beautiful post this will be for
Black's Bishop an outpost keeping an eye
on this week pawn on A4 um you can just
move your king out get developed with
the other Bishop as well to
B4 feels like one-way traffic it's just
about whether it's enough if D4 ever
happens if a bunch of more trades happen
maybe Isa can hold an end game but uh
it's certainly uh Magnus having all the
enjoyment right now um yeah it's Knight
C3 it's sad this is definitely Alisa
playing for the match rather than
playing the position it feels like he's
just begging for a draw and uh normally
against the top guys that just doesn't
work that approach yeah and that's often
the worst way to play for a draw is to
play for a draw you've got to try to
play the position as much as it is
difficult psychologically and especially
against a guy like Magnus you give him
even the slightest chance the slightest
hope it might not even be a real chance
in the end game and he's going to try to
grind that one down till the very end a
very different position than the fight
that we saw in game one between these
two uh do you think Magnus is feeling
confident about his chances in this end
game right now absolutely because
playing for result isn't playing chess
chess is an objective game as soon as
you inject that subjectivity I just need
a draw let me play this quietly because
I need a draw you're not actually
thinking about the board as clearly of
course ala he's been in situations where
all he needed was a draw maybe he needed
a win but King of7 David's plan step one
the dark score Bishop will develop that
hole on B3 for that light score bishop
and Magnus is having all the fun and
there's very little ala can do besides
hope that Magnus will fail to convert
yeah it was interesting magnus's
interview with k a bit earlier he
dropped in this uh kind of advice from
Ramesh make yourself uncomfortable get
kind of step out your comfort zone
challenge yourself he's gone back to
basics here Magnus this is Magnus from
2009 2010 when he was kind of breaking
into the kind of scene becoming world
number one grinding down his older
opponents just seeking these long-term
small advantages in the end game um this
is the Magnus I knew and uh that we all
have it's uh like he took your advice
for game two just go back to what you
know best and what you do best Magnus uh
gone into an end game he's got the
bishop be how do we see him actually
increase the pressure in these positions
we often talk about Bishop be great
position open position you know you can
bring your Rooks to the center but what
I want to ask and understand is what are
the pieces that you're actually looking
at trading and increasing your advantage
here black doesn't really want to trade
anything just yet because White's pieces
while they look nice the Knight on C3
Bishop on D4 and he goes Bishop B6 you
can't necessarily improve that easily
and what black can do is go for an
attack a lot of people think that when
the Queens are off the board there's no
attacking chances but if black starts
throwing those pawns on the king side
forward opening up some files you do
have a bishop pair Bishops have open
diagonals but I do think that he's
holding in tough for now in fact not
trade so much that he didn't even take
the extra Pawn that was being offered on
C3 on that night Bishop bear more
important David are you expecting this
strategy to just Advance on the kingside
pawns and at the right moment strike and
create more weaknesses on uh one side of
the board yeah I think for now Magnus is
prioritizing kind of stabilization uh
he's just put his Rooks on nice squares
the Bishops on nice squares at the right
moment his plan of improvement is to
create a second front right now black is
dominant on the queen side Black's piece
is control a bunch of squares some
pressure on the white knight uh suddenly
he'll try as Robert said switch uh
tension um I saw this interview with uh
Magnus G and pep guarda it was fantastic
hearing about the the kind of two
Geniuses discussed strategies and Magnus
he's going to kind of overload on one
side and then switch the ball switch
attention to the other flank and um I'm
not saying it's winning I'm not saying
it's even that big an advantage but in
Practical terms it's uh yeah so
unpleasant for white to defend King F2
not really achieving much and now I
think we'll see your plan Robert push
those pawns it's why we have have to
keep talking about the clock right now
Oliver is it down under 4 minutes Magnus
still 7 and a half minutes on his and
also white doesn't have very clear plans
Black's peace AR perfect squares and
Tanya ask a very important question
because many of us would have taken that
Knight on C3 which can be captured right
now that does Net black a pawn but then
you can't make any other progress
because of the presence of opposite
colored Bishop so Bishop takes C3 I
think would be a massive mistake in
terms of your practical chances the Eva
bar right in the middle where is your
extra Pawn it's on B7 can it move no
because a bishop is sitting on B6
protected by a pawn so taking on C3
would be a big mistake if that Knight is
going to leave the board it's going to
be for the light Square Bishop I think
that mags would prefer to have Bishops
of the same color and that A5 Pawn it's
a strength right now for white it's
defending the bishop and defended by it
but in some positions you're kind of
Tethered to it so you have to be quite
defensive yeah uh I totally agree Robert
you don't want to cash in too soon you
don't want to sell uh this beautiful
Bishop for less than it's worth and uh
this white knight is not going anywhere
anytime soon it's got to stay on C3
plugging the C file so uh don't commit
too early that option will be available
later on so uh often in chess we say
just uh kind of keep the obvious moves
for later first improve improve build up
build up and that's what Magness is
doing Rook on C4 looks across the board
soon we'll see these pawns fly forward
again it's an end game we're going to be
here for a long time it's a marathon day
uh for us it's a marathon game well what
a beautiful idea there too because he
brought his Rook to an active Square so
that when he trades Bish on the C5 score
his second Rook will join so Magnus is
showing us I mean I know it sounds like
a joke because of the chess course in
the book but he really is showing us how
to grind in a position like this I mean
this is really good stuff he's making
sure that White's pieces are passive and
look at those Rooks that one can slide
to the square next one on B4 attack some
pawns I like his chances all right
classy technique on display here by
Magnus we'll see if it's enough or not
to get going into the Armageddon we're
going to do a quick check in with the
maxim Vash lra it's a materially
imbalanced position we see Black's got
the queen for a rook and a bishop and
how many pawns is that two pawns so we
do the quick math and it looks like
White's the one who's got well one Pawn
extra yeah good math St that was much
quicker counting I was struggling I was
like wait that's doubled pawns did they
count as one um but we also have to
maybe uh just show one tactic that did
arise it was V bash gr who sacrificed
his Queen watch out for some background
checkmates black gives the king some
breathing space uh we won't linger here
too long I think objectively it's still
balanced because White's pieces are so
perfectly centralized uh but a queen is
a queen uh but it's just one tactic uh
to show off here and uh I will just
backtrack very very quickly it was this
position black landed a nice check on
the white king and Maxim said okay I
don't want to shuffle into the corner
where I'm actually a big Target for the
queen and Bishop piercing from afar the
Knight could come in now with tactics on
the diagonal instead he just gave up his
Queen Knight takes and uh this is how we
we saw the material imbalance arise so a
level position ultimately and uh yeah
one that we will discuss a bit later we
will do a deep dive into this later and
we'll move on to Hikaru nakamura's board
for maxim vagra he needs to win his
match to secure his pot into survival
stage uh and Maxim their first game was
a draw nck is already into survival so a
lot on the line in that one as well and
here we've got Dennis lavic he has to
win his game but with the Rooks been
traded off David it's a point you made
long time ago major Pieces come off the
board you get closer to a draw is Hikaru
not going to need an Armageddon in this
one I think he's a big favorite to win
the match by holding this game drawing
this game again it's still white with
the uh better side of equality the
better side of the draw but uh it's hard
to imagine anything wrong uh Happening
Here for black simply you have control
over all the squares too symmetrical and
uh yeah no real play it's a good check
in here because some may think this is
the last we'll see of Hikaru and that
will be true if Ali Rizza can hold a
draw but doesn't look likely as the
current position that I'm seeing Tanya
it seems like it's getting worse and
worse for ala and we're going to jump
straight into that one some great
technique on display by Magnus trading
off his Bishop Advantage at the right
moment tying down Whit's a one Rook on
the a line defending the A5 Pawn also
the mobility of the White Knight you're
always looking for outposts and good
squares to land into but this Knight
just feels dominated right now I've said
it before I'll say it again I'll say it
always that Bishop three squares away
from a knight completely controls it
there are no forward options speaking of
forward look at those pawns David you
were clamoring for this for so long and
now it's here yeah Magnus biting his
time not rushing that's uh tip 101 in
grind like a grandm in our book just
don't rush just enjoy the moment massage
the advantage torture your opponent as
long as possible the longer you torture
them the more likely it is that they'll
crash and Magnus the pawns are rolling
now again no concrete threat but it's
just unpleasant you see your opponents
coming towards you you see their army
advancing and you're just stuck you just
have to stay still look at that white
Rook it's just kind of yo-yoing back and
forth on the a file because White's
weakness the pawn on A5 that Robert
mentioned earlier White's night stuck
plugging the SE file and uh no clear
plan of action for white black meanwhile
improving every move yeah David you make
it sound so easy to grind like a grandm
when I try to grind like an
international master I just often find
my opponent Breaking Free and getting
this counter play and I'm the one
getting tortured at the end how do you
keep control in these kind of positions
well it's I mean it helps when you're
Magnus Carson when you've seen
everything a mile away but uh yes number
one uh kind of rule other than just
being patient is to look for your
opponent's threats and here luckily
Magnus doesn't even have to look out for
any counterplay and there's one major
really Thorn In White side he goes G3
he's trying to get some counterplay here
but that rook in the corner for white is
stuck there because that pawn on A5 it's
wandered too far if you could actually
bring that A5 Pawn back a couple squares
then white would say it's not so bad for
me because that Rook is free to go that
Rook is stuck in the corner it's
protecting a pawn meanwhile Black's
Rooks are free to shuffle back and for
for and look at Magnus he didn't trade
on the king side he pushed his Pawn
forward he may think about that pawn
promoting later in this game yeah theory
of two weaknesses white has one weakness
on A5 maybe on H2 as well big big
weakness there uh if you could ever
trick white if you can ever sneak a
black Rook by behind on the first rank
to come and grab this Pawn it's game
over and uh this is a trademark of alpha
zero of Magnus Carson push pawns as
close to promotion as possible any race
Magnus will win later is there an idea
here if black plays Rook to B4 and white
plays Rook A1 can I play Rook takes B2
I've been wondering about this can I
sacrific an exchange not yet but the
point still exists that there could be
an exchange sacrifice for some pawns and
Magnus is doing that grinding thing
where he's slowly improving his position
move by move piece by piece but watch
out for ideas just like that yeah it
it's a really nice think that you
pointed out but what Magnus is doing
right he's also playing on the clock
he'll take those critical decisions of
changing the Dynamics in the position
when alira down to his seconds which
makes it that much harder to actually
control the position a check's been
given on the board and you're pointing
out the squares that are on magnus's
radar and also aliar with the last few
moves it's clear that he thinks that
there's nothing better he can do in the
position he's just shuffling around with
the rook and that makes it so much
easier for Magnus to improve his
position yeah the hardest thing in chess
is to actually do nothing and that's
what alaza is having to do right now
most likely he'll bring his Rook back he
might get tempted to swing his Rook
across I was going to say go for that uh
slightly detached black H Pawn but no he
does adopt this defensive uh formation
and now Magnus we know he doesn't
believe in fortresses can he break
White's Fortress it's a good question
and it doesn't look very easy that
exchange sacrifice will be in the back
of his mind but we saw the eval bar say
not in that position the big problem for
white is your Rooks are stuck The Rook
on A3 protecting the pawn A5 The Rook on
the second rank is shielding the king
and protecting that B2 Pawn so has
Magnus maximized that's the question a
fortress would be a really big dream
come true for Ali Rea where it looks
terrible he can just shuffle a little
bit back and forth here and there and
Magnus saying oh big decision time can
you trade me or is that black king
coming in too quickly wow big question
to ask as well no easy answers Alara
feels obliged to trade off the Rooks but
now Black's King can start Sid stepping
slide to the left and go for that weak
white A5 Pawn I'm really surprised
Magnus has rushed into this normally I
would say kind of wait wait wait only if
you're 100% sure but it does look
mightly scary for white still and Magnus
has to be sure that after sliding the
king if there's a trade of Rooks on C5
that his King is fast enough to gobble
the queen side pawns and alira will not
be able to create counterplay against
the king side pawns but alira prefers to
keep the Rooks on the board but now this
H3 Pawn the alpha zero the alpha Magnus
Pawn that we're talking about in many
positions that can be a a big weakness
in White's Knight or the king can start
targeting it it definitely can be a
weakness but after Magnus slides his
King over there are second rank ideas
for him he has so many options here and
I think for ala give him three more
minutes he might have traded Rooks in
that position any Rook check could have
forced The Rook trade and perhaps that
was a draw but you 50 seconds you can't
calculate 20 moves down the line which
is what you need to do to ensure that
you're not giving away a half Point yeah
really difficult position Fu's done a
kind of admirable job here of defending
really fantastic stoic defense but now
it's kind of the calculation part of the
game where it's very concrete it's no
more about those strategic uh kind of
theoretical things we were talking about
where you can just trust your judgment
and play on feel Instinct alone now it's
pure calculation that's why Magness has
slowed down 2 minutes against just under
1 minute I'm expecting the black king to
move on over as well that's the
consistent kind of Final Act of the plan
but suddenly it's all about the king
side can black stabilize on that flank
and uh suddenly counterplay for the
first time in a long time amazing
defense from Alara we keep talking about
magnus's ability to grind ala's ability
to defend is Top Notch he's proving it
in this game but will he be able to
sustain this he's got 52 seconds left
Magnus he's pausing for now but you know
he's going to wraid fire just spit out a
few moves in a row and then ala will
have to keep defending while being down
to just
seconds a big decision for Magnus does
he allow Ali rzad to trade off the Rooks
or will he slide with his King uh Magnus
with a big think almost a TW minute
think at this point so really the clocks
are getting more and more leveled right
now it's going to be a race a race for
Magnus to get on the queen side alira
trying to get to the pawns on the king
side to create his own passer meanwhile
we do see the evaluation bar go in
hikaru's favor in his fight against
Dennis lavic but it all really comes
down to this game for Hikaru as well and
we're seeing it being played out the
king as you said moves towards the A5
Pawn the Knight jumping into attack
right now can Magnus just uh pick up the
A5 Pawn oh some calculation is needed uh
maybe he'll want to avoid a pure Rook
end game so white knight is threatened
to take the black bishop and White's
Rook noed on the third rank is going to
pick up that straggler the pawn on H3
Magnus I think needs to keep some uh
imbalance alive he puts his Bishop on G2
nice active Square defending the pawn I
didn't even see that was possible me
neither I was shocked but it defends the
H3 pawn and the B7 Pawn this shows why
Bishops often dominate
yeah and uh at least now is there still
a threat of taking on A5 you've got to
be a bit careful the White Knight is
jumping so some source of counterplay
but 20 seconds to hold this when it
looks like your kind of Palace Your
Castle is just collapsing in front of
you the foundations including that A5
Pawn dropping and so is the Eva bar the
Eva bar is dropping in Black's favor bit
by bit this is a nerve-wracking moment
here for alaza o Rook takes Pawn
possible or not that's the big question
but first Magnus gives a check still in
control Magnus is in control and Hikaru
Nakamura is in control of his position
we'll do a quick check on this one as
Dennis is playing with Just 4 seconds
Hikaru can wrap up his match he's got
two extra pawns on the other side of the
board it looks like it's busted
completely busted for white despite
having the Deep on black king is super
near White's passer yeah Dennis he had
to take some risks he had to win this
game a draw and uh lost the same result
essentially he took a risk too many and
nakamura's pned are just rolling now as
you say Tanya wh's deep Pawn is not
going anywhere it's been locked down now
and it's all about those three connected
passes on the queen side three connected
pawns is too many and white knight is
just unable to play Nakamura is going to
wrap this up any moment now and he's is
going to win this game it will be Dennis
lack's first loss the handshakes are
there but hi's tournament might not be
over he is relying on Magnus Carlson and
look at this Magnus Carlson you see the
Eva bar is going all the way down he's
up a pawn his Rook is active and now
it's about converting this into a win
and we mentioned it about 20 25 moves
ago Robert White H Pawn was a Target he
locked it down fixed a weakness and now
it's dropped off the board Magnus has
now created the most powerful of pass
pawns Harry the H PA's going to become a
queen uh that H Pawn is only two squares
away from touchdown Magnus is going to
take this he's got pawns pass pawns
potentially on both flanks White Knight
is a short- range piece the bishop so
clearly Superior here it drops back
white the black Rook will move out the
way with one second made that move he's
got no time and now he loses another
Pawn Yeah but what he's hoping for is if
he can trade Rooks and give up his
Knight for the B7 pawn bishop and a pawn
versus King if that King can run to the
corner will be a hold so watch out know
your theoretically drawn end games I
don't think Magnus is going to blunder
into that but he needs to keep an eye
out and he moves his King but he's
walking into a knight Fork be careful
big threat on the board Knight back to
D3 check would be a nasty Fork on the
king and Rook Magnus I think he just
chose the wrong square and now he's got
to be careful because that KN check also
forces the king to lose connection with
that A5 Pawn you can't give a check
right now or can you because there's
Rook to C5 if he would have stepped over
G that would been Checkmate white would
have won the game had he stepped in the
other direction he still has two pass
pawns I think the engine evaluation it
says equal but it's going to be
difficult for ala prove that with seven
seconds he's doing a great job thus far
wow Al are so resourceful he setting up
all the traps that tricky Knight jumps
and uh he's got a pass Pawn of his own
the white G Pawn is the best of all of
them
yeah and goes away and all of black
pieces are on one side of the board
they're sort of getting in each other's
ways the pawns can't move forward while
white spawn is just advancing further
and further he does attack The Rook he
will move back not giving any Tempo does
he push G6 why not have a pass Pawn push
a pass Pawn but that Bishop is coming
around to B3 with check and once the
king slides out of the way oh you see Al
there is he was unsure but he's taking a
square way from the black king the black
king needs to move and the pawn needs to
run oh my gosh and this is so important
for not just Magnus Carlson but Hikaru
Nakamura Magnus needs to win and this is
getting closer to a draw ever closer if
white sacrifices the night for Black's
porn we'll see the infamous rook and
Bishop versus Rook end game which is
objectively a draw but so tough to
defend with only a few seconds on the
clock he can do it now he should take
that porn in the next few moves it it's
not running away yet but uh he wants to
avoid that end game as long as possible
for and the one thing oliv has to avoid
is bringing his King forward to A6 it
looks like the best move but you're
walking into a pin so that would free up
the black king I don't know how Magnus
makes progress anymore he can't move his
king without losing his a pawn oh he's
blocking out the white Rook this is
really clever maybe forcing that
sacrifice in the next few turns but he's
going behind Alara and the Moment of
Truth he does sacrifice it's rook and
Bishop versus Rook start your counters
it's the 50 move Ru kicking in and did
you see magnus's reaction there he says
okay I'm ready for this one now this is
going to be a fight it is Rook Bishop
versus Rook a theoretical draw but can
alira hold for the next 50 moves and
what you often want to do is keep your
king and Rook on the other color of that
Bishop that's a great move by Magnus
he's trying to restrict the scope of
that Rook but you need to bring your
king closer Magnus starts in the right
path Magnus needs to force the white
king onto one of the four sides of the
board and only then will there be
checkmating ideas but that's going to
take a while Alara cutting off the black
king I'm pretty sure he studied this for
hours and hours throughout his career
the top players spend a lot of time on
this but it's all about the nerves
whether he cracks only a few seconds
left and I'm sure Magnus has studed this
uh completely as well so he knows how to
try to get the white king to the edge of
the board the way to create the best
chance and it'll come down to those
final moments does Ali Resa know those
critical defenses when the king is in
the last rank or the Conner alz is
nervous he's down under 5 Seconds you
could see him hesitating with this king
move that black king can now go to the
center that white king is being pushed
to the edge of the board but he can use
the Cochran defense pin the Bishop from
a distance he does that so it's clear
that oliv Ren knows what he's doing and
now you got to be really careful you
don't want to commit the white king is
ready to do a bit of a dance here if
Black's King later goes one way the
white king will go the other now we'll
see the white king go up the board
surely uh in the next move or two oh
Alara he's doing everything right so far
but still big nervous moments ahead it's
Magnus Carlson who's got less time on
the clock than Ali rea the clocks are
now absolutely level and hesitancy there
by Ala he finally decides to go to 86
with his King and that black king is
inching closer because white wants to
put that Rook on the G and trade the
Rooks off not allowed here if that
Bishop it snakes back here it comes if
it gets to F5 that white king could be
an a mating
net back he's losing now he's in the net
he's in the net he walked right into the
net Bishop can even and they know it
they know it this is a well-known
winning position blacks Rook will come
around now and deliver a killer blow the
white King has no Escape squares any
check on the H foul will be decisive
Magness goes the long way around and
white is stuck Al out with a smile he
knows this is all over he's gotten his
King at the wrong side there's a mate in
one being threatened that you cannot
fight against Magnus Carlson gets the
job done takes it to Armageddon aliar is
disappointed he had this one a draw
would have seen him through and the
other man who is very relieved with this
result is Hikaru Nakamura you can defend
for a long time but you have to defend
forever when Magnus Carlson is grinding
against you the Eva bar went to the
center but looks can be deceiving and
Ali Raza fua he couldn't hold in that
rook and Bishop ver Rook ending we've
got an Armageddon coming up the bids are
being written right now as Magnus
Carlson strikes back wow what classy
play from the world number one what
great Defence from alera fua in the end
in Practical terms it was too difficult
it was one step too far but yeah that
just shows Magnus he's a sportsman he
doesn't care about other results he just
wants to win his own games and such a
different game from what he saw from
Magnus in game one this was Magnus uh in
his true style this is Magnus at his
best yeah those type of games where he
doesn't force the issue he doesn't
Castle Queen side unnecessarily and I'm
curious what their bids will be because
strategy has changed game after game for
Max he been 15 minutes to get white one
game then he bit as low as 8 minutes and
53 seconds another I'm curious what do
you think for Magnus will he aim for the
white pieces alira how low will he go if
he wants black o it's tough I think
Magnus would take either color right now
he's feeling so confident alaza needs to
recover so he might well want black and
draw odds but these are the results T
and these are the results which means
we've got three Armageddon coming up
that seems to be the tradition right now
minimum of three and we've got two to
zero for Hikaru Nakamura he's got the
job done and while the games were over
take a look at what was happening
backstage they had their eyes on Magnus
versus ala fuja you're asking for five
people to watch a game that's like the
strongest five you could ask for there
are a few people missing of course but
that's awesome to see them tuned in
locked in at aaru he now has a chance
yeah some more tense than others in that
group of five people that we saw as the
action continues and one man who's going
to continue watching Magnus in action
will be Hikaru David what around we
going to three Armageddon what have you
got for us what was the highlight well
I'm going to go back and study rook and
Bishop versus Rook after this uh after
this day is over that's for sure it's
the trickiest end game to hold
theoretically a draw but as we saw
Magnus he knows all the Maneuvers the
winning plans and alera unfortunately
just didn't have enough time on the
clock it was here just deep into the end
game where the final mistake occurred he
defended so well for so long but pushing
his King back to H5 where it does get
trapped was uh the error instead he
could have played a move such as
dropping his Rook back getting ready to
uh to give the black king A little nudge
a little check from the front multiple
moves draw you could even have waited
you could even just keep your Rook on A5
it's difficult it's unpleasant in the
end King H5 was a mistake because now
the cage is closed and as we saw the
black king now safeguarded from checks
the white king with no Escape squares
and the reason he resigned in a few
moves time was simply because there's no
way now to stop this Checkmate the white
Rook is stuck unable to land a block and
game over a great win for Magnus
Carson wow Magnus Carlson gets the win
in taking it into the Armageddon and
we've got the bids that are about to be
revealed and look at this Robert this
has been the story line so far far what
do you make of this yeah the average bid
to get the black piece in 9 minutes and
25 seconds so if the players have been
studying their opponents the fellow
competitors they would know to bid maybe
around that range if they want black but
the lowest black bid has gone to both
Magnus and Ali Raza 8 minutes 53 seconds
how low will they go we know Magnus once
went 15 minutes I think he was trolling
just trying to mix things up but I do
think these two are willing to go that
low in this match up against one another
yeah it's hard to predict at this point
Magnus momentum is on his side but with
Armageddon it is a bit random it's just
about who's faster who is cleverer with
their bits yeah and Magnus Caron has
been clever enough to not be predictable
in this tournament he's been really
mixing it up and it'll all come down to
who wants the white pieces and how much
are you really willing to put on the
line how much time are you willing to
put on the line for those black pieces
and of course this is where it's all
happening and the action continues as we
got three big Armageddon coming up and
once again subscribers good news you get
some really cool stuff so don't go
[Music]
anywhere nck Abdu satov a rising star in
the Chess World won division 2 in the
chessable Masters to qualify for
division 1 in the chess kid cup and he
immediately Rose to the challenge Notre
Beck is not going to miss this he solves
these for breakfast he solved these for
breakfast 7 years ago
goodbye it's reable really just clinical
play here and there we have it NC of the
satov takes the match against Jordan van
Forest another great move Knight D6
there was Rook D7 just integrating the
tactics perfectly and he's about to win
a third PA that might trigger
resignation Black Knight no good squares
for it to use and I think Fabby you can
tell body language there he leaned back
has he resigned he has Abdu satoro takes
the match in the Grand Final he plays
kowana yet again and with another
impressive match win Abdu satarov
emerges victorious in the chess kid cup
to qualify directly for the tour finals
Queen D2 is that the winning move and
that's it we have a winner not Abdus
satro wins the chess kid cup with an
impressive performance throughout the
season Abdu satarov has earned a total
of 325 tour points the same as kowana in
second place on the standings the
19-year-old is definitely someone to
look out for in
[Music]
Toronto
[Applause]
[Music]
he
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
a
take
[Music]
the edge of our seats as the the action
is happening in the beautiful city of
Toronto but we can feel the tension all
the way in Oslo Hikaru or Ali Roosa only
one will make it to survival stage we've
got three big armag gens coming up the
biggest of them all Ali RZA versus
Magnus the question right now what is
armagen take a look welcome to the most
exciting format in chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match point white
starts with 15 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black and those coveted
draw odds let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence it's all m games right now what
will the players bid and I'm really
excited to find out as ska is with
Wesley and Fabby revealing their
beds they finished even before Hikaru
Nakamura made it to the board here in
the second games and it's going to be
Armageddon so you guys go ahead turn
your boards let's see oh all right you
want the white pieces 1459 for Fabby 903
you will play with the black pieces well
was the thought here Wesley yeah I
remember Fabby bid yesterday 959 so I
thought and then he car bid with 910 and
he won so I thought I'd bid somewhere
around that but I should have been
higher and you are eager to get the
Perfect Score here I bet to win all your
matches in the round
robin uh well I'm looking forward to the
you know to the
semi-finals because I guess because of
tie break doesn't it's not a big
difference so nope not at all well fobby
uh I bet you were going to be happy to
play with the white pieces depend uh
watching your bid here what was the
thought here yeah so I I actually had a
dream last night that I was playing
Armageddon against Wesley and I bid 15
minutes and then he outsmarted me and he
bid 16 minutes so I decided to play it
even smarter and bid 1459 cuz I thought
this is like the safe in case he bids 15
for example then I'm in good shape and
in case he bids lower then I'm also in
good shape so that's that's my reasoning
behind this very cool very cool you your
dreams and that's a very good thing I
don't remember the result though of the
dream so we'll see okay so that's yet to
see you guys so how did Fab's dream end
we're going to see when the armag gon
starts back to you guys W 1459 I'm
circling the black pieces what is in
Toronto's air with the nicest guys on
the circuit trolling each other what's
going on there
Danny what Fabby didn't say is
apparently how his dream ended was he
was pissed that we allowed Wesley to bid
16 minutes oh and he freaked out he was
mad at the organizers cuz we allowed
Wesley to bid more time than is legally
allowed so I think Bobby needs to relax
a little bit before dreams aren't real
dreams aren't real dreams aren't real
dreams aren't real you know what is real
what is real Armageddon Armageddon
Israel and Magnus is now Harry Potter
yeah from the that was by the way is
Fabi car one of the the funniest and
most normal top chess player he might be
it's it's well I mean okay there's
there's a lot
of lot to unpack about that we're you
should watch the white elephant video
have you seen it yet not yet you should
watch the white elephant video If you
haven't seen it yet okay we got to talk
about Army geddon yeah so we
have Magnus and fuja Fabby and so mvl
Notre Beck obviously the main focus is
Magnus and fuja not just the main focus
Fabby Wes so literally does not matter
it does not matter they literally could
not show up yeah and same with Notre
Beck and NBL almost well they're they're
they they're M no no now that Lo has
lost to Nakamura it actually doesn't
matter that so really we're all about
Magnus and your thoughts on who's got
the edge going into that right now I
mean obviously Magnus uh momentum aside
right you're going to take Magnus in a
match uh we're going to get their
armagedon bids in a second I imagine uh
and that was a crazy game to win I mean
that literally could not have come down
any closer than the way it did that was
Harry swooping in Saving Malfoy in the
room of requirement rook and Bishop
versus Rook a theoretically drawn end
game and he finds a way to win that's I
I I was blown away just like everyone
else we've got I guess the players
heading to their boards so we're
probably going to send it back to the
studio Tanya I wish I had more to Banter
about we're just all hype here in
Toronto literally people were on the
edge of their seats out there I can't
wait till people see the the edit of
hikaro Nakamura watching in real time as
far as what happened but you had
everybody crowded around and the drama
was insane and here we go it's
Armageddon it's all we
got it is uh go time really really soon
I'm just upset about you guys saying
that dreams aren't real what are you
talking about about I mean say that to
Wesley he's having the dream run that
anyone can hope for with his performance
but he's got an armagon to play and
these two are ready to go do we even
know what the bids were for these two
not yet but we will find that as K's got
the bids and we'll be revealing them
really soon but look at Ali Rea he is
ready to go is he still thinking about
what just happened or is he thinking
about the armagan that's coming up and
just moment ago Kaaya was with the
players and their
bids major drama this one going to
Armageddon we're going to see the bids
you guys go ahead and turn your boards
942 for Magnus nine that means you're
going to play with the black pieces the
thought here
OA yeah I mean um I'm happy at least
it's arm good and I have another chance
but not happy with my play this armagon
will decide hiar nakamura's Faith as
well what do you think thinking right
now
Magnus I'm not thinking so much about
that but I'm I'm happy that I managed to
um to uh come back even though the game
was uh was a mess quite High bit from
you here we'll play with the white
pieces now how do you feel about that
it's okay W this will be an exciting one
best of luck you guys thank you we're
going to have armag get on back to you
guys Ali RZA wins the bed with 9 Minutes
gets the black pieces and we will have
the first moov soon Magnus saying that
he isn't thinking about Hikaru but right
now Hikaru Nakamura literally cares oh
Hikaru is begging Magnus to win
something you typically don't hear but
Magnus needs to win for herar to stay
alive yes and we will have the moves of
the obon in just a few moments as Wesley
so and Fabiano Karana have taken it down
to the wire and they are ready we've got
three big ones coming up and first to go
on the way is is Fabby with the English
opening the opening of Dreams the
English opening shout out thank you
Fabby the English opening does show
fighting intentions it does keep White's
options open guarantees a long fight
fewer forcing lines than uh in the Kings
porn opening in Queen's gambits and uh
others meanwhile Fabby does open the
center and uh he does remember have a
six-minute Time advantage to start this
game a fast uh beginning here as Wesley
so tries to clarify the center um as
mentioned earlier this one less
important for the standings but of
course both players want to win and
Wesley wants that Magnificent Seven they
can't forget that there's $1,000 up for
grab every match winner gets a cool
Grand so there is quite a lot at stake
and I think that at one point some one
of these players has to turn it on
they've just been sailing coasting to
those draws and we're going to get a
sharper position now that fa develop is
Bishop out to G5 definitely things to
fight for here it's the money that
you're talking on the line but also for
Wesley the dream of of just having the
perfect the perfect the dream run going
into the uh next uh going into his
semi-finals he will enter it at Pole
Position regardless of what happens for
Fabby as well he's made it into survival
stage while it's a short day in office
for Wesley Fabby still has a lot of
Chess to be
played yeah he still has a lot of Chess
play uh to play he knows he'll be in
that survival stage Wesley so meanwhile
going for a f start here and uh we'll
check back in later we will and we've
got a of armag to be played as our next
fight of Maxim Vash and nbec Abdus satov
is also about to get underway as this
one just in its opening stages just
getting started it is still a
theoretical battle as we can see the
players are blitzing out their moves and
very often in these openings white
delays the development of the light
Squad Bishop uh you simply don't want to
waste a move if black was to capture on
C4 so kind of just bring out all the
other pieces in into their ideal
situation before you develop that Bishop
on F1 and uh Fabby not wanting to waste
time takes the decision to uh liquidate
the center it's an isolated Queen Pawn
some people enjoy playing with it but I
think in Blitz it's super hard to cover
that pawn especially without time on
your clock you don't know when it's okay
to sacrifice it for the compensation in
terms of activity or when you need to
put all your forces defending it so good
opening Choice from Fabiano I'll say and
you look at Wesley he's down to 7
minutes it's about to be 45 seconds it's
ticking down we're only on move 11 it's
not going to be an easy game for him and
we spoke about this earlier right for
Faby he's got a big part of the
tournament coming up right after this
match he's got to fight in the survival
stage how important is that in terms of
was he preparing for that fatigue
stamina how much effort is Fabby
actually putting into this game I think
he's putting in enough uh of course he
would prefer a shorter game he doesn't
want a 100 move grind with pieces flying
where it comes down down to a race
against the clock he doesn't want his
nerves jangling uh because he has bigger
fish to fry bigger matches to come but
uh yeah for now it's balanced and both
players just take me a chill well this
is a balanced Armageddon but one it is
one which is not going to be balanced at
all is Magnus Carlson with his
handshakes with ala fuja this is the big
one it all comes down to this ala fua
Hikaru Nakamura only one will survive
and go into the next stage and it is
going to be about this Armageddon it's a
crazy opening love the choice from
Magnus Carlson when your opponent does
not have time to calculate why not play
something that is not Mainline
repertoire and F3 the point is clear let
me push my E4 oh it's not there yet Pawn
E4 or why don't I throw my G Pawn up the
board and get a kingside attack I really
think this is a brilliant choice in an
Armageddon game where ala he's now the
first to really think and spend his time
wow a 30 second think there pretty much
from Alara at this early stage his early
as move four move five that's not a good
sign on the clock but what is magnus's
idea a Pawn on F3 it's very very rare to
see the top players land upon there it
takes away squares from knights it means
the white king is not entirely safe
loosens up the white position so Magnus
better have something special prepared
um I'm slightly skeptical I've got to
say I think it's very much tailored to
this match situation um but yeah it
depends on what Magnus chooses now he
needs to act quickly throw pawns forward
develop quickly before ala gets fully
organized Magnus has got to make some
big decisions and what about from a
psychological point of view we will
leave psychology aside for right now
because a big committal decision on the
board Magnus going all out with the Gary
the G Pawn G4 on the board Harry the H
Pawn should be next why not throw all
your pawns forward it's not easy to meet
a pawn storm when you are down on the
clock that goly Rea started this
Armageddon match but his position is
solid he's done nothing wrong he can
continue his development but I think for
Magnus he's trying to determine do I
jump my queen out to B3 do I keep
pushing pawns on the king side he's
trying to come up with the trajectory of
the game that suits him best is this a
new position already David because I am
not familiar with this one at all I
don't have a database in front of me but
I can safely say out of the tens of
thousands of games I've seen in my chess
career this one is brand new uh a trade
of Bishops now I guess the themes in
this opening which was the slav defense
uh often similar Black's problem pieces
is normally the light squared Bishop so
the fact that has been traded off now is
good news for fuia but white has gained
some time gained some Tempe in the
process especially those porn pushes are
Kitt really reminds me of a jababa
London the ja Binks London shout out
James County and uh White having this
extra space gives him more options a
Trad of Pawns there I'm slightly
surprised Magnus rushed and are we going
to see Magnus go with another game with
the queenside uh castle by his King once
you pushed G4 you really don't want your
King on the king side so Magnus pausing
he's got he's going all out in this one
still stopping Magnus this game is even
safer for his King on the queen side he
can Castle Queen side Slide the King on
over to B1 it's safe over there where's
the black king going especially after B5
it's clear that it's either staying in
the center or eventually when uh White
runs out of Firepower castling to the
king side
but Magnus says my king is safe you
don't have any attackers I have to say
big Advantage for white yeah at least it
looks more fun to play right now I'm
going to revise my opinion I was very
skeptical but suddenly maybe again it's
the slow Pawn pushes I was a bit
critical of alera in the first black
game that he ended up winning uh with
this move A6 it feels like he's kind of
committed to an attack on the queen side
but it's he was seeing ghosts Magnus
King just ends up on the other flank
that must be so frustrating he's
essentially wasted his own time taken
away the queen side as a safe haven for
Black's own King and Magnus is so far
ahead in this race this attacking race
wow alare is now forced to plug the
advance of those white kingside pawns
with his own Knight but that Knight is
stranded offside long term and Magnus
he's fighting in the center too the
speed the confidence the uh courage to
play like this it's impressive I would
throw the eval bar out the window
because I look at this position it
doesn't matter if it's up a little bit
for white or down a little bit for black
it's right near the middle but it's
super complicated we're on Mo 15 ala
he's got seven minutes plus on his clock
and now the center is opening but it's
just the start of what will be a very
hectic game and it is a decision from
Magnus he can recapture in three
different ways does he take it with the
pawn to try to get the center but it
could lead to an open position for his
own King the f file opening up
eventually perhaps get a piece instead
on the center of the boat capture it
with the Knight on e4 you win a Tempo
but the downside of that would be that
Black's Knight can eventually find
itself on a nice post on D5 I like the
decision Magnus has taken with Knight
takes spawn but I'm expecting alira to
get his own Knight to that nice Central
spot on D5 he needs to race he needs to
be quick he actually drops his Bishop
back I liked your idea there Tanya uh
because right now black black is really
passive black has one Knight stranded on
the rim on the edge of the board Black's
other pieces are pretty much encamped
within their own first two ranks Magnus
has all the freedom wow playing on this
flank opening up a second front just as
he did in that end game he's been
focusing on the king side suddenly maybe
learning from Pep guarda switching the
attack to the other side of the pitch
he's certainly causing confusion here
because Alo is probably looking at that
tension of Pawns over there on the king
side and now you have to switch flanks
and worry about the queen side and it's
not easy to choose between pushing that
pawn which may stick out and become
stranded or to capture but that leaves
the A6 Pawn as a weakness these are
difficult decisions in classical chess
much more so when you're down to 6 and a
half minutes and Magnus is over 12 yeah
and we've been talking about Nakamura
Staying Alive in this tournament ala is
also fighting for his own life and uh
this type of position when you want to
stabilize you know a draw is enough in
an Armageddon I mean it's wild it's just
crazy Magnus is throwing pawns at you
left right and Center literally in this
position position um it must be so so
tough having all of those emotions in
your head after that previous defeat and
now facing this I mean it's so so tough
yeah he's also fighting this inner
battle this inner game right now right
he wins the first game Ali RAR and he
does it convincingly after Magnus is
rash in the openings and then the second
game also a lot in control and that Rook
Bishop versus Rook where he could have
actually just wrapped up the match at
that point but he went on to lose that
one a very difficult one to defend in a
seconds does that shift the momentum to
favor Magnus coming into it with the
comeback with the Armageddon getting the
white pieces and this position on the
board this position is completely in
White's control that black king is in
the center it's not safe there can't
Castle King side that's going to be
ripped open and I think this match has
been Topsy Turvy in a very uncomfortable
way for Ali Raza even in game one he had
a winning position and then all of a
sudden it turned in magnus' favor and
then Magnus under the duress of the time
pressure he blundered ala took that game
in game two ala should have held after
being much worse at some points and then
couldn't so I think it's been an
uncomfortable match for Al Razer and
this position is no less uncomfortable
yeah just this switch up in styles from
Magnus he's really confirming the fact
he is a universal player grindy end game
followed by Chaos on the board and uh
right now look at the clock times look
at the difference as well he started
with six extra minutes Magnus it's way
more and F5 it smacks of panic just
lashing out here trying to open up lines
around the white king but this could
backfire white is not obliged to take
omasan is not obligatory and uh White's
KN if it simply moves I think this is
going to leave black with even more
severe weaknesses even though white king
is the one on F2 it feels like Black's
King is the one that's feeling more heat
in this position that E6 Pawn which will
be a long-term weakness at some point
the B5 Pawn will be a weakness as well
if the dark Square bishops get off the
board there are so many holes nice posts
for the White Knight to jump to but
where are you going with your knight you
said onas is not what you want to do
right now do you go forward do you do
you Retreat what would be your choice
here my first instinct at least was to
plunk the Knight into C5 a nice Outpost
that being said Okay first you could
trade Bishops and Magnus does go for
that I was going to say actually you
don't even need to move your knight you
could for example have taken this Pawn
undermining the Black Knight but instead
we did see a quick capture from Magnus
Carson and he does land the night on a
beautiful Outpost this was essentially
my idea it is this E6 Pawn which is now
backward a big Target still black is
reluctant to Castle King side it was
just important if we backtrack for that
one moment not to capture onas on
because suddenly the Black Knight is no
longer offside if black does now
eventually castle look at this the white
king will be left on a open file or a
semi-open file here so Magnus has kept
control and it's the dance of knights
now only Knights remaining on the board
of the minor pieces but too many threats
Pawn takes Pawn the first the most major
of them all wow that is a big threat on
the board and can ala actually waste
time right now trying to defend that
threat with the king in the center and
we have got results on uh the Armageddon
between mvl and Abdu satov and Abdu
satov takes the win he didn't just take
the win he crushed Maxim in that game
and he is secured a top four placement
that means he gets two lives in the
survival stage but look at this this
might be Ali Razer Fu on his last life
because he is now down upon his Knight
on age five it's on the rim and is
looking dim his chances are dimming here
and for all of a sudden for all the fans
out there Hikaru Nakamura his chances
are suddenly great are Hikaru fans right
now Magnus fans definitely I think the
happiest man in Toronto is Hikaru
Nakamura he's probably watching that
screen with with the uh rest of the
players right now uh cheering it on
cheering Magnus on and simply a pawn up
now Magnus has transformed his Advantage
from something positional from the
dynamic kind of attacki was going from
early on to a simple mathematical
Advantage extra Pawn watch out for that
white might be to throw itself down the
board later on and he was really playing
on all sides of the board right he
starts with those G4 H4 advances on the
king side then strikes on A4 creates a
weakness on the queen side feels very
clinically done by Magnus puts the King
on F2 once uh Ali rzza committed the
weakness of overexpanded on the queen
side then strikes there now he's up upon
PA places The Rook on the G line and it
just looks despite ala getting the king
to the corner of the board it's still
under Fire I will say and I'm doing this
for David's benefit it's good for black
that the queens has been hoovered off
the board there white is up a pawn but
there's not much remaining and black was
scrambling to defend everything now
everything's covered I see the
evaluation board is quite high in mags's
favor he's got a huge Advantage I'm not
denying that but the good news for ala
is he can concentrate only on one flank
and that white King on F2 it's safely
tucked away but perhaps there will be
tactics in front of it that ala he's one
of the best on the planet if he can drum
them up it could scare Magnus and right
now the other one of the best on the
planet vesley so against Fabiano Karana
and this one ended Fabby puts a stop to
Wesley so's dream run the first to take
down Wesley Fabby will go into survival
stage high and Spirits after that win
high in spirits the third seed Pocket
another $1,000 what's not to love if
you're a Fabiano caruana fan but all
eyes now on this one the other two
Armageddon games are done and in this
game it looks like Magnus he does have
the upper hand he's the one who's been
dictating the action but I see the eval
bar David it's not that high in White's
face
yeah it feels like Magnus has been uh
playing for the clock as well Magnus may
be getting excited rightly so about his
position I really don't like this last
move simply because it's trading off one
of Black's bad pieces Black's Knight on
H5 has been a bystander it's just been
watching the action from AAR not
participating now Magnus is trading it
off and uh maybe it's just the fact that
less material will be on the board
increasing Black's drawing chances maybe
the white king will suddenly become a
bit weaker either way Magnus still
bossing this position still with seven
extra minutes maybe that's the key
factor and still with the extra porn so
still good for white but maybe not as
clinical as decisive as it could have
been but is it surprising how long uh
fuja is taking to make this decision the
knight's been challenged it's a night
that you want to trade you don't want to
fall back on the board with that Knight
allowing White's other Knight to jump
further onto the center of the board to
that nice Knight E5 Square after
thinking for almost over a minute he
makes the move that perhaps you make in
seconds and I thought he was going to
follow it up quickly I really thought he
was considering his second move in that
sequence but no has not played yet and
we have to remind everybody that once
they reach move 60 the players get a 1se
second bonus with every move so you can
avoid flagging losing on time if you get
to move 60 and I think Ali RZA his
position is improving if Magnus takes
with the Rook that black knight can step
backwards towards F7 and that white King
on F2 it's been sitting there for a long
time it's not sitting so safely after
this turn of events because the pawn on
H4 is loose yeah big moment ala found
the key moves but it took him so much
time will 1 minute 42 be enough to get
to the end of this game Magnus could not
go for that he took with a pawn instead
but your idea Robert still persists
Knight takes Pawn is incoming watch out
for this black queen to slide as well
across to the diagonal the white king
not entirely safe of course the black
king a bit vulnerable as well but at
this point alaza it's step one
randomized the position and he has
achieved that he's Clinging On he's
fighting hard and we suddenly see
magnus's body language he uh realizes he
needs to focus he has let it slip
slightly he seemed pretty upset there
the way he just gave a Grimace he's
understanding that a lot of his
Advantage was in that Dynamic play there
aren't so many Dynamics here black is
only one Pawn down and if that G5 Pawn
is lost you'll be no material down the
black king it's on an open Line a rook
can give it a check it's only one check
T I don't see mates and I think that
Magnus he's realizing that this position
is much more difficult than perhaps he
realized and even if white wants to
achieve the dream of getting the queen
and the Rook lined up on the H5 black
will simply slide over with his own rook
and everything's guarded and Suddenly
It's magnesis King that has to watch out
the material balance has been restored
are there there are are there any
threats of actually taking on G6 I'm
trying to do the calculation help me out
here Knight takes Pawn is that on the
radar here wow let's check it out
because that's either very strong or it
has a floor that would allow fuia to
escape Knight takes porn here super
tempting unleashing an attack now
against this Knight a double attack
Black's King pretty much obliged to take
this Knight the black queen as well
threat and your idea Tanya would be to
play F4 attacking uh this Knight and I
think the answer is yes you do regain
the material you will be an extra Pawn
up but maybe the answer is uh maybe the
answer is simp you don't want to trade
Knights this idea is stronger than the
actual execution Black's Queen now could
come in for example watch out some back
door action here with the King and if we
just pause on this position after The
Rook takes G5 and the King moves back to
F7 if the Queens get traded this looks
like a drawn Rook end game so that's the
problem is it's only one extra Pawn I
know we joke all rooking games are drawn
this one without the queens of the board
would likely be a draw so Magnus has to
be careful here because Ali Raza he beat
Magnus in the bullet chest Championship
on chess.com several months ago he has
what it takes to make all those moves in
a scramble yeah and I think uh whether
or not this position is strong it would
be a practical decision uh with so much
extra time on the clock not to uh kind
of clear the air here not to resolve the
tension maybe it's just uh about keeping
uh things going push on the other side
of the board just kind of move around
with your queen wait because black is
actually in a bit of a pin and a bit of
a pickle actually on the G file and uh
yeah right now I do not advise
clarifying that even with flashy tactics
it's better to sit and wait uh Magnus
Carlson key moment for him seven minutes
against one and a half what's he going
for it does look like he's going to okay
I was going to say going for that tactic
but he plants a queen on E5 big big
threat White's Rook if it slides shifts
that would be a deadly check but fua
Retreats and Magnus looks up in the air
looks off to the left has he blundered
what he missed he missed that move I
guess that it attacks the queen and
defends the Checkmate the attack will
rage on the black king has to step back
here I don't think that ala feels safe
but at least he is making some progress
so much tension the nerves are high
absolute chaos in the board and if
you're looking for some Chill on your
life we've got some good news for you
because there is a chess.com and ly girl
giveaway we're giving away a signed vyl
uh record copy and it'll be signed by
the winner of the Champions Chester
final check out our social media
channels for all the details and we need
to get into further details about this
position we've been having some great
music all the lowii chill stuff but this
position is anything but chill yeah no
longer chill for Magnus Carlson who
really looks disappointed with himself
there he's let it slip his material
advantage has gone he still has his time
Advantage but uh suddenly the black is
defending black is holding everything
Alara fio he's built this comfort zone
for the black king and uh oh suddenly a
look off at the clock there for alare
maybe not realizing how dramatic it is
on the clock one minute left I actually
prefer Black's position now in Practical
terms it looks like Black's got
everything covered motoring forward now
wow this is asking the White Knight to
leap forward with a check but Black's
King is super safe three pawns for
shelter allesa doing everything right on
the board but it will be the clock that
decides this one this is courage on the
chess board pushing Pawns in front of
your own King while you're under attack
but he understands that white doesn't
have too many attackers so many pieces
have been traded off 56 seconds for
black it's move 37 he's got less than
about 2 seconds per move it would seem
and he needs to play quickly their night
Forks in the air yeah and it's still 22
moves to go before they get that 1
second increment going and this kind of
a position it's hard to imagine it's
surviving for the next 20 moves anything
can happen but it looks like it is
Advantage ala because he needs only a
draw to wrap up the match while it's on
Magnus to find winning chances in the
position I love how Ali rza's Knight on
F7 controls so many key squares near the
king and he's going going for
liquidation here and ala shaking his
head he's miscalculated he pushed the
pawn trying to clear the tension but
suddenly the black Queen's attack the
black Rook is vulnerable he cannot take
this Pawn back it is poisoned he needs
to move the black queen away needs to
make it fast he's got under 30 seconds
he's got 20 moves to make so he's about
to have a second per move Queen h8 is a
great move by Al that Queen is about to
jump into the white camp on H2 but the
Rook trade is offered Al is thinking he
needs to
move check is he going to find a
Perpetual can he repeat with checks
right now he L picking up the Rook he
does it now for ala this is so important
it could very well be the last few
moments in his race to win the
championship 19 seconds for 18 moves
that's physically almost impossible over
the board at least and white still has
an extra porn objectively he's fine
white king is too weak black can give a
bunch of checks but look at this he's
pausing he's Frozen and look at him he
makes the best move and he Auto
recapture you got to go no his hand
speed is not quick enough he's nervous
there are no pre moves here you've got
to make the moves how do you make so
many moves in just 12 seconds on the
clock and he's not fast enough Magnus
can just surprise him play some odd
moves some checks here right now and I
don't think he's going to be able to
make the move 60 uh he won't have enough
time simply the pawn pushes forward
objectively now as well it's getting
difficult he drops his Queen back white
can now just move forward with the King
keep pushing looks winning for Magnus
suddenly as well on the board these are
the last few moments it looks like for
Ali razar's race in the Champions chest
off final
Magnus Carlson winning on the clock on
the board right now alira needs a
miracle to survive this one he's got 10
seconds 14 moves to get that 1 second
increment but I don't think that's going
to help him given the position on the
board he's also completely lost over the
board so Magnus way too much time he's
just trying to calculate can I trade
those Queens the answer should be yes I
think if he trades the Queens he's still
in a winning position and for ala it
might have been too low of a bid 9
minutes to start the game against Magnus
Carlson he'll be regretting that I think
more than anything but he really created
his chances he was so resilient in
handling the attack and creating
counterplay well there is this F Pawn
you need to stop it from moving to F2 so
Magnus going to retreat with the Knight
or will he continue pushing the E Pawn
he Retreats no risk yeah no risk no
reason to risk and look at the clock
ala's time in this tournament is running
out one second
and alza is flagged Magnus Carlson gets
the win ala fua eliminated
what a devastating way to go winning
game one but Magnus Carlson shows why he
has been the best player in the world
for well over a decade he's just there
when it counts in those big moments he's
able to outlast his opposition and for
Ali Raa he gave the number one player
all he could handle but it was too
little at the end a heartbreaking moment
for ala fua so close after getting that
first game win in this matchup but
Magnus Carlson makes his comeback in
second game and then takes it in a
roller coaster of an armagen and Magnus
isn't the only one who's happy about it
hiar Nakamura books his spot into
survival with that win by Magnus Carlson
Fabby the first player to take down
Wesley so and uh it was nbec Abdus satov
who beat Maxim Vash lra what an armagen
David an absolute roller coaster a
roller coaster great news for Hikaru
Nakamura but heartbreak for Alara fua
and it was in this position where he
done everything right he'd fought back
so well that things started to go uh
wrong Pawn to E5 already a
miscalculation because of the clock here
and he panicked after Pawn takes Pawn
due to pressure against the black Rook
black simply cannot take back on E5 he
did drop his Queen back though finding
the best moves time and time again after
a rook trade again a check best move
again taking the Rook best move again G4
But ultimately he didn't have enough
time on the clock and now he started to
go wrong giving checks to the white king
when instead taking this Pawn would have
maybe secured a draw but simply it was
the clock the decisive Factor Magnus
Carson too quick in the end he checked
the king the king actually was used as a
weapon in the end game and this was a
really heartbreaking moment for Ali Raza
but Magnus he fought to the very end he
didn't give up like some people thought
that he might just to eliminate hikaro
Nakamura hikaro Nakamura lives on un for
for ala he is sent
home so what and Armageddon that was in
so much on the line and it means it's
the end of the road for Denis lavic and
alira fuja while Hikaru gets in and
these are our final standings Wesley so
Magnus Carlton get the rest of the day
off we will be back with more
subscribers don't go anywhere cuz we've
got a really really cool interview of
Magnus Carlson and Manchester City's Pep
Guardiola talking chess and football the
full interview is also on but check this
side
[Music]
subscribers
I feel good I was ready to I was ready
to play more how does 7 and a half hours
on the touchine sound to you today
thanks to pummer we're bringing two
Geniuses together from the world of
football and the world of Chess we are
joined by Pep Guardiola and Magnus
Carlson thank you for joining us we're
going to take a look at your greatest
moves and let's start with a clip that
many City fans will probably remember
yeah I remember because this season is
uh it's Clos and everyone you see the
image and everyone is in his position
and yeah sometimes you know mag said you
are in their left side you know and now
attack a right side he had to be quicker
so now you need this kind of situations
you know actions one against one be
patient in the right moment punish them
how is the moment here go them left mov
in the right runs in behind and finish
46 passes in that move Magnus that's um
very very impressive how important is is
patience in chess as well cuz pep just
spoke about the the patients and the
buildup and and stuff like that as well
that's often what happens in chess you
maneuver you maneuver try to find
weaknesses and then crack appears and
then it all you know goes very very
quickly but once you mentioned that it's
fting against the forest I I remembered
the goal and I was really looking
forward to the last move cuz it's really
beautiful another display of attacking
Mastery what do you remember about this
my this was like a typical counter
Counterattack like I was being pressured
most of the game then he made one
mistake four or five uh quick moves you
know with Checkmate on the other side it
was indeed but you actually played a
game against Ian which lasted so so long
s and a half
hours 136 moves first things first how
were you feeling after that marathon
when you played against him I feel good
I was ready to I was ready to play more
yeah because that's because that was the
key breakthrough that was uh the moment
I've been waiting for for the first six
um games of of of that match and I
remember like I was so calm so focused
for the last two two and a half hours I
was playing with fairly little time on
my clock but I knew like this is my
chance like if I win if I win this game
I'm probably winning Another World
Championship so I knew that that was uh
that was my moment and um I was ready to
go like three more hours if if I needed
to I was I was going to get that win pep
how does 7 and 1 half hours on the touch
line sound to you
way no way no
[Music]
way Magnus Carlson the world number one
multiple time world champion and winner
of the previous two editions of the
Champions chess tour Magnus has played
every opening under the sun he even has
a variation of the Sicilian named after
him so after E4 C5 Magnus started
playing Knight C3 a few years ago with
the idea that he could open the center
immediately by playing D4 actually going
against conventional chess wisdom of
developing the White Queen very early
but the whole idea here is that after
the queen gets kicked away she's happy
to step back and for example if black
continues us to develop normally white
just creates a fan ketto gets the bishop
to a nice diagonal and later castles on
the queen side actually a very
aggressive opening not technically part
of magnus' Style magnus's real recipe
for success is that he adopts his
strategy according to the opponent he's
able to do anything with a very
Universal style and if you get him in
the end game there's no chance he's
perhaps the best endgame player of all
time and you can go and check out some
of his ideas some of his thoughts on the
end game in his chest ball courses
a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
Toronto is the place to be Toronto is
where the drama is real I feel like I'm
opening into some sort of I wish I could
freestyle rap monologue but I can't but
I I don't even know how to unpack what
we just saw guys my heart is still in my
chest I me I would hope so where else
we've got we've got so much to unpack
let's make sure we don't keep anyone
waiting who might be tuning in right now
and show you where we sit we officially
know who's still dancing in Toronto
who's going home this is the survival
stage Carana Abdus turov abash the grav
and Nakamura and some of the most
dramatic moments we've ever had in
professional chess that we're going to
unpack but th those are the matchups
boys we're going to preview those in a
second but okay let's let's back this
thing up and talk about what just
happened Levy I'm going to start with
you we're watching it on a million and a
half different monitors no matter where
you go you can't escape that the drama
was just insane fuja goes home Magnus
saves Hikaru yeah what do you got uh it
this is rigged it's all rigged allig for
Ratings all rigged we know everybody
wants to watch Magnus literally saves
cararo in the most dramatic way possible
which is he loses the first rapid game
then he wins the second rapid game with
black they go to eddon and he he he
botches the attack but fua just goes
into the tank and he has too many moves
to make with too little time and Magnus
saves hiar it could have been a movie in
fact as you he mentioned before with the
Harry Potter thing he saves him like you
know what I hate you but I'll save you
anyway little buddy and he saved him
here of course as Nakamura still in fuja
goes home it was crazy it was scripted
cuz fuja I'm like oh he swung he hit him
like Magnus oh psych you know a little
blood there H and then he wins the game
right he wins the whole match as always
Le called it I mean you literally
couldn't have written a more dramatic
way to have every single person in this
building you can just hear the sound of
hikaro Nakamura squeezing the pillow in
his hotel room up there watching as
Magnus Carlson delivers and keeps his
championship chess tour the finals here
alive uh but Magnus was the guy who
saved the day for hikara when he caught
up with Kaa right after the
game Magnus Carlson wins the match saves
hikara Nakamura how are you right now
Magnus no I'm I'm good so um I thought I
did everything right for a long time and
then I don't know I think I
just relaxed a bit too early because I
thought that I'm completely winning and
then he started to to fight back and
yeah I gave away all my my Edge and at
that point I was just trying to keep
find a way to keep the game going um and
um yeah um it I always had it going for
me that it was a long way till move 61
so I thought as long as I can as long as
there's some Hope on the board then I
can maybe flag him but yeah was a mess
it has looked like a good round stage
for you anyhow the only loss against
Wesley so there so how will you summon
up now heading into semi-finals for you
tomorrow um yeah again today was more a
day of practice than anything else but
um yeah I'm very happy with six out of
seven of course um and um you know I'll
be following the um survival stage with
uh as a fan which um I think is a lot
more pleasant than playing it you have
any like hope for who you will play in
the semi-finals Wesley so obviously gets
that pick no I haven't thought about
that um no not really so what will be on
the top of your wish list for Christmas
for from hikaro
Nakamura
no I I I I I don't know um I think
um yeah he's
done he's done his job today winning a
couple of games so U I'm sure he feels
really good about uh his second chance
in the tournament and um you know if he
can uh if he can make it to the
semi-finals he's certainly a dangerous
opponent yeah he said yesterday you
wouldn't mind hikaro being knocked out
but for the fans do you agree that it is
cool to have Hikari there uh for the
rest of the tournament or semi-finals at
least yeah having ala would have been
fun as well but
um there is no doubt that tar has the um
has the skills has the potential to um
be a very difficult opponent now for
from for anybody from from now on so
what will you do rest of the day now
when you have the day off um I don't
know I'll I think I'll watch a bit of
football um I guess I'm right in time
for uh for that you know the United
Baron game sounds very enticing
so I'll just relax enjoy Manchester
United have to win will you be rooting
for them no no all right Magnus thank
you congrats on your win here thank you
all right he wins six matches here Magus
Carlson ready for semi-finals back to
you
guys the goat goes full Magnus Carlson
and gets the job done versus Ali Resa
fuia KY there's our full page breakdown
of the stats of this matchup your
thoughts yeah in fact the thought that I
don't like the most is well he was under
90% what is that Magnus that's a failure
right of course under 90% what is he
doing no I'm kidding at the same time
shows that it was very close there fza
just wasn't able to get it done but
Magnus did even with 89% accuracy under
90 which is uh his uh what he's been
doing all day it just seemed like a bit
of a nervy match right for both of them
to have 89 and 88 uh for fuja it was a
huge moment because you could have
started in a better way like to win with
black and all you have to do is then end
the the match with the white pieces
which is actually even guys like Fabiano
Carana have said being up one- nothing
and playing white is actually a lot
harder than it seems because you want to
play a game but you don't want to play a
game the second you get you get a game
on the board there's a chance that you
might actually lose so that's all that's
all I really took away from that but I
think experience prevailed there yeah
I've got one big question here okay does
Magnus come to regret hiar Nakamura is
still being in this
tournament
oh you called it scripted yeah yeah
we're going to see what happens Nakamura
we're going to see what happens when you
go when you go full Nakamura oh man
we've uh we've got a lot ahead of course
two more matches still today so don't go
anywhere but Kaaya also caught up with
one of the other winners of the
Armageddon battles that just took
place here with uh what of the happiest
guys in the venue right now of dor of
making it uh top four to play uh on the
winners bracket how are you feeling
about that right now yeah I'm feeling
great um yeah very very glad to to to
get um this winners bracket because you
know it's very important it's you have
to play less games and
probably uh you know you saves energy so
yeah that was really important for me
before I ask you more questions so
what's going to happen later today this
armagedon game was just crushing from
you take us through what happened here
yeah I played um R Lopez and um you know
one of the reasons that I play it
because you know you get you get to play
more moves that you know because you
know opening is so so deep and uh you
know in marketing it's it makes sense
you know to just to play long lines
because you know it's it gets you closer
to the mo 61 so yeah and uh yeah it went
well for me and
uh uh I think I got a very quite a
decent position out the opening
and uh when he played F4 I I thought
okay that's that should be not good and
you know I I I already had some ideas
with h with C4 but when he play King H2
then okay Knight G4 is is kind of asking
for Knight G4 so yeah it's uh you know
I after Knight G4 King G3 I just saw you
know Rook three and something should
should work out because you know his
King is so weak and um yeah it's it went
it worked well oh it definitely did now
we have to talk about what's going to
happen later so you're entering now
survival stage will play on the winners
bracket to face Fabiano Carana so how do
you see your chances now of going
through to the semi-finals oh is it
clear that I play I play Fabiano yes
then okay um yeah it's going to be of
course very tough match
although I beat him um 2N in this
tournament in this uh round robin stage
it doesn't mean anything so yeah we'll
get a new game and new uh new new fight
what does it mean to have two lives now
for the rest of the day
here oh it's very
um you know back in your mind you you
have you know you have a feeling that
you know you you have still one more
chance even if you lose so it's kind of
tricky because it might get you to you
know to
play um bit relaxed but no I mean that's
that should be not be the case and you
know you have to be fully focused fully
focused good luck in the survival stage
nor be and congrats on your armagan
thank you thank you for joining us all
right he's G to face Fabiano Carana
later today back to you
guys I thought we might see a full game
break breakdown there by NY going over
all the lines in his head but here's our
full game review Levy your thoughts on
what pops
out uh noer backck has been on fire 96%
accuracy detonating against mvl but this
is a very different set of circumstances
I feel as though if you play in a
matchup where it's just you know we both
make it no matter what it's a little bit
hard to maybe get in the zone as much
but this is the survival stage so yes
they have one LIF po right like they
have to be a little bit careful but what
I my major takeway is I was wrong
earlier today and Nock is like he he's
out to get him yeah I think he's got a
little bit of a chip on his shoulder I
thought nvl would show up the experience
would Prevail but yeah noser backck was
a beast monster I think he doing some
chess boxing in fact I mean the way that
he was swinging on mvl bro youall know
this is a family channel right like we
are this is on kids watching you know
what I'm saying look that was very
brutal what he did to MV there he's also
up now in their in their head-to-head
it's like six to now to seven to two
yeah that's crazy he's just going off so
this is a new notb and we're seeing his
survival St is going to tell a lot about
the rest of the tournaments yep let's
remind everybody of where we sit we've
talked about the matches if you're just
tuning in this is official the survival
stage is set Fabiano Carana will take on
Notre Beck Abdus turov Maxim Bashi lrav
will play hikaro Nakamura and remember
the winner of the 56 match plays the
loser of the 34 match so as we said it's
NBA tournament playing style for those
who are National Basketball Association
fans carwan and abusa turov have a
second life so uh your thoughts on any
of those four players who has the most
momentum I feel like so many of them are
there because they had very real ups and
downs here in the initial round robin
stage but give me your player to watch
oh player I meaner I gotta say hikaro
right second second chance in the event
didn't even control his own destiny
really I mean we who controlled his
hikaru's Destiny Moore in the last round
was it the match at Magnus fua or was it
Hikaru himself he he did his job and he
was in good spirits we saw him out in
the playing Hall but I would argue that
that matchup really controlled his fate
a little bit more and it was really
Topsy tury but he must be feeling
rejuvenated and I mean if you're
comparing Magnus or mvl mvl just right
like he had you know he lost but
whatever he was already in so he might
be a little bit relaxed while hiar was
going to be a you know breath of fresh
air I mean I'm not to take everybody's
names out of out of your mouth but like
Fabiano Carana just took down the guy
who winning the event 6 and0 so like we
got we can watch everybody we will watch
everybody yeah I was actually into hearo
myself too as well that's what I was
going to pick I was like hikaro it's a
new hikaro it's like all right cool all
that is in the past literally every game
now is in the past I mean if we check
the graphic here 965 there he was ready
he felt better
96% right most accurate match of the
tournament so far you were right maybe
that the late night Blitz last night on
chess.com was was working out and I said
I didn't think it was all frustration I
think he I think he was trying to rev
his own engines up and he did so he's
got 96% there in that match and uh okay
it's hard to say he car's maybe not the
player to watch but I'm going to say
Notre Beck as well I mean this kid just
ran a train wreck and he's the highest
seat or I guess with Carana either way
whoever wins that match directly seated
so of course so much chess to be played
and we're going to have all the action
here but uh oh man I'm still just a
little my heart my heart's a little bit
that was crazy a little bit you know
here but it's it's this is this is
insanely exciting and the format
continues to roll on the format
continues to deliver let's remind
everybody with our new explainer kind of
breakdown of where we sit what we have
here for the remaining days in
Toronto with the completion of the round
robin stage our top two finishers Wesley
so and Magnus Carlson Advance directly
to the semi-finals while Ali Resa fua
and Dennis lavic have been
eliminated the remaining four players
will do battle in a double elimination
survival bracket again the top two
players Advance while the bottom two
players will be eliminated the final
four Champions are headed to a single
elimination bracket the winner will be
crowned our champion of
[Music]
champions this is insane this is
exciting I don't know that the players
have ever felt this much pressure except
for maybe one other time that's right
one other time which was before the
tournament kicked off and we played a
little game of white elephant our
holiday party the pressure the
calculation outsmarting your opponent to
make sure you really got the gift you
wanted chess players in a social setting
chess players in a social setting things
were awkward things were weird things
got real and if you haven't seen this
video yet you're going to enjoy it and
we'll be back on the other side to get
set for the first round of the survival
stage
enjoy welcome everyone to the first ever
chess.com holiday party we're here with
the eight well seven of the Champions
chess T finalists one of them is not
here but lucky for us as Santa I already
knew that one of the gifts might come in
in real handy so what we've got here is
a uh is a gift that keeps on giving for
some lucky lady out there right there
we're going to put Magnus right here in
between Maxine and Hikaru but let me
explain the rules real quick we have
eight numbers in here everyone here is
going to pick a number to decide the
order in which they go to choose the
presents in front the present can be
stolen if you like what someone else
gets you don't even have to pick a
present you can just steal their present
from them but once the present has been
stolen twice it is officially frozen you
can never steal that present again at
the end of the game whichever one of you
gets the number one gets to choose
whether to keep your present or make one
final steal to get the gift you want so
I'm going to go around
here I'm going to take the last number
lot like our fair play you know judge
jury and execute tioner over here right
hey there you go insert joke who's
number
one okay next B the gr starts us off
let's do it well I guess this for my
guests look at that I know what you guys
thought you guys thought you were
showing up and every gift was going to
be a joke no it's not that's a Nintendo
switch M play that every day I'm Number
Two okay I have the the best number the
worst number wor are that worse than
eight oh eight is a second bestest oh
really yeah cuz a you get to have all
the information chice thank
you I got a box what's in the box I have
a smaller
box I got airpods wow number three okay
number three here we go are you stealing
no I'm picking this big oh sweeter every
white elephant has to have an ugly
Christmas sweater and you're the one who
got it okay all right who's four
[Laughter]
okay show it to the
camera you can cook
theight you can bring it back to
front Dennis here we go okay is that
magnet show it to the camera the proud
owner here we go
all right the car is shaking shaking
vague or is he
stealing who that
Danny that was not my idea all I'm going
to to use this one here I don't know
what it is but I feel like Magnus might
want it certificate of disposition and
Proclamation lord of the bong Cloud
opening okay I'm I'm a lord of the bong
Cloud here we go Wesley I'm GNA steal
yeah yeah it's hard to choose I see I
see P airpod okay that's fair okay
airpods have been stolen it's official
game on wait what happens if I steal his
gift who gets to go after that does
Maxine Maxine gets to go and he can't
steal it right back he has to steal
something else well he'll take the
airpods are youing you don't know that
maybe he wants the map so we have to
keep the game going so I'm taking your
all right okay now this is your chance
you steal a
[Music]
niche okay he's rolling the dice he
loves a niche that much okay Dennis
you've been set free so are you really
going to keep that in your flat or are
you going to give it to Anie are you
I'll figure it out you put it by your
you put it by your bedroom yeah all
right what do you think oh you got the
switch okay Dennis loic officially owns
the switch party in his room tonight I
guess I'm taking he's taking the air
airpods are off the table which means
Wesley you have the power to choose a
new gift steal the an nishe yeah give I
mean I actually don't know what this one
is oh my gosh what is it are you
kidding oh yeah they might with that
you're you're paying right yeah that's
okay good ab thank you and but he is
kind of The Unofficial CEO of CH he is
he is it goes for a lot I'll keep it
okay there we go that's it and that
everyone was our first ever white
elephant brought to you by chess.com and
n giri thank you CEO of chess.com right
there we really appreciate it I could
[Music]
have I'm so excited that Anish was
willing to sign that for us gave us the
gift personally for this white elephant
but Levy anything you would have wanted
out of all that no that was everything I
could have ever imagined maybe just
Magnus and the gift Wap in the corner
something like that with that Gary photo
in the date night with Danny you know oh
my gosh I didn't know half those gifts
were coming but it was good stuff and
I'm glad that uh we don't need to see
those socks anymore you know the socks
are put away so all right it's time for
us to throw this thing away across the
pond to Tanya Robert and David who are
going to have the call as we get set for
the first matches in our survival stage
we get to go back to being fans Tanya
take it away hey guys we want our gifts
as well I mean that was really cool I
want a set of airpods I was just on my
phone texting why didn't I get a gift
like they sent me out to freezing Oslo
you don't give me a gift Danny I'm mad
at you what about you David if you could
pick any one of them uh I've taken the
airpods a the photo Anish we all love
him yes we do and right now we're loving
the chess action that we're getting as
well and it continues we go into
survival stage four players are in it
two will be eliminated but there is a
difference between finishing third
fourth and fifth and sixth Robert talk
us through that yeah if you're third or
fourth that's not Beck and Fabiano you
get two lives so if you lose in that
match you get to play the winner of
Maxim bigra versus AAR Nakamura whereas
MBL and hikaro they just have one life
you lose the match you're gone that's
big stress on maxan Hikaru they are on
their last life one of the two will be
eliminated at the end of the of the day
we'll have two more players who will be
packing up their bags Hikaru Nakamura
did make it into survival after Ali Reza
went down to Magnus Carlson but I also
want to take a moment to just talk about
Dennis Lac yes he doesn't make it into
survival stage but excellent excellent
effort by him well Dennis lazik is a
really strong player if a couple matches
had gone a little bit differently we
might be talking about him in the
survival stage I do think he took a
premature draw against Ali Raza fuja
that second game of the match he was
better with the white piece he could
have pressed he didn't and he ends up
going home yeah small marins at this
level and here we see a handshake
between uh third and fourth place in the
uh round robin stage kowana and Abdu
satoro and Maxim Vash grv he is one with
just one life now and he needs to play a
bit better a bit faster bit stronger
than he has been doing so far this
tournament let's remind everyone that
Maxim vagra did beat Hikaru in the round
robin stage meanwhile NC took down
Fabiano Karana as well in the round
robin stage so for Hikaru and Fabby also
a grudge match yeah they need to change
things up especially Fabiano who lost to
NOAB twice in the chest Cup and the
Olympiad last year there's history there
and these two have so much history
playing each other in all formats all
time controls online in person you name
it they've done it is Hikaru wearing the
Danny socks what do we know about that
he's wearing his lucky sweater that's
for sure and uh I think we'll be seeing
a beginning to this game very shortly
how will Nakamura react to being given a
second lease of life that's the big
question that is the big question right
now and chess will be underway as the
players are ready ready to go for maxim
and Hikaru this is their last life it is
a best of two if tied it goes into
Armageddon one of these two will be
eliminated you hear the Arbiter just
turn the rule so why don't we listen in
as well you say 60 Minutes 60
seconds sorry about that thank you and
it's go time 1 E4 1 E4 Maxine vash's
trademark move and a Sicilian Defense
we'll get that live board uh working
catching up with games there we are and
uh wow Deja Vu Nakamura has had this
position multiple times so far at this
tournament including just yesterday
against Fabiano kowana and uh this is
the bishop B5 variation of the Sicilian
nothing open yet nothing aggressive
about it but we'll see their intentions
just on the next few turns it's a
different Hikaru though because if we
talk about emotions and we knew Hikaru
was really upset coming today he didn't
control his own fate now he does if he
takes down Maxim and then the loser of n
back against Fabiano he'll make his way
through to the final four the
semi-finals so for Hikaru I think he can
breathe a side of relief it doesn't get
easier you're playing Maxim vagra but at
least he can control what happens next y
Nakamura normally in these tournament
situations these kind of great sporting
moments in history we see people somehow
survive somehow qualify last minute by
the Skin of Their Teeth they suddenly
get inspired so we'll see how Nakamura
reacts and while we wait for that we
will jump over to our other survival
match and this is between Fabiano Carana
and nbec they are in the winners bracket
of the survival stage which means that
they've got two lives and uh for Fabby
he starts with the Kings Pawn opening
whoever wins this match goes straight
into semi finals so definitely looking
at securing that spot because at this
stage of the tournament you want to play
as less number of games as possible it's
only going to get more tough from
Tomorrow energy is vital right now but
no recabar he is all the energ in the
world let's not forget that he was stuck
on his travels here he was stuck for
over a week in Germany he came here said
h no problem he lost the first two
matches he played in he stormed back
he's been playing really good chess in
the round robin stage he should continue
that here in the survival yeah it feels
like he has the upper hand
psychologically Abdu satoro he's just
been playing so well Robert mentioned
their track record their history this
season he's beaten Fabiano in two
matches he won 20-0 in the round robin
he's beaten him so many times
historically and look how fast they're
playing up to this point we now have
already 15 moves on the board and uh
neither side has really paused For
Thought actually looking at the clock
they've gained a bunch of time and this
is how well they know each other by this
point this is how well they've uh
researched this opening the Spanish
opening Roy Lopez one of the most
classical openings out there in chess
one of the most historic and uh all
pieces on the board all pawns locked now
in the center this is promising a really
really tense fight ahead but fa's got to
be feeling good after taking down Wesley
so in that last round of the round Dr in
stage he has to be feeling the
confidence but look at that body
language both players playing some top
top level chess and it's uh Fabby who
goes into the first thing and nck has
managed to really expand on the queen
side he's already managed to get the
play going very often in these positions
white has to look out for breaks the
breaks could come from D5 C5 or B4 on
the board meanwhile uh Fabby a little kg
play just waiting for NC to take one of
those decisions there is some activity
on the queen side for Notre backck but
his Bishops are not really doing
anything they're staring into their own
pawns these decisions will not be easy
for either player which Pawn break is
the accepted one which one keeps the
status quo in terms of the evaluation
but I think Fabby has all of his pieces
on perfect squares now it's time to stop
caring about the Aesthetics and find a
legitimate plan yeah he's occupied the
center with his pawns he's done
everything right maneuvered his pieces
I'm liking that line on the third rank
of Whit's minor pieces but what to do
next as Robert says that's always the
biggest question so we will see play
start to slow down now we've reached the
end of both players knowledge in terms
of the opening or at least Fabiano's
knowledge and it's all about maneuvering
all about when to pull the trigger when
to break out in the center trade stuff
off for the first time um I think we'll
see a very KY battle as T put it
continue well I'm expecting nbec at some
point to force Fabby to take decision in
the center with a move like the C Pawn
moving forward to C5 but for now until
there's a break things are even and this
one is developing we will move on to our
other battle which is in the losers
bracket of the survival stage both
players uh only one will make it through
after this match and uh Hikaru Nakamura
with that last move whenever the queen
and the bishop lines up like this to me
it's you've got to get those Spidey
senses going that you know Bishop takes
Pawn on the king side always in the air
yeah the good thing for maxim is he does
have that side of the board under his
control but you do need to watch out for
a sacrifice on the H3 square and this
game resembles the other game in the
sense that there haven't been any trades
we have all pieces still on the board
David what are these players doing when
are the trades going to start yeah uh
I'm hoping soon because this is too
complicated there's too much to handle
uh I certainly prefer simplified
positions but these players are saying
they trust themselves and uh trades
could start when for example one side
decides to go for the center of the
board for example white can push forward
himself with D4 in the next few turns
black may try to do the same by pushing
a pawn himself Maxim says no trades for
you yes these Bishops are staring each
other but uh they want to trade on their
own terms Maxim goes back with his
Knight he's cleared a path for the White
Queen to come forward watch out for the
White's Knight to LEAP to G4 very
typical ideas here white wants to be
playing on the king side black meanwhile
needs to decide when maybe even now to
break out in the center flank attack
versus Central play and I like the
control of that D5 square that both
players are fighting for and something
important not is that Knight on C6 isn't
really doing all that much that pawn on
C3 it limits its access up the board so
I do think that I would prefer to have
the white side your queen F3 Knight G4
ideas they feel very standard and
obvious and for black that D5 push it
can either be a good choice expanding
the center or could be very
consequential white can still play Queen
F3 there's going to be a knight coming
to G4 Knight coming to F5 it has the
Brewings of an attack yeah Black's
Central edifice here is a bit
uh it's a bit vulnerable it is a bit
loose you need to decide whether to
close it allow white a free hand on the
king side or whether to open things up
but actually this level of symmetry
still gives promising chances to the
first player to White due to the access
to these holes so that's why Hikaru
Nakamura is pausing thinking right now
he wants to clarify the tension he wants
to solve his issues by forcing the issue
here and offering a trade trying to
persuade white to part with the
beautiful light Squad Bishop I think
Maxim will say no after Knight to A5 he
can just drop back if he wants to keep
that balance all the pieces on the board
I would agree with that you don't want
to give up that light Squad bishop and
it's also such a useful piece once you
get the Deep on moving forward the
positions are extremely strategic slow
play by the players right now and we're
going to head to Toronto where you got
internet's favorite teacher with us to
tell us more about the action the
tension all of that that's coming on
from Toronto levie what's
up hey Tanya I'm not sure I'm the most
qualified to discuss closed strategic
positions but I'm definitely very
curious about this matchup it's a tale
of two days it's Karu on uh using his
second out of nine lives uh and it's mvl
who obviously just lost to ner backck in
a really really convincing match uh from
noer Beck's side so how have you all
been enjoying the action and who do you
think has the advantage in this matchup
well Levy it's funny because I was about
to ask you so much has been said about
Hikaru struggles NBL really has not been
that much better at least by his own
standard so I think that in this matchup
both players they have their fair shot
but I I'm just curious have you noticed
anything from Maxim has he been upset at
all with his
results no Maxim is like the most chill
relaxed guy ever yesterday we shook
hands we've never actually had an
opportunity to meet in person I feel
like over the last three years this is a
very common phenomenon you have all
these online Zoom meetings and Microsoft
teams and then you realize wait a minute
we've never actually had an opportunity
to uh talk face to face so he's he's
very nice he's having a great time but
he's probably not feeling as good in the
playing Hall at the moment which is why
it's called the survival stage uh but
he's in a very very tense match I think
he played an opening he doesn't play all
that much I mean you you guys have the
opening database but is mvl a Rosal limo
uh essayer he's normally going for the
open positions he he's happy to play
into the Berlin um but it seems as
though he's trying to maybe get into an
unfamiliar battle with hikaro who I will
say I don't know if this has been
brought up anywhere Hikaru has gained
something like 15 to 20 rapid rating
points he lost four matches in
Armageddon so he's actually had a pretty
good event but he was still on the verge
of elimination which is something to be
said for the format I I did find that
pretty interesting and uh Levy we've
been talking about the chess uh you
obviously missed the first couple of
days due to covid but now you're on site
hanging out with the players what's been
the highlight for you so
far oh I love it here uh I was here last
year as well it was a slightly more
relaxed atmosphere the best example of
that I can give you is like after every
day you know Anish giri and I would go
to dinner and we would all have some
some Robert was here I mean it it was uh
I think Robert was here unless my memory
is failing me but it was a very very
kind of chill relaxed atmosphere last
year and this year there's a little bit
of that but it's still it's pretty
Cutthroat I mean you've got some you got
the top three players in the world by
classical rating there's a lot of money
up for grabs the production looks
incredible so I've had a great time and
and uh maybe next year we'll have all of
you in Toronto as well I don't know
it'll be a lot of fun oops sry go ahead
T it would be a lot of fun and hope we
can be there as well and I wanted to
check in with you we saw you know when
Magnus alira game was on Hikaru with all
the other players they were all watching
it could you feel that uh for Hikaru it
was a big moment and even though he
looked Chill on camera it was uh he was
stressed about that
matchup yeah I imagine it was pretty
stressful like I said in the game break
I didn't quite know what percent of that
situation depended on Hikaru and what
percent of it depended on the matchup
Magnus fuo like which one was actually
more influential of course hikaro was
the favorite in his match up against
lvic and he took care of business uh
hikaro was in much better spirits here
in the playing Hall he was chatting and
he was analyzing and everything a little
bit more than normal because he won his
match and he did everything that he
could uh but even then he came out and
he looked unhappy and I wondered why and
it was because he had a better way to to
win game one against loic so you got to
have a level of perfectionism where even
if you win you are not fully happy which
I suppose is a better you know
description of Chess in general uh and I
found that quite funny but now he's back
in there right I mean you just just go
right back and back to battle he is uh
back to battle and he looks very
determined right now and we got the
other matchup that we're going to bring
up Fabby versus Nock uh levie did you
manage to meet either of these guys you
mentioned that Maxim you never met
before but I'm guessing Fabby and you've
hung out what about nbec did you manage
to chill with him a little
bit well yeah I was away uh and I was
supposed to do a little bit of filming
with all of the players I'm still hoping
to get that uh in before the event ends
and I've got some fun questions I want
to ask everybody but Nock is completely
locked in first of all I'm not even sure
Nock knows who I am like I walked by and
I was like what's up and I think he
thought I worked at the hotel um I and
and you know like I said like oh hey
like you know good luck and he's just
razor focused and to his credit he does
have a chance to be the third seed if he
beats Fabiano right now NRE is giving
amazing interviews behind the scenes I'm
hearing and he's got a level of
confidence that uh his play backs up and
for a good reason this guy has very very
big dreams and he's been on fire he's
excellent in every single format and he
is the only player in this event not
named Magnus Carlson to hold the title
of world rapid Champion which now has an
opportunity to go in again in his home
country of usbekistan in just a couple
of weeks so super cool guy and amazing
competitor and it's really cool to see
we have 17 to 36 here right we have like
three or four generations of Chess uh
all you know in one building all
competing in this very unique format so
uh hopefully you have all been as
excited about all the action as I have
and uh Levy I'm going to be a bit mean
and put you on the spot here which of
these four players do you want to see
join Wesley and Magnus in the
semi-finals
oh that oh that's mean and I you know
I've got the games here in the
studio what is the best what is the best
matchup of
four oh man I mean you gota obviously we
we got to roote for the hikaro comeback
story and I just gave all that hype to
noer Beck and he's playing against
Fabiano oh this is mean y'all I mean
look I'm just going to come out and say
it I think it's got to if if we want the
highest level of Rapid chess currently
being played and like the the top
players in the world I don't think it
gets any better than Magnus Fabiano
Hikaru and Wesley so because you have
the top three players in the world by
classical chess you also have the
probably the top three players in the
world by performance overall in 2023 and
you have Wesley so who in Toronto is the
greatest player of all time so that's a
nasty combination of four and that would
be a crazy semi-final yeah I think we're
spoiled for choice to no matter who
makes it through we will have a good
final four but Levy in this position the
one that we have between Fabiano and
nordbeck I this is looking
quite quiet for now but wild in the
future I mean we could see the makings
of some kind of sacrifices blacks pieces
aimed at the white king uh there's also
a play in the center so what are you
making of This
Dynamic it's a really interesting
position because basically nck has to
strike uh we saw Fabiano come under a
very simil
type of attack in his game against fua
where fua put a knight on F4 which is
exactly where Black's Knight is
currently headed or it's going to
sacrifice on against the G3 Pawn but it
also sort of feels like if nerre doesn't
get a decisive attack white does have
certain advantages in the position white
will open up the dile white can Target
the C5 Pawn I'm not sure who I prefer
here I mean I I look at the position and
I don't exactly see Black's attack but
then like chess in 2023 is like you
think you know something about a
position and then stockfish is is like
telling you an evaluation so you're made
to think another way I don't know if you
all experience the same emotion
sometimes I'm sitting here looking at
the games going I I'm thinking something
of the position but stockfish say is
minus point7 so am I stupid the answer
is yes unequivocally um but I I like
White's position I I don't see blacks
attack developing that
fast all right lby you like White's
position I'm going to push back on that
I do like that the black pawns have
moved forward and there's play on the
left side of the board as well as
control with the queen and Knight on the
other side but it's still a long way to
go I actually have a non-chess question
for you right now earlier on we saw this
Christmas Christmas party where um it
was Wesley who ended up with a dinner
date with Dany if out of these players
you could hang out for dinner with any
one of them who' you go with totally
putting you on a spot everywhere oh
that's a wow that is a that is a good
question if I could have a dinner date
with any of these
players
um probably Fabiano like Fabiano is but
that's that's an easy one cuz I think he
he's he's just like he's just super cool
like super cool guy um that's like the
Comfort question that's that's like the
Comfort answer and I feel like uh maybe
maybe noes your back just to get to know
the guy right that that's like that's a
little bit more edgy and dangerous
because you you don't know somebody at
all so you have to make conversation
which is not always easy but uh we have
to be brave uh I think all of us are
introverts at heart once we get off the
broadcast we'll just go in our rooms and
scroll on our phones and are terrified
of social settings uh but uh probably
probably know you're because I don't
know much about the guy he's like total
mystery and that's the beautiful thing
about getting everybody in one building
uh is that you have an opportunity to to
get to know these players better which
which I find to be a lot of fun so uh
those are my two answers Magnus would
say no which is why I didn't say mag be
off somewhere doing his own thing and uh
Levy I want to ask you being on site in
person up close with these players
versus sitting at home streaming any
preference any preference well okay look
uh I think I think streamers leave the
house I think that's a common
misconception that perhaps they don't we
actually have evidence of that in two
forms here Hikaru and myself he's
definitely much more of a streamer than
I am I I take the I take the YouTuber
title now I don't do a whole lot of
streaming um but uh no I mean it's it's
it's all great uh it's all great I'm
probably saying that cuz the flight here
was about an hour uh if it was like 8
hours or if I had to go to
Samar then uh that might be a little bit
difficult but uh it's it's it's great
fun and it's it's very interesting to
watch chess on in this type of format
broadcasting to a mass audience like we
have this crazy production behind the
scenes that I'm sure you're all of aware
of as well over there and the scale it's
really cool to see because this is just
the beginning and formats are evolving
commentary is evolving behind the scenes
is evolving so we definitely need this I
don't think chess can grow as much as if
everybody just sits at home and plays on
their computers but you guys you know
the Young Generation we spoke to fuja
before the event and fuja was like why
did we travel all this way to play this
game like we could just sit at home play
on a computer it was very funny like so
I don't know everybody's on a got a
little bit of a different thought about
the whole thing yeah uh lby thanks so
much it's so cool that you're feeling
better and you're with us in Toronto
right now and we'll catch up with you uh
later and throughout the week and right
now we've got so many developments that
have happened on the position as well
Levy said he did prefer White's position
when we checked in last bit a lot of
moves have taken place and we see the
kingside pawns uh of white they've
stepped up ahead pawns don't move
backwards is that to committ and can
that backfire for white well black just
heard you and said I'm going to push
some Pawns of my own and and now we have
a locked Queen side so there's only one
open file black is ready to double Rooks
on it I've actually been waiting for an
exchange sacrif rice for those of you
who maybe classically trained chess
players and you read about your great
predecessors you look at those D4 and D5
squares if black throws a rook on D4 can
white afford to take it or does that
open up some lines for the black pieces
in this position it says maybe not the
best option and if white could clear the
defile maybe there's a moment where if
the Rooks are in a St on you put your
own Rook on D5 and say please go and
take me there you'll open up some lines
so the position is so closed that it
might even be worth giving up a rook for
a minor piece just to open up a new file
and create some new
threats yeah really instructive stuff
there Robert it's all about squares
right now and it's about who is able to
control those squares over the next few
turns it feels like a critical moment
has been brewing and Abdu satov visibly
nervous there he's unsure about the
evaluation just as we are he is and he's
taking his time as you said that that is
very instructive uh he knows he's
managed to do maximum on the queen side
it's blocked now where is the
Breakthrough coming from but he's got to
be careful and on the clock as well that
classic Abdu satov stare we just saw
right right there we will go back to the
other game while nck has a think and
this one I think is clearer because
White's got this monstrous Bishop on D5
and it's the kind of Bishop that you can
get rid of but you only help white
because then there'll be a pawn that'll
take its place and become a huge huge
passer I'm really liking White's
position despite a backwards deep on
which is weak but it's impossible to get
to it yeah uh Robert you were talking
about exchange sacrifices on the D5
Square why sacrifice The Exchange when
you could just plant a beautiful Bishop
like this in the heart of your
opponent's camp and supported by two
pawns um yeah this looks like strategic
I wouldn't say dominance yet but a
strategic Mastery from Vash gra he's
achieved everything he wants but uh
still some hard work to be done to turn
that uh Advantage into something else to
increase it there was that Dennis lzic
game against hiar Nakamura we're talking
about rerouting a bishop and here here
that's what I'm looking at for maxim
who's on the clock his Bishop his dark
Square Bishop is in line with that black
Rook I'm a little bit nervous about some
exchanges there I would actually step
back with my Bishop to D2 and then put
it on the C3 Square let's get a nice
long diagonal for that piece and start
creating threats I'm actually surprised
the advantage is only slightly in
White's favor this looks like black
could actually be lost if you make one
wrong turn yeah black is really stuck
and just to emphasize this bishop super
strong if you ever capture uh I mean
here they attack teal problems perhaps
on this diagonal but this is just too
strong a protected pass Pawn combined
with the E Pawn these pawns will decide
the game so you cannot really touch the
center after Bishop D2 which I love I've
got to say because I wanted to slide the
black king into the corner on h8
suddenly I wouldn't feel so comfortable
about that after Bishop to D2 uh Hikaru
has to perhaps rely on tricks could he
for example at some point trade off uh
White's beautiful Knight sacrifice a
rook for it and try to open up the white
king Vash gra wow he's parted with his
beautiful Bishop why would you do that
yes he's won a white won a pawn here in
the corner but suddenly black has some
more control opposite color Bishops
tricks in the air I guess he wants to
take back with a rook defending the
white Bishop uh that you mentioned but
it's hanging by a thread suddenly for
white this time Wow and his Queen is
almost trapped because my first instinct
is can I really get away with stealing a
rook Pawn the queen doesn't really have
many Escape SES except for A6 right now
but if the Rook goes to A8 taking away
the A6 Square the queen can slide to C7
the bishop and queen line up there it's
protected and this would actually lead
to a favorable end game for white so
greed sometimes is good sometimes it
completely backfires I don't know what
to make of this decision by Maxim he
stole a pawn and now he's forcing AAR to
prove that he has sufficient
compensation yeah maybe not bad but it
just feels like it was selling the
position a bit short uh so we'll see
whether Hikaru can punish Maxim's greed
uh a pwn up though for white and he gets
up very confidently from the board yeah
definitely that Bishop f felt way more
worth than the A7 Pawn which has been
picked up and I think his decision has
taken Hikaru by surprise as well it's
not something that he was expecting
because he pretty much walked into it he
wanted to allow it to get to ease out
that pressure on the center Maxim gets
up he's back on the board looking very
relaxed about the decision now in these
kind of situations you know very often
you you pick up the material and then
you ask your opponent prove your
sacrifice prove your compensation here
and that's not an easy task for Hikaru
right now especially touching the under
five minute Mark I yeah I love openings
in quicker time controls where you steal
material where your king isn't unsafe
but at best your opponent plays accurate
moves and makes a draw it's this type of
position where I don't feel like Maxim
is in any danger whatsoever he stole a
clean pawn and now it's up to iar to
prove that he could hold I don't think
iar is playing for Dynamics he's not
playing for any tactical ideas he just
wants to say all right I lost one Pawn
it's not the end of the world so many
pieces remain on the board I'll do okay
yeah Hikaru here he would love to for
example trade off queens and somehow
destabilize White's uh Central porn
chain you see the white porns on C4 D3
E4 on the light squares vulnerable to
attacks from Black's Bishop so if you
can somehow simplify the equation trade
things off yes you're horn down but get
active pieces in return you might be
able to draw but as Roberts mentions a
draw might well be the best hikaru's
hoping for right now as he appears very
interested he might be calculating
something actually uh this feels like
another critical moment and because of
that I think we need to Deep dive a
little bit into this position I we can
tell from hikaru's expression he's
totally into the game with a lot of
lines running through his head and David
my feeling as a player here would be
that I want to calculate paon takes Pawn
First I'm hitting your Bishop I'm
clarifying the center what are the
consequences of it yeah white would have
to recapture um so this is the first
tactic you do defend your Bishop so uh
Black's Rook can no longer capture on
this square and talking of lines running
through the head there's so much Tanya
uh firstly this queen almost trapped but
always won Escape Square so she can
slide back if the Rook attacks it then
maybe now Queen to C7 and Hikaru could
be thinking of tactics for example after
a trade my first instinct was Bishop to
F5 trying to come uh to a better
diagonal trying to put some pressure on
this D3 Pawn but I suddenly realized you
can take on H3 as well so this would be
a very forcing line undermining the
defender of this white knight and if
Hikaru is calculating not sure what face
number that is then it could be this
variation Pawn takes Bishop for example
would be met by Rook takes Knight a fair
trade but H you have to calculate the
consequences these pawns are hanging
these pawns are hanging and uh you have
to do a lot of counting here to ensure
you're not losing material he needs to
make a decision he's taken almost four
minutes at this point on this move but
if this liquidation is to happen after
that best sequence and if white is
forced to do it he may understand if
he's calculating correctly it should be
a hold with best play so that I think
it's a very forcing line it's concrete
and that's why investing all this time
and he does uh reach out for a piece he
doesn't trade on e4 hits the queen first
we might be still seeing the position
that David was talking about with the
trade on e4 we will of course keep an
eye on this one but let's also check in
with Fabby against uh nbec a Clos close
battle as you're talking and it's all
about the D5 Squad right now between
both the players we saw a bishop on D5
now there's a knight on D5 I was
offering a rook on that square but
somehow Fabby got a night there this is
the best possible outcome from him the
queen side is closed when nck pushed all
his pawns there there's no tension you
can't create any tension so that flank
is closed and the play on the king side
may decide this game and it's Fabby who
can push his pawns maybe to F4 maybe to
G4 and you're not taking that Knight on
D5 you open up that Bishop on C2 which
is sitting behind the white Pawn you're
going to be asking for trouble so I love
Fab's chances right now yeah it feels
like he's teleported magically somehow
that white knight to its ideal square
and I'm looking at the black Queen what
is she doing out there on A5 she was
previously beautiful glorious on the
king side putting some pressure on
controlling everything suddenly the
black Queen's on the wrong flank and he
does take this KN Robert maybe he just
didn't want to suffer any longer looking
at that stallion in the center but this
could backfire too much tension to uh
have that Knight on D5 and Fabby
immediately takes the decision of
recapturing with the c Pawn I like it I
think taking with the other Central Pawn
would allow black to get a lot of
counterplay on the king Side by starting
to push his own pawns eventually so C
takes D5 and immediately a blockade on
D6 is Fabby trying to get his Bishop on
the Square that has just been vacated by
the pawn and he can put his Rooks on
that line too that C5 Pawn that could be
a Target so unfortunately for nck as
white can shift Rooks over looks like
he's trying desperately to cling onto
that pawn but white can play on the king
side you could say to notbe use all your
forces go to the queen side but as soon
as you do as soon as you lose sight of
where your king is I'm going to start
pushing pawns on that flank this looks
really dangerous still for back yeah
really dangerous combine that theory of
two weaknesses as Magnus did so well
earlier today first I think we're likely
to see maximum pressure applied to this
Pawn we do indeed see this occur and all
of Black's pieces are tied down now
these two black Rooks the bishop the
queen are all fixed defending this sorry
backward Pawn so the time might be right
very shortly as Fabiana puts pressure on
the king side and uh soon we will see
Robert's idea Pawn to F4 we could even
see the bishop sliding in later uh to
some beautiful squares this is one-sided
traffic right now and uh look at NC's
pieces they're all so passive he's had
to go back to f8 with his Bishop to
defend H6 this is all gone wrong and uh
as soon as white improves this piece I
think he'll be ready to throw his pawns
forward Pawn to F4 look at this he's
coming in with his Bishop to some
beautiful Outpost white dominates the
light squares really nicely played the
concept of two weaknesses right you've
got the C5 Pawn last week and you've got
the 86 Pawn that's week and he's playing
against both of them you pointed out one
square for the bishop the bishop can
also land on A6 and start targeting that
defender on see it nck it's extremely
passive but at some moment Fabby has to
break he's maximized the pressure where
do you see the break coming from and
Fabby shows it I was going to say we've
been waiting for it F4 push that pawn
forward if black takes it you take with
your Bishop hitting that Rook on C7 I
feel like Black's position really is
about to fall apart you can then put
your E Pawn as white E5 E6 uses a
battering ram and the bishop on D3 it
can go in either direction and go up to
A6 it can hit the king towards a seven I
mean this is just overwhelming
Initiative for white yeah f for forward
f for Fabby f for fabulous this is just
a beautiful play and Abdus torus Bishop
goes back to its original fian ketto
square and now you're spoiled for Choice
I'm loving all those Bishop moves you
mentioned uh Robert looks super
promising for white right now very
minimum you can keep motoring forward
with your F4 just lock down the king
side create targets there but he's being
greedy and rightly so Fabiano he's just
looking at all the pawns now the White
Queen dark Square Bishop Rooks all
staring at that one black weakness that
we highlighted on C5 the f file about to
open as well this is torture for black
he's going to do Hikaru takes takes
takes takes takes takes takes and
unfortunately for no dearbeck white has
more pieces attacking that pawn than he
has pieces defending and he can't defend
it anymore uh this is going to be at
least a pawn to the good for Fabiano
Carana and there's still going to be the
attack raging on so he brings his Knight
out to D6 Knights are the best
blockaders against pass pawns but what's
wrong with just takes takes takes takes
takes I think we're going to see it
Robert this Pawn is dropping let's focus
on Fabby now as he starts to clean up
starts to count the extra material and
uh what is NC thinking about here is he
just going to drop the queen back if you
trade off Rooks white has won a porn
white activates the pieces Black's
Knight as soon as it's kicked away the
remaining blockading piece that will
spell the end of the game and uh okay
Fabiano now what is the cleanest way to
do it what's the most professional way
to kill all counterplay do you trade
Rooks do you just keep the status quo
that's it Bishop C5 aren't you winning a
second Pawn you hit the Knight you hit
the pawn on B4 and that's what happens
when you lose the base of a pawn chain
the B4 Pawn is next I think he can even
slide his Queen on over if he would like
I'm sure there are other options but
that B4 Pawn it's gone too far and you
can't bring other pieces to defend it
yeah just uh start picking off those
weaknesses now just looks so simple
Fab's making it look simple and uh nbec
ever since that white knight landed on
D5 he hasn't had a single chance and
queen takes Pawn here I think that
Knight is pinned to the queen black will
have to backtrack with a bishop F7 will
fall I think this is almost
resign he plays it winning advantage
that black knight is doomed Fabiano
caruana in complete control up material
and probably going to win some more this
one looks like it's in the bag and we
will head over to our other Armageddon
hiar Nakamura is he in some trouble here
it is a pawn down for him he's down a PA
in this position White's got the bishop
controlling all the squares of the night
but right now hikaru's managed to make a
White's Rook passive and just as I say
it said what passive Rook I'm coming in
for counter attack it's the black Rook
that's passive now the black B6 Pawn
next to the black Rook is uh the only
glue holding together Black's whole
structure um we were talking about it
earlier Robert Bishop versus knight if
you control the Knight squares you often
control the game and that's why the
Black Knight has had to move away
looking for fresher pastures
I I think he's uncomfortable Nakamura
but it doesn't look over yet and wow
porn Sacrifice from Vash gra he's
allowing the black pawn to push and look
at this race black spor two squares away
from touchdown but white has two pawns
so he wanted the connected passers while
that Bishop it can go back into the
corner to block that pawn and meanwhile
hikara 27 seconds this gives me hints of
that game against nirc Abdu satar and
Armageddon where nirc had the bishop
hiard the Knight as play on both sides
of the board I will say one more thing
the knights have an advantage over
Bishops and that can they can go from
color complex to color complex that
Knight can go to the light squares the
bishop can't control light squares and a
rook trade is offered is that a good
decision oh it's a brave decision
committal decision and uh I think the uh
fact is that Nakamura now needs to
accept this he needs to trade Rooks to
keep the black a pawn alive that's your
Ace card that's what's going to save you
the game and yes white has two connected
Pawns in the center but Black's Knight
is coming round black knight is now
going to jump to B4 into C2 and support
the Pawn's promotion meanwhile Vash gra
has to try and win on the king side or
in the center with his own pawns it is a
race again in the S game now Maxim bagra
will eventually have to give up his
Bishop for this a pawn and it will all
come down to how quickly he can push
those Central pawns combine that with
getting his King to the kingside pawns
and also try to pick those up it is uh
it's a game that's for all three results
right now well I think that if Maxim he
wants to ensure that he can't lose he
can push his Pawn to F5 trade off some
pawns on the king side over over there
and then bring his King around but he's
getting a bit low on the clock before it
was a huge lead and now look at Hikaru
he's sacrificing the KN but you can't
take it because the oh wow he might try
to trap the knight in the corner though
oh really clever move forcing a
headshake from Nakamura Maxi Vash grav
is going to try and trap that black
knight if it came in if it came forward
and Nakamura forced to lose time he's
lost two Tempo he's gone back where he
came from with that Knight and I think
he realized that perhaps you could have
jumped in with the Knight to the other
Square forcing uh a better sequence of
moves Hikaru falls back with the Knight
and now Maxim isn't forced to give up
the bishop anymore for the pawn and look
at that move Bishop E5 making sure the
black king cannot step forward and the
bishop still covers that pass Pawn in
the corner now the white king can slide
back towards the pawn and go and win it
he's winning Maxim Vash lrav he's even
going in with his King he doesn't even
care about that a pawn the white Bishop
will always keep a watchful gaze over it
and White's Pawns in the center are
going to decide this game Nakamura lost
three full Tempe with his night
Maneuvers earlier he's panicking look at
the clock as well no time to defend
don't play King C4 if you're Max team
that allows Knight E3 Trek and you drop
your central D5 Pawn you do not want to
allow that to happen so he gives a check
he pushes his Pawn but now where does
the king go up it goes cuz C5 is carved
out for it yeah beautiful nak Nakamura
here in trouble meanwhile vashar finding
All the Right Moves the coordination
between White's pawns and dart Square
Bishop should be over now white just has
to be careful where he puts his King the
only trick is to not walk into a night
Fork tensed moment there and Maxim is
going for that big pawn and he does take
it but there are some complications it
just looks like Maxim's pawns have moved
way too ahead on the board that's right
the Knight could have stolen that pawn
but the king and pongame would have been
losing because that G5 Pawn would have
been falling as well so it's two extra
pawns for maxim and he just needs to be
a bit careful not to allow Hikaru to
trade off and that's a connected pass PA
one square away from promotion Hikaru
Nakamura 14 seconds he is panicking he
tries to create a mess on the board the
H Pawn relying all hopes on that but
White's Bishop it's got to find a
defensive Squad does he just move all
the way to B8 right now so that the F5
can come in with a check as long as he
stays on this diagonal that the bishop
sits on you called it Tanya there we go
then he is x-ray vision guarding the H2
Square the black pawn can no longer push
it will be captured within a couple of
turns Pawn to F5 next is guaranteed and
now there's no more hope Black's other
Rooks Pawn both of them were just kept
under uh under guard by this bishop and
it's now simply over the bishop will
come back and check this black king
out of the blockading square sooner or
later four pawns against one you can
push the G Pawn now you have four pass
pawns to just one for black and you can
see AAR he resigns he throws in the
towel great finish there from Maxim V gr
incredible endgame play there on seconds
by Maxim and he takes the lead and again
this is just a best of two which means
Hikaru has to has to win the next game
to take it to Armageddon he managed to
survive the elimination in the round
robin but he faces it one more time and
on our other match up we saw Fabiano
Carana as expected he converted that
flawlessly first move Advantage led to a
win both Fabiano and Maxim they were
able to convert win their opening games
they will have black in game two so
Hikaru and nbec respectively have their
chances but what a start for maxim and
for fabbi incredible play by both with
the white pieces and it started as a
strategic battle out of the opening
playing for this important Central
Square and then eventually we saw the
complications favor white yeah in both
games actually a mirror image almost of
each other those two battles we saw in
the survival stage and I just want to
highlight where it went wrong for Hikaru
Nakamura against Maxi Vash gra and it
was in this position yes black is a pawn
down yes it's a difficult defense but
here he went wrong if you look at the
Black Knight and its Journey now it came
forward to C6 and after white pushed a
pawn it tried to come into A5 attacking
a pawn ideally coming in as well to B3
to help promotion but this is where Maxi
VRA with a nice King Retreat did clinch
a decisive Advantage if black could come
in now then the king simply continues
retreating if you promote to a new Queen
then a capture and the Knight is caught
in the corner knights in the corner are
the worst but look at what Nakamura had
to do he instead dropped his Knight back
to C6 back where it came from and back
to E7 losing three full moves in the
process and the pawns became too strong
in the race the bishop simply dominated
the Knight that even if you won the
bishop the knight in the corner was
trapped I love that Bishop E5 move as
well making sure the king couldn't touch
those pawns great great endgame
technique on display from Maxim
VRA tempos are everything in end games
and the one player who's keeping the
tempo up is Fabiano Carano with his win
against nbec kayak got up with him after
that
game here with Fabiano car and you must
be very happy right now yeah it was a
really tough game I mean very very
complicated all the pieces were on the
board there was a lot of tension but I
think in the middle game I outplayed him
and I don't know how the quality was but
I feel like I was in control for most of
it and yeah of course I struggled with
Notre Beck in this tournament so I lost
the match first match to him so
hopefully second one will go a bit
better and you're now getting very close
to a semi-final is that's something that
will be on your mind in the next game oh
sorry yeah for sure of course I getting
to the semis is the the first goal and
then I don't know who I'll play I guess
it's my fate is not in my hands in terms
of who I play it's either uh Magnus or
Wesley but it's Wesley's Choice uh if I
get but um yes still first things first
I mean uh Notre Beck is a big fighter so
um before I think about that I still
have to hold my game against him now um
a little bit of coughing there I have uh
seen you with a big cup of tea for most
of the day here how are you feeling well
on the second day I actually on the
first day even when my my match against
Ali Resa this second game I started to
feel a bit strange and um yeah I came
down with something I don't think it's
too serious but uh it's not too Pleasant
uh but okay I'm starting to recover I
think all should be better soon I can
barely get out of bed if I'm feeling a
little bit sick what is it like to play
chess long days when you are a little
bit under the weather actually I don't
mind because I have a distraction so I
don't don't have to think about it too
much and if I'm staying and doing
nothing let's say staying at home then I
all I'm thinking about is how I don't
feel well and so I'd actually of course
I prefer not to be sick when I'm playing
but uh it's not it's not so bad okay
guys should be like you Fabiano I'm
telling you all right thank you for
joining us good luck in the next game
thank you all right Fabiano corana he is
uh not playing like he is sick
definitely
not I completely agree with you ka there
just fantastic fantastic play by Fabiano
not just so far in this tournament but
the whole year he has been on the
biggest form the biggest shape of his
life and uh we've got the second big
round coming up between the 2021 W World
rapid champion and he will be taking on
the reigning US champion world number
two nbec Abdus satov has to win to take
it to
[Music]
armagedon
Maxim VRA had not played in a single
division one of event until the last one
he went through the play-ins to qualify
for the AI cup but was not a favorite to
take the last spot in the tour finals
this is crazy the black king is hiding
Behind Enemy Lines it's even taking
porns and black is actually going to be
the one delivering Checkmate the checks
are going to dry up and white king is at
the enemy's Mercy checks dry up it's
game over and Yan loses on time Maxine
progresses he had to win the AI cup to
get the ticket Maxine mean while going
forward with his King wow look at this
if he pushes his Pawn will he get M
Magnus Carlson on the edge of the board
we all know queen versus Rook how
hopeless that is Magnus allows a
Checkmate on the board and we have
Armageddon look at that he's giving away
another Rook checks to follow there we
go it's a draw and that means we are
heading to a grand final reset Magnus
Carlson loses the match here in the
Grand Final against NBL he is on fire
the
Frenchman Maxim played fantastic chess
taking down some big names and finally
won the AI cup securing a spot in the
tour finals Checkmate is guaranteed
there's nothing to do black cannot
defend this position will we see Magnus
hit the resign button and mvl is
starting to let the emotions come to him
he is starting to realize he is the
winner Maxim vaj the Frenchman he win
wins the AI cup he banks the ticket to
Toronto he is going to the tour finals
he does the impossible he beats Magnus
Carlson in two
matches a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like
make your move get an exclusive discount
on all metal posters shop now with the
code Chess at displate.com
[Music]
[Applause]
if you been inspired by all the playing
Toronto and want to up your game we've
got some great news for you the chessel
pro week is on through December 15th
there's a 20% off all courses used the
command Pro in chart and transform your
game and the one player who needs to
transform his game right now it has to
be Hikaru Nakamura as he faces Maxim
Vash lra Hikaru has survived elimination
once today can he do it again he is in a
must-win game to take it to Armageddon
and this is is where we are on the
survival stage right now Fabby Maxim
both incredibly impressive with their
wins Robert yeah Fabiano Carana is just
a draw away from the semi-finals he's in
that upper bracket and for maxim Vash
grav of course he's in the driver seat
but AAR Nakamura has shown so many times
of the years he's capable of roaring
back yeah if anyone can Nakamura can ab
to sattorov as well has shown that he
can fight back too uh I mean two players
who yes uh had a bad first game but they
did have black now with white if they
can match how well their opponents
played with the white pieces definitely
a chance I'm not predicting anything
it's not over far from it yeah now the
back Abdus satra was the comeback K
against Hikaru Nakamura can he do it
again this time against Fabiano karwana
the big big game two coming up the
pressure is on the players only two will
make it into the semi-finals and there
we see nbec he's ready to go he starts
with white Fabby walking around there
what was your pregame what is your
pregame ritual like David do you like to
come a little early I'm always turning
up two three minutes after the clock has
started because I'm disorganized less
professional than these players uh I
have noticed that Fabiano is a pacer
I've played him several times myself
he's always pacing up and down uh I
think that's just how he gets in the
zone how he gets focused well Abdu satov
uh we see him there he's all about the
death stair whether it's his opponent
the chessboard he is always focused
always focused and that's what needs to
do only focus on the next move and it's
the same story for Hikaru it's
handshakes games are underway and we
start with a sicilian are we going to
see a night off no we're not what is
that it's the Mora Gambit wow I must
admit I am shocked uh not just because
he's giving up a porn with this Gambit
but also because it does allow a
transposition back into the alipin
Sicilian the C3 Sicilian and uh that's
something not known for its winning
winning Tendencies at this top level but
wow Vash Vash lrav now uh playing very
classically that is met by Nakamura
bringing his Queen out and you say it
doesn't give much in the way of winning
chances for white and I've played this
many times from the white side it's not
loved by the engines or by the top
players but because it's not played so
frequently maybe it catches Maxim off
guard perhaps he's not so well prepared
for this and this isn't a situation
where you just trade all pieces look at
that Queen in the center you line it up
with a bishop maybe there could be some
attacking chances for Hikaru as this
game proceeds
yeah the White Queen looks really
actively placed but whether she's a
Target or not that's the big question
head in hands Vash gra uh he clearly
hasn't studied this one recently unlike
Nakamura and uh the big question is
whether to go attacking that Queen
whether to just continue development key
moments critical moments already at this
early stage hiar Nakamura gets the early
opening surprise in and the other game
is about to begin as well as we've got
handshakes nck what opening approach
does he he have planned for this one in
his must-win game he's going for the
queen Pawn opening and are we going to
see a queen's gamber declined it's the
nimzo I think it's a good choice from
Fabiano he's played the nimzo from the
black side so many times over the years
and he strikes at the center he does not
afraid of some trades if he can actually
liquidate he's feeling happy and we
could get an isolated queen palm
position like Dennis lavic had against
Fabiano yeah and uh we saw what happened
in that game Abdu satov meanwhile will
he get his Knight out will he just get
castled will he uh be the first to Blink
and trade off a set of Pawns in the
center there's a lot of uh tension right
now he does trade off just uh
simplifying the equation there and look
at that peering away from the board he's
in recall mode trying to go into that
mind Palace and uh remember what to do
against this slightly rare uh Knight
recapture and uh I think we're headed
straight on that same path Robert that
you mentioned lavic against Nakamura uh
I think we had this exact position on
the board and lavic against Fabiano with
something similar so for Fabi he's
taking the direct path he wants to
clarify the State of Affairs on this
board we see white saddled you could say
with an is said Queen Pawn or you say
it's the beneficiary because that pawn
is very useful that when you have an
isolated Pawn you have open files
adjacent to it and very often the
compensation for this early opening
weakness is to try to get the play
Rolling and an attack going against your
opponent's king the more pieces that
come off the more trades general rule is
that it favors the side that's attacking
the weakness on the board so for nbak it
will be key to try and keep as many
pieces on the board as possible to keep
the pressure he has provoked G6 which
can often become a hook at some point
perhaps a far away H4 H5 to create play
uh is it fair to say nbec is going to
try to avoid all possible trades in this
position yeah certainly any end game
black would feel safe especially in
terms of the match situation I do love
fabiana's last move I must admit
bringing the black d square Bishop the
whole way back just covering all the
darkart square weaknesses around Black's
King and yeah it's up to nbec the
pressure is on him to attack due to the
match but also due to the nature of this
position iqp I used to play it all the
time myself from a variety of different
openings you have to be energetic you
have to keep pedaling uh on this bicycle
you cannot stop otherwise you might just
fall off black long-term doing well
shortterm white has Dynamic potential I
like that Bishop Retreat because when
you have the Swiss cheese Pawn formation
like black does all those pawns and
light squares it means that your dark
squares are vulnerable so he brings his
Bishop next to his King soon that Bishop
will be in front of his King staring at
that isolated Queen Pawn in the center
of the board protecting some critical
squares I like what Fab's doing and the
fact that nordbeck is thinking I believe
that he also approves of Fabio's
position well he needs to approve of his
own position right now he is uh playing
for the win and uh it's the only result
that will keep this match going we will
check in with this and see how the
Dynamics of an isolated Queen Bond will
ver is developing kingside initiative
goes on but meanwhile a lot of action
early on Hikaru gets the opening
surprise in with his second move going
for the early D4 and we see a
non-standard position but both players
have kind of kept it together on the
clock they've kept the speed up what is
this uh opening outcome like and do you
think Maxim is now feeling a lot calmer
than he was a couple of moves earlier
maybe calmer but I'm not sure whether
he's happy with the outcome um I must to
say at least in terms of the match again
Nakamura should be thrilled he's somehow
escaped the opening uh with as many
pieces on the board as possible still
maximum tension white has a space
Advantage as well due to the E5 pawn it
could have been a lot worse we could
have seen a bunch of Trades we could
have seen a lot of uh different things
happening but Vash gra is on his own
that's step one get your opponent out of
their preparation and uh a lot of
potential for Nakamura if Maxim isn't
accurate on the next few moves it's what
we call just a position it's not one
where there's deep preparation for
either side at this point they're
playing on their own and the good news
for Hikaru he has this nice Central Pawn
in on E5 protected by his Knight and his
Queen and that pawn cannot be traded off
black might want to push that D5 Pawn
back a square so that you can try to
trade it maybe get some liquidation
going clarify the middle and you look at
that Bishop on D3 for white if black has
any hopes of cast and kingside watch out
there could be a Greek gift sacrifice
there could be vicious attacks Brewing
over there because many of Black's
pieces they're all the way over there on
the queen side yeah Black's pieces
there's a bit of a traffic jam there
they're all huddled up but what are they
actually doing and there are a few
tricks in the position for example Maxim
Vash grav could try to go for this far
Advanced porn as quickly as possible by
bringing his Knight back to D7 but
White's Bishop comes out and at first
thought I uh was looking at Pawn to F6
try to take advantage of this pin try to
cash in on this E5 Pawn but I think
white can hold things together this is
what Maxim is calculating right now with
clever sneaky moves such as Bishop to B5
pinning the Black Knights both of them
so that you can control E5 you keep
things together it's just about holding
for Nakamura and he should be happy
about that other tactics do include the
Black Knight coming to B4 for example
due to a pin along this file the C1
Bishop is hanging but I don't think this
is anything too serious to worry about
fasid de gra as Robert mentioned he
cannot afford to Simply play quietly
bring his Bishops out it would be too
slow as soon as white is castled uh as
soon as the white king is safe white has
a big strategic Advantage so now or
never he has to find something concrete
and the big question is does it exist in
the position this concrete line that
you're talking about because Maxim he's
taken his time right now he's at 2 and a
half minutes already and uh At first I
felt that Maxim should be feeling fine
in the position but everything you
pointed out it all revolves around this
E5 pawn and Maxim needs to find a way to
fight against it he decides to bring the
bishop to the diagonal so that he can
start hitting the pawn and now your idea
of bringing the Knight back doubling
down on that pawn with the bishop on G7
uh Hikaru perhaps will be looking at
sliding in with his own Rook to defend
it so the fight is really against this
E5 Pawn can we expect black to go shot
castle and strike with F6 at some point
it's a long ways away and black is
currently cramped that Bishop on C8 now
it can't even develop but even if it did
develop it's like a French Bishop no
offense me to Maxim vilagra I mean the
French opening that Bishop gets stuck
behind a wall of its own pawns and we
see how quickly Hikaru is going to bring
his pieces out defend E5 I really like
White's position it's much easier to
play you are playing for the aggressive
plans whereas black you just don't have
so much space and you can't initiate
trades for everyone at home when you
lack space you want to see trades happen
when you're the side with more space if
you're hit car here you don't want
trades yeah he simply got a clear plan
of attack Rook to E1 Knight to D2 throw
that H Pawn down the board easy play for
hikaro Nakamura what is black doing in
the meantime a bit of a mystery and uh
it's that swiss cheese formation you
mentioned earlier Robert in the other
game again a mirror image of of the uh
other clash in the survival stage lots
of points on light squares means dark
squared weaknesses so watch out for
black king to come under heavy fire
later in the game all right well Maxim
has managed to get his King to safety
I'm still looking at potential F6 breaks
we've been talking about the French and
that's really the Thematic idea there
but there are so many tactics And Trades
that you have to watch out for there
once white takes that pawn you'll be
hitting the bishop and Maxim will be
calculating all of that we know Maxim is
a player he likes the initiative it's
not like he wants to just sit passing
and let his opponent kind of achieve
whatever they want and ask them to play
it out so Maxim will be trying to find
that break in this position for Hikaru a
dream outcome in a must-win situation
it's a lovely position for white I I
will say though it's not the type of
dynamic position that the top players
generally prefer where they can see
where the future is but hik car's moves
are easy it becomes like a king's Indian
attack from the white side and you know
who's played the Kings Indian a lot
hikaro Nakamura where he's going to push
his H Pawn move his Rook slide his
Knight back just to reroute It Forward I
think that hiar actually has many great
plans here black has cramped black
doesn't have the plans that white does
hikara should be thrilled to have this
position yeah must-win situation nearly
all the pieces on the board only one set
of porn exchanges this is uh more than
he could have ever dreamed of especially
choosing this opening Vash lrav I think
rightly spending a bit of time right now
he should go into the tank two three
minutes form a plan of attack try to
trade off pieces somehow to alleviate
the space concerns but look at the
Frenchman he's normally so intuitive so
instinctive he's slowed down I think
he's secretly hating his position as
black this is not up his alley doesn't
suit his strengths and uh no obvious Way
Forward for
black yeah I'm really biased here I've
got to say White's position is beautiful
right now and we did see when Maxim got
that position against uh Magnus Carson
and I was talking about the game the
miniature that he lost he wasn't happy
with it it he didn't survive too long
and the F6 break that we were discussing
earlier it has happened all the trades
are on the board Maxim trying to break
out trying to create that activity and I
see you shaking your head saying that
it's not going to happen the advantage
has transformed it went from purely a
spatial Advantage with some plans to
actually some really bad pawns for black
the E6 Pawn that's going to be a
long-term Target the bishop on the light
squares for black it's stuck defending
it and look at aaru's last a really
clever idea he's saying I know we
typically talk how Bishops are better
than Knights long range pieces blah blah
blah look at the dark squares on this
board you know what can't help the dark
squares a light Square Bishop let me
take your night on C6 leave you with the
light Square bishop and then I have the
E5 Square maybe the C5 Square later the
D4 Square as well give me all the dark
squares here and that's just dark Square
domination and car Nakamura loves a
whole lot of that yeah look at this bad
Bishop we talk about good Knights versus
bad Bishops this is the worst of all and
he rightly avoids this Maxim bash lra
this is how classy the top players are
yes it's already uh pretty ugly position
for black but he doesn't want to make it
worse he's going to try and bring his
Knight around preserve his Knight and
White's Bishop which was trying to
tradeoff is now hitting thin air so a
good fighting move there yes there's
still one problem piece yes it's still a
backward Pawn but uh at least if with a
knight on F7 with a queen back on F6 he
can curl up into a ball and try to stay
solid so he's at least preventing
nakamura's ideas for now he's fighting
and I think uh yes Hikaru like you guys
are saying and explaining better but
it's a long Long Way long way to go
still to convert this advantage and
especially that last move by Maxim it
just means that it's not going to be
again just a game where either Hikaru
pushes or Maxim is fighting for survival
once that Knight does arrive to F7 it
gets to D6 the central point and starts
jumping into enemy territory I mean the
F line is open we can also Imagine the E
Pawn pushing forward at some point after
Knight F7 E5 coming in and then you're
talking about game right black can also
look at the bishop coming out I mean I
think we're writing this off for maxi a
bit too early well hiar knows that you
want to push that pawn and he's going to
say no no no and he could start by
placing his own Knight on E5 then
bringing the second Knight over to F3 I
think that what hiar is going to try to
do is clamp down on those squares leave
the black queen side pieces where they
are they're sitting at home and they're
not participating the way they want to
so it's just a clean Advantage for a car
whether you can convert it and how tough
Maxim's defenses are that's a different
question but any player in the world
would prefer to have the white side
here yeah defitely agree with you on
that but Maxim vagra we know how tricky
and resourceful he can be we'll see if
he can muster something up or Hikaru
manages to take this to the
Armageddon uh and the one person who has
actually been rooting for Hikaru from
the very start making his predictions
betting on Hikaru from the start is
James kanty he is in Toronto and he is
joining us right now James what do you
make of hikaru's chances to make a
comeback in this
one let me tell you something I'm always
ride or die with my guy Hikaru is the
man of course Hikaru is half man half
everything else right he's an absolute
Legend a pineapple whatever you want to
call it whatever he does he gets it done
he's a World Champ of course this is my
guy I ride with him of course there's
people in the chat do too as well I like
his opening Choice with the uh of course
C3 Cil for the kill as we like to call
it but it was really A Smith Mo that
kind of changed into something else so
he plays a lot of Smith Smith more him
play it many times I haven't had a lot
of success classical but of course with
that um you know having it in Blitz and
faster time controls is really fun so I
am rooting for him it is a battle of
course he's going to have to you know
show on the board right here so I also
have been checking Fab's game too as
well fabbi had a great Roy Lopez as you
know um from the white side and the
black side he's very good they went into
some type of brayer but he just had the
pressure got the C Pawn rolling Flawless
game here now with the black pieces
painted nimzo with that ISO Pawn white
has a little bit of uh of play on that
side n Beck does trying to to attack the
king but you know Fab is handling it
very well so I'm watching the games very
closely but I'm definitely watching my
guy he car over there well James
throughout uh this whole tournament
you've been talking about ner Beck how
he's always a fighter I mean well you
just start talking about this position
he lost round one a lot of players would
collaps it seems like he's actually
bringing his best chess in this must-win
game against
fabbi yeah you know what's funny with
that um Fabby that battle of of fobby
and nck is is really heated as we see I
remember watching when he beat Fabby
just kind of like flawlessly there when
I was in Oslo he won the chess kid cup
so really in a way I think someone
mentioned it earlier maybe Danny was
like hey this is his CP tonight it's
like n backck is just always having good
results against fabbi but this time
Fab's looking to close it out he's like
not this time real hard Flex I do got
the trainer Now You See Me on IG I've
been curling the little seps the little
biceps trying to get like KY I'm gonna
win today says
Fabby yeah and James uh are you
predicting a Fabby win ultimately
despite this current position looking
favorable for for uh
nyck yeah I mean of course it is a
little favorable there obviously
obviously the engine says slightly
better you know for white there got
rookie eight on the board there now I
think he's okay though yeah okay a
little shaky E6 Pawn maybe looks like of
a a um weak Pawn you have the bishop on
C8 that's maybe French like type
position but there're still play still a
lot of play you know you can't count
them out yet so I am rooting for Fabby
maybe he'll hold here I think what do
you think David yeah I'll have to agree
with you James
as always you think he going to hold
there yeah well it looks like it's going
to be a tough task I'm just looking at
the evalar I'm looking at those dark
Square weaknesses around the king I'm
looking at the alpha zero Pawn on 86
white pces nicely placed uh I'm not so
sure James but uh thanks so much for
joining us and we'll keep checking in
with you and the gang in Toronto right
now we're checking in into this position
and it looks like NC has managed to
create his chances for the comeback
let's remind everyone nck has had quite
a performance against Fabby throughout
the Champions chest St season in the
chesk cup it was the finals where he
took down Fabby in the round robin stage
off the finals as well nbec was the
winner Fabby has got the lead in this
match but looking at this position I
mean I'm loving white here it's horrible
for Fabiano something went really really
wrong because the eval bar is skyh high
the material is level so way has
sacrificed nothing for this attack who
doesn't love a good Rook lift I think
that white can bring more pieces to the
party while black is doing nothing about
it Rook D3 slide that Rook on over to F3
at some point G3 Knight H5 I don't know
what to do but there are too many
good-looking options the black king is
going to be hunted down yeah this is
horrible you talked about swiss cheese
and it's actually a mirror image again
the first game of the day or at least
the survival stage both sides with white
had an anchored uh outpost on D5 now
again just like Nakamura in that game
it's D Square domination and uh it's all
about the squares I just want to
backtrack to one key moment where
Fabiano I think made the uh kind of
decisive mistake it was just a few turns
ago nbec had very cleverly pushed his
Pawn up to H4 H5 something he did
against Vash lra uh earlier in the round
robin stage this looks like his
trademark right now he loves putting
pawns on H6 and the problem is here
Fabiano he chose the wrong Square he
needed to cover the dark squares around
his King by dropping back to h8 he was
reluctant to do so hope maybe fearing
that his Bishop would be trapped in the
corner long term but at least now you
control the vital the valuable F6 Square
you can later kick back White's Bishop
but by dropping back the other way he's
left the holes especially this one on F6
and uh as Robert mentioned the White
Knight will most likely get there if we
catch up with the current position
really surprised to see white going back
uh retreating looks counterintuitive I
think he wants to go the long way round
D3 E5 back back and eventually into this
dream Outpost but yeah he could have got
got there quicker Rook to D3 and no
matter what black does this is going to
be a knockout punch the Knight would
come into H5 F6 there's too much
pressure on the black king this would
have actually ended the game so hope for
Fabiano now after the Knight Retreats
but he has to take dramatic action maybe
even throw a porn away just to get his
Bishop out of jail just to bring this
piece to life it's still looking
terrible for black but less bad than it
could have been you say hope for Fabby
to me it's still looking pretty hopeless
all the points that you just discussed
and ab absolutely agree David once that
Knight lands on G4 it's game over so
Fabby needs to do everything to make
that not happen I don't believe he has
time to go Pawn hunting right now Queen
takes Pawn just invites this idea uh
with a lot of force and we see the
evalar it doesn't like it at all also
opening up the sea line with potential
infiltration on the seventh rank as well
it's not something Fabby will go he
doesn't sacrifice the pawn as you
suggested he goes for a safer approach
but how is he fighting the main threat
with this Knight E5 does he eventually
want to go F5 the bishop is hit he needs
to take a time out now to move his
Bishop he tries to gain time hitting
this white Rook which moves but only up
in the direction that Robert was
advocating and I mean this looks even
more deadly now four white pieces are
gathering storm clouds are gathering
around the black king and black has no
Defenders this is one-sided don't even
see an idea for black because all of
White's pieces are just heading towards
the king side and you can't even make a
move like Rook a to d8 I was like let's
just even suggest a move you could lose
an exchange on the spot I wouldn't even
take that Rook because the bishop is so
strong but the point is that black has
no ideas you attacked a rook The Rook
moved it moved up to where the action is
taking place and with Knight G4 as you
mentioned Rook F3 if you do play Pawn to
F5 maybe I can just play Knight takes G6
why not if you take me pawn to H7 this
looks like I'm going to go and check me
your king yeah this looks deadly black
can block here but the white Rook just
slides across and this king is not long
for the world yeah this is just oneway
traffic and it's another example just
like Abdu satov did in his game with
black and just uh in this clash between
the others never put a black queen so
far away from your own King you can
never defend have satov made that
mistake now Fab's made the exact same
mistake his opponent did in the previous
game you need your Queen nearby if you
want to defend any attack this is so
instructive black gets all the big
pieces on the queen side and nck using
Fabiano King as the norstar just guiding
his own play getting more and more
pieces into the attack The Rook
currently attacked but you could think
about sliding it over to F3 what AB is
hoping for is to plant his own Bishop on
F5 trying to control that G4 square
right now will that be enough he's
trying to get that Bishop into defense
it's definitely not enough because white
also has a pawn it's not just the Knight
that can go to G4 the pawn can go to G4
the F7 Pawn's under attack I think Fab
is just hoping that nybeck goes wrong
somewhere because the position is so bad
for him that you know if nybeck does
pretty much anything it should be
winning so I think that nck up on time
this position easy attack that's going
to be impossible to stop if he doesn't
win this game I will be incredibly
shocked okay this one looks like very
likely to head into the Armageddon just
look at White's Army right now all
directed towards the black king only the
bishop the dark Squad Bishop supporting
it and F5 has arrived on the board which
inv whites the sacrifices David that you
were looking at is Knight takes spawn
possible right now I think so why not it
makes sense as well white has those four
attacking pieces we mentioned the white
Queen Bishop Knight Rook black only has
a king maybe add the dark Square Bishop
as a Defender but uh it's a simple
mathematical mathematical equation here
and let's show it on the board Knight
takes Pawn would likely be lights out
you can take this Pawn just to blow open
the shelter around the black king and uh
maybe they're stronger but uh this one
looks decisive to me although I've just
realized something has changed from that
earlier variation the black Bishop will
defend the G6 Pawn I thought you could
just slide and take this Pawn next but
suddenly F4 I eat my words black can
suddenly defense Fabiano does have a
sneaky plan then in mind a trap and
that's why you always have to take into
account what your opponent's last moves
were and nck he brings his Bishop into
F6 The Black Queen slides back to C7 so
Fabiano he's holding on for dear life
but as you're showing the black king has
no moves so if that Rook just slides
over there's going to be a sacrifice on
G6 in the very near future and there
might be a rook sacrific after that on
G7 just blowing the whole thing open and
Fabby there's nothing he can really do
because it's just straightforward for
nck as long as he doesn't make the
mistake that I often do as a commentator
just sack all the pieces he's doing it
the right time yeah no need to rush full
control uh he's just lining it up
putting his army his forces in position
lights out soon it's going to be Boom
Clash bang on the G6
Square all right so Fabby trying to get
rid of that Knight on E5 that would be
the dream to try to trade it off uh and
Rook moves to E1 so no no sacrifices
just yet is this the moment for Fabby to
try to take on E5 but giving that dark
squar Bishop also feels extremely
suicidal right now you know you are just
look at the look at the check meting
spots the queen lands on F6 h8 G7 that
looks disastrous but I say I have
opposite color Bishops and I was always
told that when they're opposite color
Bishops is going to be a draw not when
there's an attack on the board maybe in
a pure endgame even if one Sid's up a
pawn materials even here but white
remains better I would take that Knight
on E5 and just try to F he doesn't do
that David this looks like you know he
got to take out that Knight yeah I think
he should have done and he should have
tried to beg for a queen exchange at
least fending off the immediate danger
and yes white is dominant longterm white
would keep the Queens on most likely by
blocking and the attack continues but
Fabiano he's allowed what looks like it
might be a decisive blow um oh I was
going to say night takes 36 again I'm
scared after that last experience of uh
blundering things away uh you don't need
to rush maybe you just preempt it put a
bishop on G7 but uh he is defending
Fabiano and the longer that it goes on
with NC unable to land a punch like
Knight takes G6 then the more hope
Fabiano will gain D I just want to push
on this line because night Tak spawn
would be so so tempting for me and it
doesn't work and I my idea is that if
you take the Rook yes I get that but
what about Queen to G5 now how are you
defending this mate yeah it looks so
terminal I was going to suggest this too
Tanya great minds think alike but
unfortunately it looks like black can
just sacrifice everything back black is
up temporarily at least a rook uh a rook
in a piece even so uh no discovered
checks that knock out the black king he
would survive so F4 he's actually lining
it up again setting it up but now you
have to Fabiano you have to get rid of
this uh stallion on E5 before it's too
late now this would be decisive the
diagonal has been
blocked wow okay Fabiano Carana is in
under big big pressure he does decide to
trade off uh the night meanwhile we are
getting the end of this game Hikaru
Nakamura against Maxim Vash lra and it
it's just finished and we're getting an
update that Hikaru Nakamura has done it
Maxim Vash lra resigns Hikaru kept up
the pressure he created Magic on the
board and we get an Armageddon in that
one wow one Armageddon will it be two
that's the big question did look like uh
Nakamura applied enough pressure to
crack Vash gr's defenses but it was a
blunder from the Frenchman in the end
which we will show a bit later on but uh
this one Fabian is fighting he's alive
he's covered everything for now yeah I
mean this the tone in your voice I have
that same feeling where it should be
winning right it looked so dominant
before and suddenly fabbio has counter
chances of his own his Bishop that is
firmly entrenched on the E4 square that
applies some pressure towards the white
king now there's a pawn under attack and
if you try to push the pawn Fabiano will
continue to challenge it with his own
Pawn he needs to open files give himself
some counterplay he's doing just that I
see the Eva bar it's always been good
for white but black has legitimate
chances all of a sudden and the more
hope that nck keeps giving a Fabby the
the easier his position gets as well by
now Fabby it almost feels like should
have been checkmated in this game all
the sacrifices that we were looking at
Knight takes Pawn earlier on the Knight
landing on F6 none of that has happened
this is a big big strategic technical
Advantage but is it going to be really
enough to wrap up the game will Fabby
manage to create the counterplay on the
open files that you're pointing at you
can take on C5 opening up the D line as
well trying to look for infiltration
with your own Rook but I think what nbec
wants in case of a trade on C5 is to
actually recapture it with the Rook
because notice how the d8 square is
actually defended by the queen yeah
possibly uh so Fabiano hesitating from
Trading anything off it's really tough
here the problem is if you do manage to
open lines maybe actually backfires on
black the black king is always in a
mating net and here we see the
evaluation bar errupt on the white side
uh that means there's most likely a
knockout blow I'm looking at some
sacrifices again I'm getting carried
away always looking for Rook takes G6
check I think you need to set it up but
uh yeah Fabiano maybe one of the worst
openings I've seen from him but he is at
least for now uh well surviving it's one
of these positions where with the eval
bar I think we're led to believe there
must be something maybe I'll sacrifice I
actually think that white is winning
long term but the players don't know
that they know that Black's in bad shape
but NC's not sitting there being like Oh
I have this win in the bag he's like
well how do actually crash through and
sometimes we're only human we get
impatient with our decisions thinking I
just need to find that open file I need
to get that sacrifice going I need to
get at the black king what you really
need to do and something I think is why
five didn't take the pawn C5 is line
your queen and Bishop up on the same
diagonal if white could accomplish that
game over on the spot but that Bishop on
E5 it's in great shape that's why the
black queen sits where it does it is not
letting the White Queen in and whoa this
move has played a very natural looking
move and the eval bar is unimpressed
yeah and uh that's the thing about
playing these really elite players such
as Fabiano Magnus Nakamura you need to
keep knocking them punching them
punching them down even when you have a
dominant position like this where they
can barely move they tend to wle somehow
and then you get frustrated then the uh
kind of fear of botching it gets into
your head and yeah you can self-destruct
very very easily I like this last move
however from nbec even if it's not
winning yes it could have uh May
potentially been better but he's just
keeping the tension and in what is now
pretty much a Blitz game looking at the
clock I think it's still incredibly hard
for Fabiano to find the move so must be
frustrating for nck but still in the
driver's seat so much tension on the
board and that last move does it just
keep the tension or does it reflect that
nck perhaps is struggling to find a way
forward in this position he is and he's
spending time fa is the one down under
two minutes but notbe he's looking
across the board trying to find that
winning idea and I think for fabbi that
should feel at least pretty good even if
he goes on to lose this this game the
fact that he was able to Challenge nck
from a position that looked hopeless
earlier uh nbe's the one struggling at
the moment and Fabby does take a
decision that's a committal one he
decides to trade the pawn now earlier on
I thought that he wants to take it with
the Rook but instead he recaptures with
his own Pawn One Thing Fabby can't allow
is that pawn from C5 moving ahead to C6
because then it becomes a real strength
notice how the bishop and The Rook are
lined up against that so it's still safe
but it means Fab's Rook on Cate needs to
remain passive a queen trade has been
offered C5 Pawn is hanging does white
have to actually go into an end game
right now he can block this queen
exchange White's Bishop can step in the
way to F6 as it has just done on the
board uh blocking the queen trade
kicking Black's Queen away but it does
feel like Fabiano with this last move
surprised NOC somewhat and uh at least
now the kind of inroads the uh squares
the entry squares that the White Queen
wants to use have been blocked out so
Fabiano yeah he's going to open files
with his Queen he's still fighting still
kick kicking he just needs to improve
the black Rooks and then real counter
chances great prophylactic move though
from ner Beck just getting his King out
of check's way and I think Fabby can do
something similar he can bring his King
one square close in the diagonal towards
the center he does just that I think
it's a really smart choice for him
because if that bishop ever leaves then
a queen trade will be on offer once more
I actually don't see how white crashes
through this is frustrating for myself
as a commentator I can only imagine for
nordbeck as a player yeah and you can
see it a bit jery now as fiddles with a
piece exhales frowns he's I mean visibly
frustrated visibly disappointed because
his position was worth so much more he
knew he was winning he knew he was one
or two accurate moves away from crashing
through breaking through Black's
defenses ultimately though it looks like
black has set up a perfect blockade
nearly every black pawn and every black
piece on light squares other than the A7
pawn and uh right now he set up this
barracade that's hard to break through
it's been a fantastic game from nck so
one can understand that frustration and
very importantly if White's Queen tries
to land on F6 anytime that the bishop
moves Black's Queen will slide back to
that E7 square and keep everything under
control for NC the way forward to me
would look that you have to find a path
in which your Rook can join the attack
try to bring your Rook to the open file
but notice how the bishop on e4 actually
stops that B1 Square guards it the queen
on D7 is stopping the D1 Square it's
really difficult to actually get your
Rooks to participate in the attack right
now and I was going to suggest that very
move from Fabiano he's bring another
piece into the defense at some moment
watch out for the move Pawn E5 it may
sacrifice a pawn but he's okay
jettisoning that pawn if it opens up
some lines for the rest of his pieces I
like not deck's full board awareness
that Rook it really wasn't doing
anything now the king is where it is for
black let's slide on over to the B file
that's an open Line let's try to double
my Rooks at some point O but indecision
from Fabiano maybe the time pressure
kicking in as well as he nears one
minute he drops his Rook back he's just
given two free moves to Abdu satov and
uh now how could the young USC profit
he's going to move his Bishop back
massive threat of Queen into F6 black
has to offer that Queen trade we've
mentioned it before and now the White
Queen does she Retreat she does finally
repurposing that piece and he's got a
threat on the board I think that Queen
on F2 it's a retreating move but at some
point it's eyeing that A7 Pawn as well
so you've got to watch out for the C
Pawn moving forward and Fabby brings his
Rook to the seventh rank defense so
defending A7 and both sides are going to
make mistakes here because we see Fabby
down to a minute n he's trying to punish
fa on the clock he may think that's his
best chance because of how stubborn
Fab's been but if he could trade off
some pieces if Fab's able to do that and
get some checks against the white king
he may have some chances to survive
Black's been under attack the whole game
on the king side maybe it's time for
black to suddenly counter and flip the
script play G5 yourself open lines
against the white king you mentioned it
Robert uh go for the Counterattack he's
trying to do similar in a different way
attacking White's far Advanced H6 Pawn
this time and NC just gives it up he's
ready to swing the white Rook cross and
block any captures and Fabby just
maintaining his setup yo-yoing back and
forth with the black queen just banking
on the fact that he's stable and white
has the pressure of creating a plan and
no dearbeck might make this plan he
slide his second Rook over to the B file
and sacrifice his Rook for a bishop on
B7 that might be what's whoa speaking of
sacrifice he gives up a pawn wow we were
looking at these ideas if the A7 Pawn
was hanging but this is a Full Sacrifice
The Rook jumps on to B8 it hits the
queen you you've got to move it up to E7
because you need to keep the H4 Square
under control but the white rook's
coming behind it's in and behind just
like Magnus Carlson did against fua
earlier today you bring the Rook behind
you've pin pinned a weakness on H7 no
way for black to defend the H7 P once
the white Rook swings the whole way into
the corner NC abdat has found a way to
break through he has and I think Fabby
has to bring his own Rook to attack the
White Queen but that's not going to be
sufficient T it you spied it the queen
eyes that A7 Pawn you bring your Rook
all the way down for the attack the
queen takes a pawn with check and I
think both of those pawns would be lost
so he moves Queen up but Rook h8 that
seems Queen H4 that was the point that
you need to keep the queen defending
that square and queen F6 is a massive
threat how do you fight it you don't
fight it it's handshakes not a Beck
comes back and that means we've got two
Armageddon coming up the players there
sitting to check out analyze a little
bit but they've got a big game coming up
wow what a comeback from The Comeback
Kid both The Comeback Kid and hikara
Nakamura the streamer the content
creator and someone who created his own
chances just to be in the survival stage
but nbec gusarov the world rapid
Champion back in 2021 he now has a lot
of pressure on him to write his bid down
and figure out if he wants the white or
black pieces but what a game that was
what a game and what a survival stage
all decisive so far all white wins and
uh armag getting to look forward to at
this point I would be shocked if the
players aren't bidding for white yeah
you just said all white wins so do they
go really really high with their bits
trying to get uh that those white pieces
now hey G Nakamura he lost every
Armageddon with the black pieces do you
think he's going to switch that up try
to get the white pieces that's really
difficult because if you think that he's
going to bid for the white pieces then
you can bid a high number and get black
with say 12 minutes on the clock I don't
know what hi car is going to do I think
he has to forget about the past easier
said than done yes definitely and not a
back up toov there on our screens he's
having a think right now he's
strategizing about what color he wants
and if he wants to go with black how low
can he afford to go against a player
like Fabiano car
yeah it's really tough you can sense the
internal dilemma there he's trying to
read the opponent trying to decide on
his own mood especially after that
exhilarating white win and eventually he
submits his bid he goes to make his last
minute preparations Armageddon very
shortly things are heating up in Toronto
both our survival stage matches go into
Armageddon and uh we've had four
decisive results four decisive games
with Fabiano te taking the lead then n
striking back Maxim vagra taking the
lead in his first game Nakamura striking
back and we've got two armag gons David
you mentioned there was a big blunder in
the Hikaru game there was and we didn't
get to see how that concluded I just
wanted to show everyone how Nakamura
wrapped up that comeback and struck
against Maxim Vash GRA with a with a bit
of a helping hand from the opponent and
actually it was just when Vash grav had
achieved the best position he'd had all
game black in this position was able to
control some Dart squares and erect a
strong Pawn Center by putting his Pawn
on E5 Nakamura though is so good at
switching Direction at rotating his
pieces probing for weaknesses and a
really sneaky Retreat here Bishop to F1
provoked a gamechanging blunder from
Vash gra Vash gra could have held things
together here in various ways one would
for example would have been to push the
pawn forward to E4 creating a nice
Square for the Black Knight game on
anything could have happened but instead
the very careless the complacent Bishop
to B7 developing but forgetting about a
weakness suddenly the Black Knight was
undefended the Black Knight was hit and
once it moved he simply dropped a pawn
in the center and actually just two
moves later he resigned prematurely
perhaps a very early resignation but
white is a pawn up with full control
Nakamura took it hiari took it
flawlessly after that great technique
there four wins in survival stage all
with white pieces two armag what are the
mind games like what are the bids going
to be like we're going to find that
let's head over to Toronto with
Ka there will be and Armageddon to
decide who will be knocked out and who
goes through here in the CCT finals
Maxim Hikaru go ahead and turn your
boards maybe the most important bids you
have placed this week 949 954 you will
play with the black p SEC car are you
happy with winning the bids I mean I
think after so many army guns you just
pick the time and just whatever color
you got that's how it goes doesn't
matter we'll see are you do you agree
that bids definitely are higher here
than what we've seen in the online
portion of the tour yeah because you can
play the first 15 moves and like 5
Seconds online you can't do that here so
it's much different yeah how are you
feeling about this uh Maxim white pieces
in a game that is must win I mean so far
I haven't had much luck in zedon so
we'll see like I'm just hoping to
finally click some things together
thanks for placing your bit bids here
guys this will be an exciting one back
to you
guys awesome andaru Nakamura wins the
bid with the black pieces but is that a
good thing because thus far he has gone
0 and4 in Armageddon losing to Maxim vas
lrav in the second round of the round
robin stage so once again Hikaru gets
the black pieces Maxim gets white if
history repeats itself that's good news
for the
Frenchmen wow this is going to be
exciting and we've got some good news
for everyone watching as uh we've got
the cool displates for you decorate your
life and your walls with these
lightweight posters they don't damage
your walls they look very sexy and you
can get a 33% off using the code chess
you got to head over to displate.com
sless and there's more chess that is uh
coming up with two Armageddon in the
survival stage one player will be
eliminated one will move down to the
losers bracket and we are going to go
into a shot break don't go
anywhere
[Music]
Fabiano caruana started his journey from
division 2 and his climb through the
ranks has been formidable winning
division 2 in the air things Masters
qualified him for division 1 in the
cheser bille Masters where he beat
Hikaru Nakamura on the way to his first
of two back-to-back Grand finals Fabiano
cannot lose this game he's a por up 10
seconds David yeah two pawns up wow but
a horrible Bond structure yeah but it's
all about the white PA if he keeps the
central porn alive he
might oh my God you sit in a blunder
shate in one and hiar immediately does
you commentator's curse a one Checkmate
and that is going to cause Hikaru the
whole match there we go does it
immediately he finds it there is no
square for the queen they have to be
traded off and he jumps in with the
Knight but it's too late the C3 Pawn is
super strong and this black pawn is
going to completely paralyze the white
pieces and I think he's had enough heura
is the winner of the cheser Masters
Fabiano Karana resigns Queen D2 is that
the winning move and that's it we have a
winner not be Abdus wins the chess kid
cup but playing Division 1 in another
two events has banked him a total of 325
tour points to secure second place on
the standings and a well-deserved ticket
to
Toronto
Alara fuja impressed big time in the
incredibly difficult qualification and
playin stage to earn division one spots
in four events this season on the
Champions chess tour in the Julius bear
generation cup fua beat his young rival
NOC Abdu satarov on the way to his first
and only Grand Final we jumped in just
as we're about to see a result this
night check gains an important Tempo
next move black Bishop picks up the
White Knight peace up and he's going to
go through fuja lost to Magnus Carson
but with 18 tour points he qualified for
the ultimate showdown in Toronto he's
trying to check don't take the queen
it's poisoned that would be stalemate
and a draw PR me you don't have to take
the queen and Magnus he's going to
resign two queens are better than one
it's over and this means everyone we
will see Armageddon to decide this match
this one is over look the Pawn's about
to promote yeah he's going for checkmate
but this is full on yeah black queen on
the board now is going to win this game
Magnus he's got it he's got it in the
end and wow what a fight though that was
amazing it's over Magnus Carlson he
takes it this is the winner of the
Julius bear generation cup after an
exciting final match
here a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
the 2021 World rapid Champion the
youngest ever a World rapid Champion
continues giving nightmares to the world
number two Fabiano Carana making his
comeback taking this into
Armageddon and it's all going to be
about who gets to win that bill bid who
gets the white pieces who gets to play
with the result odds and we've got Ka
with the players and their bids four
games in the survival stage so far all
of them won by the player with the white
pieces so now I am super excited to see
the bids for the armagedon go ahead you
guys and turn your boards will they be
high is that 14 yeah 14
14 and we have 1014 with the black so
you will play with the black pieces how
do you feel about that Bobby yeah I I
had a feeling would play with black um I
wasn't sure exactly how high a notbe
would go I guess pretty high um but okay
we'll see it's a going to be a close one
I guess yeah so you will place face
Fabby who will have quite a lot of time
with the black pieces how do you feel
about how this bit
ended um you know I will anyway I want
to play with white so yeah we'll see
best of luck to both of you thanks for
placing your bits back to you guys wow
Ka not a back really going for the white
pieces with that 14-minute bid right
there yeah he gets what he asked for but
Fabiano also gets a lot of time 10
minutes and 14 seconds I know he just
had a disaster in that first game but
he's got great opening preparation the
onlyus on the player with the white
pieces five should not be displeased
yeah it can't get much worse for Fabiano
that previous game I think that would
have shaken off the cobwebs and uh this
next one he'll just set up store he's
going to play solidly it will be
pressure on Abdu Abdu satov to win to
take risks and uh yeah Brave bid he
needs to back it up now yeah very brave
bid indeed and nbec Abdus satra making
his intentions clear that he's ready to
fight for the full point till the very
end Hikaru Nakamura meanwhile won his
bid and chose the black pieces we're
going to head into Toronto and check in
with Danny Danny the bids anything
surprising you
there I don't know that I'm surprised
but I am impressed at this point you saw
both Notre Beck and Fab I guess kind of
get what they wanted the confidence that
Notre Beck had in taking the white
pieces despite Robert's point that Fabby
is great at prep yeah he doesn't lose
with black like that that often so I'm
kind of in a spot where I kind of like
both players chances I like Notre Beck's
confidence but I love Fab's time a
little bit of behind the scenes Fabiano
did come out and say I had a feeling he
was going to do that which is why I bid
so high but he also said I didn't know
he was he wanted it that bad maybe
should have gone for 11 minutes cuz
10:14 or whatever I think his time was
there is a that's a lot of time it's a
lot of going to lose like that twice
well not only that I mean you look at
fuia just took I think like 9 Minutes
against Magnus I mean 1014 a whole
minute plus that that is a lot so again
I like the youngsters confidence but I'm
definitely looking at Fabiano caran
rebound from that but all right we got
to go back to the one before the break
yeah that's nuts this is nuts right so
hikaro Nakamura has bid for black four
times yes he's won four bids and he's
gotten black four times and and he's
lost all four games and four yet he goes
into this one bidding for black again
yes just winning in a Smith Morrow with
white that is a man who believes in his
approach he trusts in himself regardless
of the form that he's gotten here are
you are you impressed by that there's so
much to unpack so the definition of
insanity is doing the same exact thing
over and over but expecting a different
result I actually think hearu despite
losing four Armageddon with black truly
believes in the fact that in every
single one of those Armageddon he was
two or three correct moves away from
winning the Armageddon and that's what
we talked about at the beginning of the
show it's just been those clutch time
decisions he's got completely fine
positions a lot of these Armageddon and
just like the game that he just lost
against mvl it was an end game and it
was super close yep and he lost it and
if there was ever a moment in this event
to write the ship it's right now and I
just want to quickly add a point that
it's it's obviously not gone his way
here but overall Hikaru has been very
successful with black and armag again I
mean Magnus made the point that until
this win Magnus had as white neither of
them had ever won with white Armageddon
they had always won with black so hikaro
believes in the strategy he's sticking
with it and I don't know what are the
questions you got there Oslo but we're
we're excited well I got one question
for you too historically players like to
have the black pieces Armageddon but
here in Toronto players with the white
pieces have done really well so what do
you make of hikaro sticking to Black
once again as you guys were just talking
about is that something that isn't
existing in Toronto that exists in the
outside
world no it's it is it is really
interesting uh and I my the reason I
explained what insanity is is it's not
to say oh Hikaru is insane like what's
doing it's a fifth time he's choosing
black it's he believes it's the right
strategy and he has been multiple
moments away from being 50% in
Armageddon and not 0% in arm and he
really believes that this is the
strategy and he just had a bad run and
he knows what he's doing he almost
always chooses black no I agree and so
to answer your question Robert I don't
know white has had a little more going
for it here in Toronto apparently but I
think historically we all tend to look
at the black pieces that draw odds as a
big Advantage hikaro believes in it or
he wouldn't have done it again so like
the rest of you let's go let's go eat
some snacks in the lounge with Magnus
and and see what see what
happens I agree Danny really surprising
that Hikaru after losing uh those four
games with Armageddon sticks to pla so
some big decisions that you got two big
Armageddon coming up in Toronto and the
chess will start really soon and it is
of course a big big matchup one player
will be eliminated uh and for Hikaru
Nakamura it is against Maxim Vash gra
and there they are they are ready to go
I see no Danny socks there so he decided
to switch that up and Hikaru starts with
black handshakes we are off and it is
one45 we're going to see the Berlin or
the Petro the Petro it is and wow this
variation this branch of the Petro that
he's been loyal to sticking to at
Nakamura it has traditionally had a do
doy reputation it is a porn sacrifice
but how well is Vash gr prepared
he pauses are you shocked Robert firstly
by nakamura's choice secondly by uh Vash
lra hesitating here didn't we have this
between these very two players in their
Armageddon uh in round two of the round
robin I remember Maxim's King went to D1
at some point it was a crazy game and
like Levy said Hikaru did blunder deep
into that game when the computer said it
should have been in equal position so
Maxim he's going back to this King D1
system and Maxim himself lost badly with
white against Abus satarov in round ear
today in Armageddon so I feel like
hikaro he believes in the chances for
the black pieces he believes in this
opening I don't love it it's not my
style but it is hikaru's yeah I must say
it's uh kind of refreshing to see Hikaru
kind of go so aggressive like this
throwing another Pawn forward he's a
whole porn down but uh yeah we'll have
to see how to unpick this a bit later on
it's really dramatic on this board
really dramatic already he trade out of
the opening and this one's going to be
dramatic as well as nbec Fabiano we've
got handshakes and it is go time we've
got the Queen spawn opening one more
time is it going to be the nimzo yes it
is another nimso Indian it was disaster
for Fabiano last time they faced off in
this opening but he chooses a different
branch this time as the camera goes
crazy just as the games have been so far
in today's action uh he plays Pawn to B6
Fabiano he is the first to launch a
surprise here look at Abdu satov
thinking for the first time surprised
maybe frustrated he wasn't able to get a
repeat of that first game and I'm
surprised Fabiano was 10 minutes and 11
seconds and then I remembered that
because nck wanted white so badly he
allowed Fabiano to go with a high bit
himself 10 plus minutes is a lot of time
and nir needs to win and we're getting a
pretty solid start to this one no Pawn
tension just yet unlike in the previous
game where there was an ice at to Queen
Pawn I think right now Fabiano should be
happy with how the game has started he's
playing quickly and it's in his
repertoire yeah this is uh pretty much a
polar opposite to the other Armageddon
that we're seeing today where all pieces
is still on the board very positional
black is first to Castle White King
stuck slightly awkwardly in the center
right now as Abdu satov needs to catch
up with peace development he's got a
beautiful porn Center here with white
but not much more to uh to speak of
feels like the drama is happening
Elsewhere on the other board now it's
getting really really dramatic with uh I
think we need to switch that white king
out in the center FAS gra Nakamura
Throwing Fire throwing fuel on this
board and we will bring that up uh very
very shortly and there we are and you're
absolutely right that is fire on the
board a pawn has been picked up on C6
David before we Deep dive I think we
quickly have to just take a look at how
we even got here I mean this whole
position it has blown up completely yeah
I hope we have time tan because the
players are throwing the moves down at a
crazy speed right now as Hikaru is
waiting to capture a porn I believe
that's it there we go so oh wow offering
a queen trade now that black king out in
the open the white king out in the open
who is better white is a porn up and
let's do a deep dive to see how we got
to this madness uh it was the repeat of
the opening uh we'll go back to the last
time we saw it after the move G5 the
Moose still coming thick and fast uh
here black throwing pawns forward you
need to be be fast if you're black a
pawn down and here the White Queen
stepping forward Hikaru castles into it
allowing his Pawn structure to be
shattered allowing another Pawn to drop
now nasty checks threatened against the
black king he says who cares I'm going
to Counterattack and let's catch up with
the current position white king forced
forward after a check watch out there's
Checkmate in one threatened now that's
how dangerous this is this is how it
could spin on uh yeah just one blunder
right now but this is fended off black
offers a queen trade the Bishops are too
strong so white says no and uh after
Queen to A6 check the Knight lands on e4
guarding everything and what to do if
you're Nakamura the evaluation bar means
uh well it shows that black is doing
very well very healthy position but it
looks crazy so hard to evaluate for
these uh these two humans if you could
switch the positions of the bishop and
the King for white white would be doing
extremely well white is up a pawn and
it's a healthy Pawn at that but it's not
a healthy King and it's not easy to
actually develop that Bishop because if
you after Queen D5 which was played if
you push your B Pawn say Pawn to B3 to
fetto Black fien keto's first hitting
your rook in the corner and maybe you
have time to slide your Rook over I'd
just be very concerned with all those
pieces staring towards the white king
this looks very very dodgy yeah wow this
is heating up and you're talking about
one fan black mishop can jump back
actually to C8 and start hitting that
White Queen and Target itself on the B7
Square as well I think the bishop be is
going to tell in this position it's an
open game right now that F4 Pawn looking
really nice and Maxim he's trying to
he's trying to push that pawn get his
Rook into play what's going on here is
that a big mistake wow the computer says
blunder and this is I mean I did just
check I don't think I would find this in
a million years will Hikaru find it it's
a crazy move to take advantage of the
fact the White Queen is pretty much
trapped
Robert Pawn to C6 break this down for us
not happening oh well Bishop C8 is
coming and I think white would like to
play Pawn to B3 to reinforce the
protection of the and ifar finds it he
plays C6 and that's going to be a shot
to MV system and his chances remember
the loser of this game of this match
they're out of the tournament and a B3
for white you're trying to get your
queen to C4 desperately he plays it
Bishop B4 check you have to play Pawn to
C3 and I'm not sure if I can sacrifice a
piece but Queen takes B3 becomes very
tempting here how does white survive
this I think the answer is you don't if
Nakamura finds this continuation a
bishop check and then Queen takes Pawn
this is simply over firstly because look
at this White Queen she's still trapped
and uh this full board awareness
switching the bishop back it's on his
radar Nakamura this is what he set up
and the problem is the White Queen has
no safe squares if she drops back then
Checkmate the white king caught in the
center of the board oh my god wow brutal
tactics here if he finds the move Bishop
check he is winning hikara Nakamura on
un believable when you said C6 in my
head I was thinking there's no way that
a player finds this and Hikaru just
plays it in seconds his understanding of
this position his as you mentioned the
full board awareness the bishop C8 idea
that we were talking about earlier but
he's just taken away all the key Escape
squares from White Queens he pauses he's
reaching out and I think he was about to
reach out for the bishop he does but he
doesn't play the check he plays Bishop
to G7 instead but similar ideas but that
variation was not that easy to spot I
mean when you have the ability to take
moves back sure but you would have to
slide your Bishop back next to the king
some of these tactics there are a lot of
them they are going to be difficult to
find so harkar still in the better
position and weird preparation is still
preparation it's what's allowing Hikaru
to play on feel on intuition he knows
he's got chances here but mvl he should
be happy to still be in this game yeah
he's just playing for survival right now
mvl but he will need to win eventually
with white in this Armageddon now he's
begging he's praying for a queen trade
because then the white king will live to
fight another day but this check
erroneous perhaps because white can
block white can block with a pawn right
now and he does so Nakamura panicking
there slightly it's about the clock
right now I think he would have found a
knockout punch with just a minute or two
extra and then the dark score Bishop for
white can slide out off for a trade and
as soon as some of Black's attackers
come off the board let's not forget that
black doesn't have so many Pawns in
front of his own King and that Knight on
e4 it's great it can slide into C5 this
is looking scary for hiar Nakamura all
of a sudden I didn't think I'd be saying
that but he slipped and now ma can knock
him out he rushed with Queen A5 check
and now he pauses but what's the reason
that he can't grab on A4 why can't he
just pick up a pawn right now I think he
can and he will but uh it's more about
the fact that whites King now is just
entirely safe and look at the
frustration from Nakamura he did
underestimate White's reply the block to
this check and uh maybe we can show this
queen takes porn right now and uh white
as Robert says can at the very minimum
just challenge the Bishops maybe there's
better but uh now as soon as these
Bishops depart from the board White's
King is safe as anything white has a
beautiful Knight this Superior minor
piece right now and actually it's the
black king that might come under a heavy
fire in the near future white can push
pawns forward white can swing The Rook
to the a file oh my God it's turning and
it's all about King safety right now and
hamura is panicking you can see it he's
cons he's just shaking his head and I
think it all came down to that one check
the most natural looking move right you
just move the queen give a check you
avoid Queen trades and now suddenly he's
in big big trouble yeah perhaps he
shouldn't have been uh kind of afraid uh
of that Queen trade because black does
have two really powerful Bishops black
has advanced pawns on the king side and
I think had full compensation for the
pawn so end games wouldn't have been so
bad instead it was super tempting to
give a check but there's no followup and
that initial check with the bishop while
you see the engine go all the way down
the players they don't have that so he
didn't know that there was a winning
followup it looked like you push a pawn
the bishop has to move again so his
understandable decisions are backfiring
and look at this position now he is just
really disheartened he's down to 4
minutes he can't believe it he's been
thinking for 2 minutes you've got three
legal moves on the board you either
retreat with the queen or pick up the
pawn on A4 I think he's just fighting
his mind right now he is hating what
he's gotten himself into yeah that
winning idea that winning continuation
we showed was very difficult super
difficult but he probably wishes he
spent 2 minutes on that moment rather
than 2 minutes here where it's already
verging on too late we see the Bishops
disappear this is the variation we
showed and now he's trying to seek
Solace seek safety in in in an end game
and uh the Queen's coming off I see a
Pawn on G5 hanging though it feels like
this is by far the worst possible
version of an end game he could have
hoped for but he's in damage control
damage limitation mode right now Hikaru
and Maxim Dodgers doesn't take the offer
of that free porn on G5 and again
Hikaru angling for this end game
now wow all right this one uh hot action
here we'll quickly check in with nbec
versus Fabiano caruana because that one
as well a lot has happened I mean there
supposed to be a white bar on H2 what on
Earth is a black bar on H2 doing it's
like they're playing checkers and the
same board but different games all of
black pieces on dark squares many of
wh's pieces on light squares but I'm
just trying to do a quick material count
looks like extra Pawn for black it's the
pawn H2 it'll be captured any moment but
where's the rub what is going to happen
here that would even challenge black
setup yeah I think White needs to just
try and trade off Rooks White's rook in
the corner fast as sleep Black's
position is slightly loose you could
imagine losing control here if white
somehow able to get one of the white
Rooks active onto the seventh rank uh
meanwhile this umbrella porn as you've
called it Robert this kind of double
agent on H2 I actually think it really
suits Abdus satov here it just blocks up
Black's attack and uh still in the
balance this one still in the balance we
will check in with this let's go where
the action is Hikaru Nakamura against
Maxim Vash
wow a lot is being offered for trade
that last move hinting at opening up the
B file a queen trade on offer now let's
remind everyone for that for Hikaru he
needs only a draw Maxim has to win on
Demand with the white pieces who does
the queen trade favor here well White's
position is just better because people
think Queens are gone no attack look at
The Rook it's staring down the Bel line
towards the black king that second Rook
can come to the a file and there could
be an attack plus Black's pawns are
hanging and speaking of a rook on the a
file there it is so Queen tra doesn't
get black out of the woods and look at
the speed with which Maxim is playing
he's putting so much pressure on
hikaru's clock right now no increment
until move 60 we're halfway through to
that but Black's King Under Fire as well
yeah he knows the clock is an ally maybe
not the best move fash graph but a
testing move he's challenging Nakamura
he's saying okay Queen trade please on
my terms you have to make that decision
and if not I might go for your king I
might Checkmate you and White's Knight
on e4 was on pre but you cannot pick it
up even though the D Pawn was pin I
think that were check mating ideas uh
David with the Rook taking the B5 pawn
and you can finish that line yeah let's
show that Tanya really important I'd
actually forgotten that the night was on
PR it was up for grabs due to this pin
but as you mentioned it just loses
control over too many squares a check
and now if you do try and step into the
corner it's the other one yeah boom
another check stri the black king of its
shelter and a ladder Checkmate here the
queen and Rook trapping the king so
Nakamura he's trying to hold this Pawn
with his Rook now maybe hinting that
he's threat to take this Knight a big
blunder by Maxim Vash lra what happened
Vash lra he's whoa he's going in for the
attack but he's walked into Checkmate
black can play Rook takes Pawn oh oh my
God he misses it Maxi misses it Hikaru
misses it it's very hard to see that
when you don't have the evaluation bar
nobody is looking at that move the queen
was just protecting that pawn but Rook
takes D3 check and we just backtrack
there if you take back with the pawn the
queen takes the Rook with check and
you're going to deliver checkm on E2 so
it was a very difficult spot no one's
tapping you on the shoulder like the
eval bar is for us but there was an
opportunity there so easy to miss he did
miss it but he still has control
Nakamura he can just slide his Rook
across now defend the B B5 Pawn I think
he's got everything covered his defense
is pretty sturdy right now and it's just
about the clock under two minutes in
such a crazy position just watch out
though if you're white finally black is
soon threatening to take that white
knight off the board so Vash gra defends
it w so easy to miss this is The Madness
of Armageddon I mean crazy position fair
play to both for going into this mess
and the craziness continues the position
continues to get more and more wild now
a pawn has been thrown forward opening
up the Queen's path directing towards
that H2 Pawn that can be picked up with
check if white was to grab on F3 I think
that big miss that happened the
Checkmate Miss neither of them have
realized it no chance I mean it's such
an obscure tactic not something they
were looking at and they are looking at
if there's going to be a repetition a
perpetual because that black queen can
start delivering some checks can the
white king Escape that's the big
question the evaluation is going in hi
car's favor but 1 minute 51 seconds or a
move 34 if the complications continue
can Hikaru keep the pace yeah Hikaru
he's been doing great so far the black
queen can now com and Munch on some
pawns I think if he needed to find it if
there was nothing else he would have
found that checkmating idea earlier but
he's done such a good job of keeping
control he knows he's got everything
covered and this is just good enough
simply and look at this it is the white
king suddenly coming under heavy fire
White's Queen I mentioned it before in
other games is so far distan from his
own King right now no defense and
pressure on the White Knight threats of
some checks Black's Queen coming in
diagonally the H2 Pawn hanging vasra
he's running out of resources and he
gives a check the black Rook blocks
where's he he's offering Queen trade now
but he could have traded queens before
on favorable terms for him in fact there
was a moment where he would have had a
huge Advantage now he's just down
material and whoa no Queen trade to zaru
wow no Queen trade but look at the clock
1 and A2 minutes we're at move 38 no
increment until move
60 well Nakamura is not out the woods on
the clock yet this is all going to be
about flagging for maxim VRA that's his
big Hope on the board he is busted black
has got two extra pawns the king
absolutely safe look at those queens and
those two Rooks just guarding guarding
the king making sure that there's
absolutely no attack the White Knight
can't really jump onto activity because
of the C2 Pawn the bishop on F3
controlling all the squares black can
just start pushing up the pawns on the
king side Maxim's busted and he has no
attack whatsoever in fact the white king
is in more danger Hikaru has defended
perfectly from any trouble on that side
of the board and as you said Tanya he
can start pushing his own pawns canaru
the G pawn and the H Pawn they roll the
only thing sorry David the I just want
to say the only thing Maxim can attack
is hikaru's clock right now yeah vintage
Nakamura I just wanted to say he's got
everything covered stabilizing and uh if
this was online zero chance for white he
would pre-move his way to Victory
Nakamura so as you men mentioned Tanya
it is about uh yeah it is about that
clock but getting the Queens off now
pretty much by force should get him one
step closer there we go it's all about
those two pawns such easy moves now that
the quein are off and Nakamura massive
favorite surely he'll convert this the
pawns are coming and if you're fighting
against hikaru's clock that's really not
giving you much hope probably the
fastest player on the planet definitely
with a mouse in his hand but Armageddon
it's it's throwing up surprises before
Max seem's trying to muddy the waters
trying to complicate things but and you
see Hikaru he's doing the head Bob he is
dancing to some lfi girl music he's
having a good time because suddenly all
he needs is a draw and he might even win
this game but is he allowing some
counterplay from Maxim there's only 13
moves to make he has a minute and 12
seconds so I think he has everything
under control I just saw Rook jump into
the action but no it's not going to be
anything for maxim Maxim's trying his
best to complicate it he's trying to
push the pawns trying to get some Knight
jumps in the air Knights are so tricky
with no time but again finding every
defensive move Nakamura everything
covered still two pawns to the good he's
fended off the the threats and look at
the confidence with which Hikaru is
busting out those moves and uh just
playing uh it seems like the correct
chess here he pins the White Knight as
well the H5 Pawn can't be picked up
because there are sacrifices on B3 it's
done I mean once these Rooks are coming
off the board there's no way black can
lose and I'm looking at the move number
I'm looking how much time aaru has he's
just trading pieces pushing pawns how
could you possibly loses unless you walk
into a fork and even though Maxim has
got six minutes on the clock his only
hope is to not give Hikaru enough time
to think that's why he keeps on blitzing
the moves but it's not going to be
enough with just six moves to make it to
time control to get that extra second
that gepon will be decisive yeah he's
pretty much pre-moving at this point and
he has a move counter at the side of him
and he knows he's safe he gets the draw
nakamura's through it's game set match
Hikaru Nakamura he wins the Armageddon
with a draw he takes it well it's a draw
in the end but Hikaru goes through Maxim
vasher lrav is eliminated of the
Champions chest of finals and we were
just talking about how the players of
the white pieces were doing quite well
in Armageddon Maxim he sent home two
games with white and armagedon today
unfortunately for him two bad results in
this game it looks like Fabi carwan has
everything under control it's even
material the white is kind of up a pawn
that A3 Pawn that one is actually alive
and well the H2 Pawn can be captured at
some moment I'm more worried about the
white King there's a rook on G5 playing
offense and defense simultaneously the
Dion Sanders of Rooks over there
protecting the E5 Pawn while threatening
the G2 Pawn I think Fab he's controlling
the board pretty well yeah right now
Abdus satov has to decide how to block
you definitely don't want to move the
king and take that shelter Pawn black
Rook the uh Dion Sanders just go slides
across and delivers Checkmate so you
have to block I'm surprised he's even
thinking here looks so natural to drop
the Rook back but now the queen again
trying to angle her way in such strong
play from Fabiano big big threats Queen
to F1 is a Checkmate in two threat again
prevented he's really having to contort
himself here AB dorov just to
survive and we see the black queen
continues to pursue white species now
the bishop is attacked there are threats
on the back rank which will force white
to grab the H Pawn and that would be the
end of the game as you mentioned the
Rook will slide over big pressure on uh
uh on nbec right now no coordination of
his pieces and we see actually where the
bids come into play right now Fabiano if
he had say 50 seconds he could be in
some trouble here because at any point
notbe can Retreat his pieces try to keep
that a pawn but with 2 minutes and 50
seconds on Fab's clock because he was
able to get the black pieces with 10
plus minutes to start he's doing very
well and he's keeping control of all the
key squares trust me guys people need to
stop putting their Queens on A5 I said
it for black twice in a row they put
Queens on A5 they got checkmated now
White's Queen on A5 just like it was
professionally gra and you're almost
getting checkmated and it's suddenly
game over Black's Queen is coming in his
Queen is too far away Abdu satoro no way
to defend suddenly my gosh you can't
move the Rook to E2 there's a m on G1
the only square is Bring The Rook to F1
but now you got to check on E1 you got M
on H5 it's Checkmate and look at see on
nock's face you can't believe it but
it's a win for Fabiano Carana he sails
through the semis nck is still alive but
he has to now face an angry hungry
Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru Nakamura who has
used up two of his n lives today it
feels like surviving elimination twice
will play against nbec Abdu satov and
one of them will be eliminated Fabiano
Carana he reacts you can see the relief
on him nck gosh that was close and he's
finally gotten over the Abdus satar of
Hump unfortunately for Fabiano he's been
really a tough opponent for him nybeck
beat him in the chess kid cup he beat
him in the Olympiad a year ago but Fabby
he's able to take him down now did you
see that nck stopped and had a look at
what happened in the Hikaru game just to
see who will be his uh next opponent you
got one more match coming up in the
survival stage that will decide the
final
semi-finalist what a day and it's still
continuing and we just getting started
on that David what about you what stood
out to you in this big match so many
highlights we're really spoiled for
Choice here so many checkmating attacks
including Fabiano delivering mate in the
to Abdu satov but I just wanted to go
back to that highlight that clash
between Vash gra and Nakamura it's a
Pity one of them had to go home because
they both fought so hard and both
deserved to go through in the end it was
Nakamura who did take it by grinding out
a victory in the Armageddon but uh
Bishop to G7 here in this position I
just want to highlight the two moments
he could have wrapped it up sooner
Nakamura maybe an even more on form
Hikaru would have spotted the two
winning blows firstly he could have
given a check in this position and now I
just wanted to point out this beautiful
Retreat one more more time one we showed
earlier full board awareness the White
Queen is the only defender of this D
Pawn so he could have slid back uh in
this variation with a bishop to C8
winning the game due to this checkmating
threat he also missed a small
opportunity a bit later on with Rook
takes D3 out of the blue this tactic is
bound to appear on puzzle rush in future
Rook takes D3 with checkm check mating
ideas even all over the place but uh in
the end Hikaru despite missing these did
take the
win stunning stunning game that was
start to finish so many twists and turns
and Hikari Nakamura again and will be
playing against nbec Abdus satov NC did
beat Hikaru in the round robin will
Hikaru gets get his revenge will he be
able to move on to the semi-finals or
will nbec take this one it's all
happening right here in the city of
Toronto and we will be going to Toronto
in just a
few
[Music]
we are in Toronto the tour finals and
Maxim V is here and uh so knowing the
format the Fantastic players we have
here what is in store for the fans
watching the CCT finals do first of all
this matches are kind of fling nice as
the time control I think is not too slow
uh it's also not too fast so like uh
it's possible to for the games so you
know I'll be looking to get one of those
to spots and the battle for for these
two spots will be Savage I think and uh
if we do have some new fans watching how
will you describe your playing style I
like two types of things that looks
contradictory but actually work out so I
look for bloodless fights you know big
complications that you
know I cannot navigate but I'm hoping
that my open and cannot navigate and you
know out of the mess maybe I'll have
spent a little less time than my oppent
I like to play uh quite fast in general
and when it comes to the last second I
trust my instincts so if we do have
blood on the board does that mean you're
comfortable with those kind of games uh
well as long as it's not literal blood
I'm okay with that how do you see your
chances to win it I know among others
Magnus uh will want revent
I feel confident about my chances I feel
I can play at a very high level I'm
going to be an optimist and look for the
top spots well Mel we wish you best of
luck in the tour finals thank you so
much thank you
[Applause]
K if you're in a must-win situation you
do not want to face Wesley so one of the
most precise players in chess history he
makes very few mistakes and when he has
an advantage he does not let let it slip
out of his grasp just ask Magnus Carlson
in the 2019 Fisher random World
Championship Wesley so dominated his
final match against Magnus Carlson very
one-sided Affair that showcased how
strong Wesley can be when he's at his
best back towards standard chess he
plays a healthy dose of one E4 in fact
he made a chessable course over 50 hours
worth of material on the Move E4 and all
the ins and outs of the positions he
likes while Wesley so may be one of the
most precise players it does not mean
he's unafraid to take risk in this 2016
Blitz game against none other than Gary
Kasparov Wesley he sacrificed the pawn
he has a lead in development and he
played the spry B4 move giving up
another Pawn because after C takes B4 he
made his Rook to C1 a pin along the SE
file and after black developed with
Knight to E7 Queen B3 the attack raged
on and Wesley won a very nice game so he
is showing that he's unafraid to enter
tactical territory if the position calls
for
it
[Applause]
[Music]
Fabiano Carana famously had a seven out
of seven start at the 2014 sful cup he
also challenged Magnus Carlson for the
2018 World Chess Championship title how
does a player get there you might ask
for five of Carana it is feared opening
preparation he is a theoretician like no
other in this 2016 game from the London
chess classic Fabian a car want to
demonstrated how deep his opening
preparation can go with the white piece
against Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru
sacrificed is a knight temporarily with
Knight takes G4 after Fabiano takes this
Knight on G4 with his Bishop hikara
looks to win back the piece with E5
hitting the queen and the Knight with
his Pawn but Fabiana Carana was a man on
a mission he says you're not going to
get your peace back I'm going to
sacrifice my queen on F6 and after the
bishop took the queen he puts his Knight
on D5 the queen slides back because
under attack as the bishop to d8 and he
plays Knight F5 getting two pieces for
the queen but with a dominating
positional Advantage he went out to win
this nice game and just a great
demonstration of his excellent and deep
opening
preparation a new opening for your wall
is here capture new major pieces on
unique metal posters from displate now
with the official collection from
chess.com Mount them in seconds with a
tool-free magnet kit and swap them
whenever you like make your move get an
exclusive discount on all metal posters
shop now with the code Chess at
displate.com
[Music]
to
when we were last here two matches we're
getting set to begin in the survival
stage now both are over and one more
player is going home Danny wrench
alongside KY and the legendary Gotham
chess Levy Rosman guys I don't know
where to quite go from here Levy I'm
going to throw to you first the two
players one player's moving on to the
semis one player's going home your
thoughts back from the dead yep AAR
Nakamura that was crazy y he played the
same opening that is supposed to be bad
for a third time he got an insane
position there was a ridiculous Rook
sacrifice that could have won him the
match outright that slipped up we were
sitting there outside counting and doing
fractions he's got how much time to make
28 moves and he just held it together
and he did did it guys your guy your guy
KY My Guy Look hey okay you know fifth
times a charm you know what I'm saying
that's what they say you know what I'm
saying fifth times a charm is what they
say in the books right ain't it the
fifth time right I I didn't know what we
were going to see he took black
obviously Levy and I broke it down when
we saw it we were wondering but also a
man of his principal stuck with black
cuz he believes it's the right strategy
and uh it paid off he did agree to
withdraw as you saw on camera there and
that draw as black eliminated Maxim Vash
lra from the 2023 Champions chess tour
that that means that with Carana beating
Abdus turov which was also a thriller
also an Armageddon but didn't quite have
the stakes of a player literally
fighting to stay here we focused big
time on nakamura's match with Vash the
gravin so now he moves on he's playing
Abdus chura you've got a younger player
super confident he beat Hikaru in the
round robin stage but now this is as
Robert said an angrier a hungrier hiar
Nakamura that maybe we've seen all week
here who do you got in this one and give
us a little flavor in terms of what you
think both players are thinking I I mean
I'm not I'm not going to sit here and
and and say who I got like obviously
they're they're on different planets at
the moment we have hikaro winning two
matches today none more important than
the one that he just won whereas noer
backck obviously had the setback but he
has the safety net of playing a second
match that's a weird situation to be in
knowing you're playing to qualify but if
you don't ah it's all right just try
again I think noer backck is going to be
able to uh clean the Slate start with a
with a fresh one but I I mean this is
about to be this is crazy what we're
about to see correct that's correct I
mean car coming back from the dead there
I have my my new you know thank you
thank you thank you I'm new like I feel
good I got a new set of games yeah I'm
feeling better if I'm me CaRu bro I'm
GNA go with him like you know he should
be feeling better he he just won an
armag match something he lost to Maxine
BOS lrav in the Run Robin stage of
somehow you're just getting here and
after he won said match he caught up
with Kaa and uh here's how that
interview went
down I have to say he's on fire today
hiar Nakamura still in the CCT finals
and how are you right now hiar after
that incredible game yeah I mean it's uh
nice that finally one of the Armageddon
goes my way um I mean I think I was much
better out of the opening I was very
surprised that Maxim chose to play the
same line um and you know the the
hardest part for me is that I knew I had
a good position and then like not
panicking and very specifically there
was a moment after Queen A5 B4 that I
very very nearly lost my mind and could
have gone to O and5 um and I kept it
together but there was also a moment
later where as soon as I made a move I
realized there was a win in-one move I
think it was work takes D3 if I remember
correctly um and so I was just trying to
keep together and I think I made a lot
of good practical decisions um even
though I was way down on the clock and
um yeah at least one of them went my way
so first what was your reaction when you
saw the opening from Maxim here yeah I
mean armageddon's almost always come
down to the opening if you get an
opening with a black piece where you can
play a lot of quick moves generally
that's to your advantage as opposed to
having to think at the start because you
have a lot less time so I was surprised
I was very happy to see it because I
knew that the position was pretty easy
for me to play the good thing is I just
try to develop try to attack and I don't
have a whole lot of plans um it still
got very complicated somewhere in the
middle but you know it's yeah you win
some you lose some and if I had to lose
the other four to win this one I I'll
take that order definitely and to win
this match now to still be in the
tournament to to go through to the
losers fine what does that mean to you
yeah I mean it doesn't mean a whole lot
like I said my goal was to make the top
six and that's all that I was hoping for
so it's it's nice but I guess I have to
play another match um and I'll try to
play decent rapid I mean I think
actually if you look at the scores in
the rapid I have the the best score
alongside Magnus so if you get rid of
all those armagedon disasters it would
look like a pretty decent event so I
feel pretty good and we'll see how it
goes in the next match and the fact that
um to stay in the tournament we have
armagedon here it's been uh some
fantastically entertaining days what do
you think about the format here in the
finals yeah I mean I I don't like the
format I think uh having two rapid games
is fine but there should probably be two
Blitz Games before you have an
Armageddon game I mean I think it's a
it's a bit much to go straight and then
also I think the scoring system is
questionable if they did it like Norway
has I think it would make more more sun
so I'm not a big fan but it is what it
is it is what it is and I do see the
other game has finished here as well so
you will
play nordbeck yeah oh he's leaving well
it's going to be nordbeck against hiar
Nakamura to survive in the tournament
back to you
guys I don't think hikaro knew that she
meant she wanted to ask him looks like
he was like all right I'm going to go
get ready and get Focus he's here as a
player he's not here he doesn't have to
comment on the conclusion or beginning
or middle of other games I will say that
was an interesting mindset he has that
he looks at his overall play in the
rapid feels pretty good just hasn't
played well in the Armageddon which I
think is a good place to saying I've
been saying that all day right I've been
saying if you look at his performance in
the rapid he's actually gaining F rapid
points yeah for his overall rating he's
just losing a lot of the Armageddon
right so maybe he has a point but we're
working on it you know like I feel like
we're all we're all in this together I
completely disagree with him I think the
format's amaz and and I'll say it right
I I don't agree and I think theat great
there but it it is interesting that
again the the arm the armagedon again is
uh is where a lot of the matches are
decided right especially because it is
only two games and you don't have Blitz
but you know again we don't want matches
to go on forever and ever and uh you
know I think we're getting some of the
most entertaining content we've ever had
in an event so that's what I would say
yeah and chess is the only place you can
Tire opponent and score but lose there
you go and a half one and a which is why
Armageddon exists right that's right Dan
your thoughts on the stats that came out
of this one I mean it's great it look at
87% not 90 you know but okay we feel
good okay so none of that matters
literally none of that matters like none
of never stop putting that up like what
matters is that this man is back and he
better get Magnus a good Christmas
present that's all like it's not over
yet but we're we're about to have the
dream final we're about to have the top
three it's not over yet we are on the
verge of either having Nock breaking up
a final of Magnus of Fabiano and Wesley
so or we're gonna get Hikaru top three
in the world in classical and the best
chess player of all time when it's in
Toronto so both look pretty good to me
yeah it looks pretty good I mean I like
you got the streamers in there you know
you got Magnus a little streamer you got
Hikaru streamer battle we got Levy here
we got Danny and we have maybe Wesley so
or nordback who's fighting and actually
norback being as strong as he is is
going to try to make it to the finals so
we'll see what happens Champions chess
to a reject finale right here you you
said it right you said that Magnus might
come to regret saving mag saving hikaro
from the fire Harry Potter Maloy St
we'll see hikaro is one match away from
joining the semi-finals but of course
Notre Beck has a lot to say about that
we're going to talk to the guy who beat
him and that's Fabiano Carana he's with
Kaa right now here with Fabiano Karana
ready for semi-finals congrats thanks
yeah I keep playing Armageddon I don't I
don't think it's going to be good for my
health to play so many Armageddon but
it's going yeah Armageddon are going
well definitely you're becoming an an
expert what's the secret to be honest I
don't know I think I was out of control
in this game like my position was
probably very dangerous
uh maybe very bad but also maybe very
good at some point but it was completely
out of control uh but then at some point
it got very tricky for him because he
couldn't kind of cover queen queen G1
Checkmate and then I realized like I
have quite a bit of time and it's
getting close on time and he has to make
the difficult move so I was already
feeling like I have a good chance now I
have to say like watching this um as a
spectator even this drama going down to
Armageddon to decide you going through
the semi-finals deciding who's knocked
out what do you think of about the
format here well you know when I if I
had lost maybe I would have felt a bit
worse about the format but when you're
winning then you feel very good and I'm
sure that all these Armageddon are quite
exciting for the spectators uh and we're
still going to have another very close
match okay hearu is still in it uh like
today really seems to be his day so far
I
mean at some point I thought he has no
chance because alza won Hikaru was in
trouble against uh against Dennis and
but yeah he's he's very tenacious he's
still sticking in there so it's going to
be another tough match for both of them
and uh you've uh revealed to us you have
been a little sick the last few days
feeling a little better definitely now
playing semi-finals how do you see your
chances now in the rest of the finals
well I'm just happy to be there and it's
going to be a bit of a slower Pace now I
guess compared to okay today especially
a lot of really high tension and okay
it's still going to be high tension but
uh still we're going to slow down a
little bit and I'll see who I play I I
again I don't know Wesley or or Magnus
um I'm I'm curious about Wesley's
mindset because uh well recently he
struggled against me so maybe he'll feel
like he doesn't want to play me but on
the other hand I don't know uh it
depends also on who else is there right
if it's Hikaru or Notre Beck because
maybe Wy will would also feel that
Hikaru is a very tough challenge so uh
in any case I'm happy to play whoever I
do play and we'll see what happens yeah
I mean it's you did end third in the
round robin it definitely isn't unlikely
that Wesley will not pick you as his
opener meaning you will play Magnus
Carlson so if that happens what will
that be like yeah I do have a feeling
that probably I will play Magnus it's
not like 100% of course but uh well we
played each other quite quite a lot uh
I'm looking to get some Revenge because
here he beat us in our in our mini match
in the preliminary stage so I'm looking
to get some revenge for that revenge is
the word Bobby congratulations on being
in semifinals thank you thank you for
joining us and back to you
guys he Wants Revenge 100% one thing I
like about fabbi is uh how calm he is no
matter what like he's out there hanging
out even if he loses draw Win whatever's
going on he's just very good I think we
can learn a lot from that just being you
know stoic and calm and being focused on
uh the task of him I agree yeah Fabiano
is really he's really interesting
because maybe his biggest weakness like
if you have to pick a weakness about
Fabiano is putting him in a situation
where he's up one- nothing in a two-
game match like he almost doesn't know
what to like he he he almost doesn't
know what to do does he play for win
this he play for a draw but he is so
good at bouncing back from a defeat yeah
it's incredible I knew he just lost this
game to to norback and norback got his
desired color and I still was like I
don't think Fab's going to lose the same
way that he did and he did and he was
just super stable that game I felt the
same way he's and Fabby definitely
defines that short-term memory loss of
the great players right they believe in
themselves enough that they're not
they're not as worried as we are as
commentators about momentum right he's
focused in the moment but all right
speaking of momentum who has more going
into this matchup the guy who already
had time to have some bad chess now he
has time to collect himself or the guy
who's been on his last leg for a whole
lot of games now in Hikaru of course
it's hikaro right it's got to be hikaro
uh he's got it's it's it's yeah it's
momentum it's experience like it's been
here he's been here before and I think
it was really just like flipping a coin
four times and getting four heads that's
why he lost four Armageddon flipping a
coin and flipping a switch in a way too
is that he's turned on now he's ready it
feels like that machine machine is now W
Oil but and he's ready to go Fabby
looking the same though I want to remind
everybody too as you look at abdur of
Nakamura coming up the reason Fabio
Carana has not been slotted over in the
semi-finals is because the other really
interesting thing about the format and
it will be content toward the end is
that regardless of who wins between
abaturov and Nakamura Wesley so will get
to choose his opponent between the two
remaining players which that by itself
will be fascinating to break down cuz
he's going to have to sort of pick pick
his enemy right which definitely
what do they call that's bul boardi
right there you Pi your enemy and you
got throw against question if Hikaru
wins this match right now you think
Wesley is going to pick him or Fabiano
that's scary I I actually will make it
even different prediction I think
regardless of who wins between Abdus
turov and Nakamura I think Wesley picks
Fabiano I think he thinks he has the
rapid Edge in that one believe we'll see
that's nice even though he he just lost
he still thinks overall yeah I think so
cuz today today was a weird
I said Wesley didn't have the same
motivation yeah all right well we're
going to we're going to uh we're going
to continue to talk about this stuff
it's going to be a long day we got more
chests ahead we got picks in terms of
someone choosing their enemy but we're
going to take a breath little change of
pace here we already showed you that we
got up to some white elephant with the
players before the event got kicked off
we also had a uh we had a food tasting
kind of competition thingy I don't even
know how to describe it so I'm going to
let the the video do the talking it's
got poutin poutin and I'm here with omed
the general manager first of all what a
fantastic beautiful space you have here
in the warm kitchen yeah I mean thank
you so much it's a it's a pleasure to
have you all the way we design this
restaurant is focused on Greenery
sustainability zero waste local products
that's what we love to do here that's
what our kitchen does here and we're
here to do a poutine competition a
traditional Canadian dish what is
poutine so poutine essentially it's
three simple ingredients it's a good
french fry nice and crispy soft on the
inside yum good cheese curd you want a
little bit of squeakiness but also
meltin and then a good gravy James
what's going to be your tactics here in
the poutine comp me look I'm I'm I'm
really concerned about the young lady
over here okay the one that really knows
how to cook so I'm I'm concerned yeah
she doesn't she doesn't let me anywhere
near her
kitchen if if I even hold the pen she'll
say let that go right now but
fortunately we're not near her kitchen
today so take FR you want them crispy so
so at least to redeem my French you know
from my frenchness you need the duck I
need the duck so with the duck you
always get caramelized onions in ches
would be a favorite but I per personal
preference for spring onions you sound
like an expert Mar I have to say not
really here I'm not to be the expert but
I'll go for spicy mayo and here I really
don't know I really don't know what it's
going to look like okay let's say this
is my version of a ptin cheese free I'm
up next okay I'm in the kitchen every
day this what we do this is nothing so
we going to start with the crispy ones
you need to get you a nice little
handful we going to go with the cheese
curds of course Mah we going to put some
cheese in here like this got the meat a
little bit more meat perfect got to get
your protein we're going to have here
some carbonized onions green onions very
nice get you a little assortment of
veggies all right I think we got some
chives here right just some jalapenos oh
jalapenos yeah we don't want that some
ches just down here if you want this is
good throw that on there and then for
the sauce you know you got to have a
little Spice in life right so man just
smells amazing put some in there put a
little bit over there put a little bit
there maybe a little bit in the middle
too as well look at that that boy slaps
my goodness look at that you know Ka
already H look at that one or two
calories you know what I mean exquisite
exquisite keep being classy exqu it's a
classic and that's it w and we done good
perfect nice job so I've never seen this
fries on a ptin so I'm stick to the
thick cut little bit there a little bit
here and I'm going to stick with the
chizo okay okay I guess I'll come back
to the sauce I learned something from KY
come on there it is Chef KY that is
thank you very much Chef KY thank you
appreciate it some of these green CH
green chib the beef gravy beef gravy not
too much though yeah there and and I'm
done I don't really want to add anymore
of that stuff all right why are you
going with those Lo um they're crisp
looking and they have a sweetness to
them I'm going take a little bit of the
cheddar um some duck yes a little bit of
the
beef just drizzled and then I I like to
put the vegetables on top of something
like gravy cuz it gives some color wow I
don't know how nobody got this one this
is the best it's crispy onions yeah we
do that show you how it's
done all right it's time to decide who's
the winner of the poutine competition
you ready to do some tasting I'm excited
yeah all
right I am just missing the cheese but
that is
tasty
nice Definitely interesting interesting
nice okay thank can we fix ours before
you
get that's my favorite so far
oh you you should be allowed in the
kitchen
the sweet potatoes are adding a nice
crunchiness which is what you were
trying to do right right now it's
between these two okay okay the family
the family the learn from watching
me ta will be the pie breaker oo so none
of these are traditional but I think oh
yeah you have some really awesome twists
on a classic
poutin this had more taste to me mhm I'm
actually going to go for Wes
[Music]
y I think I think we both go with West
yeah I'll never forget
this you always have to give me
interviews
now that was it for the cooking
competition in the CCT finals Omid thank
you for having us here at one kitchen
and uh for being the awesome judge of
course it was a pleasure to have you I
look forward to welcoming you at any
time any year any day and please West
continue to make poutines and I look
forward to trying yours the next time
thank you and everyone else of course
but Wes is
delicious Wesley so the poutine winner
are you bummed about that oh I'm defin
you know what's funny Wesley was like
hey man after the competition you know
can you just uh if you have any openings
back there I would love to be part of it
and I was like this man got a job at
freaking at the kitchen like cuz
apparently he needs to do something
besides chess I mean doesn't seem like
doesn't seem like Wesley is searching
for work but all right we got more work
to do here games are starting in a few I
think why don't we just open it up and
chat with some Oslo sweet yeah let's do
it let's do it the big low Oslo how you
doing Tanya you there we're here and I'm
just so hungry after seeing uh that
amazing food James what was that and
even the chef said that it's interesting
and you know that interesting is not a
compliment these days okay Hey listen
okay it was good it didn't may not has
looked as good it did look like some
slop I did say that was okay this
probably terrible but the taste was
amazing and we did taste all of them and
Wesley definitely slapped pretty hard
yeah all right well we got chess to go
to go into here I don't even know where
to begin with Notre Beck Nakamura but
Robert I want to I want to throw to you
we've we've we've kind of seen this dog
and pony dance for years right with
Hikaru in regards to the comeback and
and what he's capable of but what are
your thoughts heading in here with Notre
Beck and what do what does his mindset
need to be right now facing the Beast
known as
Nakamura well as David said while we
were watching that video it's cooking
over everything and right now hiar is
cooking finally he's found his form he's
won a couple matches today but narbeck
is somebody who's not afraid of anybody
that's the good news for narbeck fans he
might have lost he may have suffered but
he always gives it his all so I think
that Hikaru right now should be the
favorite he's finding his form at the
right moment and nordbeck well he just
needs to get over quickly easier said
than done do you think we're writing
Abdu stov off too quickly though he did
take down Nakamura in an Armageddon
earlier in the event he's a world former
World rapid Champion he's capable he's
young he's full of energy it's a long
Marathon day today we're feeling it here
in the studio and he's the youngster
he's got the stamina I agree with you I
mean this is going to be such a close
match but if I had to pick one I don't
think that NC has a great chance he's
been consistent throughout the event
he's had pretty much good days every day
yes Hikaru is finding his momentum today
but I think we can't ride off nbec and
I'm going to pick not what about you
guys have you made your predictions yet
on this
one h take Dan who you think I got who
you who you think I got I mean I'm going
to you I got starts with an end and and
then exactly Nakamura I'm pretty sure
you're picking Hikaru in this one 100%
Levy again I know you said you didn't
want to give a prediction but what are
your thoughts hearing David and and
Robert break it down yeah what the hell
is a dog and pony dance a dog and Pon
how did no one pick up is nobody
listening to each other on this podcast
Google what that is a dog and pony show
you want me to you want me to reenact it
yeah I don't even can't you get get no
I don't know what it is it's a it's a
thing that I guess I would say like is
like a cheap ticket it's like going to a
circus it's like you've seen this before
we we that's kind of the metaphor I may
have invented that I don't know I feel
like I heard it from someone some no one
even pick up like does everybody know
what that is or does nobody listen to
each other Rob hasn't been listening to
me for years a thumbs up from over here
you're right that's exactly what it is
is related to traveling circuses so
don't listen to them Denny you got this
oh my God Robert that is like I miss you
I love you I miss thank you for doing
that I love you Tanya David have you
heard of a dog and pony dance I have no
idea you got to break this down for the
rest of us what is that dog and pony
show it's a common expression so related
traveling circuses Danny probably was in
one himself so he knows what it is that
makes sense now wow that's all right all
right well we uh I I wasn't in one
although you know you did grab there is
a complicated life story there yeah you
talked about this 202
one that's true that's true and and I
don't really have much else to say I
know that we're we're all anxious to see
what's going to happen here with the
chess so I'm ready to I'm ready to go
have more snacks and sit next to the
Magnus pillow and let them take it away
guys I know it's hard to pick a favorite
in this one but before you go just a
prediction are we getting an
Armageddon uh no I think hiar wins in
regulation James wow I'm with that no
I'm going on again I'm riding with my
guy I'm riding with my guy real hard
Flex you know at home yeah yeah no no
Armageddon why not six
Armageddon there he is he just sat in
we're ready to go we're going to throw
it to Oslo take it away crew we'll see
you on the other side see you guys wow
Hikaru Nakamura is ready to go uh will
this match go down to the wire or not it
is against nbec nbec who's been having
consistent days here he started slow but
then from day two we saw him win so many
of his matches and he did beat Hikaru
Nakamura in the round draw in for Hikaru
he survived elimination he won that
match then he goes on to play Maxim he
loses the first game he wins then he
wins the armagen how is he feeling about
his chances right now it's been a roller
coaster but today's been all up and so
for Hikari Nakamura who's seated in his
chair he gets the black pieces narbeck
you know sometimes he brings the fight a
little bit too much and over presses but
I'm with everybody he has legit chances
nck he was the world rapid Champion
something that even Hikaru hasn't been
able to accomplish in his illustrious
career yeah imagine Hikaru lying in bed
last night just envisioning uh kind of
manifesting what could have happened
today he might have thought one game I'm
out if uh Magnus loses no chance but
somehow what is it five six hours later
he's still fighting still plugging away
we see the handshake and I mean it's
just too good of a story this fairy tale
can it continue it looked so unlikely at
the beginning of the day yeah that is
the big question right now NC is ready
to go as well and whoever wins whoever
is the fourth player who makes it to
semi-finals I'm not envy of Wesley so
who will have to choose an opponent for
himself in the semis and it's going to
be quite interesting to see that but
that's for later right now it's going to
be about these two players on our screen
as we are about to kick off the chess
and it is uh go time between these two
opening approaches and there we have
handshakes King spawn opening Queen
spawn opening he starts with one E4
Hikaru immediately with E5 is it going
to be another Petro it is and it's the
it is the pet I say the scotch it is the
pet and not the same variation that we
were uh discussing in that Clash that
crazy game between Vash gra and Nakamura
earlier today and nbec Abdus instead
chooses a much more theoretical much
more popular variation where we see some
early exchanges incoming uh what will
black do here a lot of pressure in the
center all of those nights they'll soon
disappear from the board it's a pawn
Sacrifice from nck at the start here
because his Knight onc3 is attacked by
two pieces and he decided just to Castle
it's an ambitious line from the white
side but at least what I appreciate from
NB is that he's not going down the same
line that Magnus and MV did against
aakar and well AAR is going down the
line where he grabs a pawn but white
gets very quick activity yeah this is
brave from hikaro Nakamura greed is it
good here he touches he adjusts his
Bishop we heard him say something there
so he's not obliged to move that piece
Black's King though in big trouble
whether or not it castles there is an
attack Brewing I'm loving uh the opening
outcome that we have right now but I'm
see seeing these two players on our
screen and I'm feeling a bit sad because
one of them will be eliminated and uh
whether it's Hikaru or nbec you got a
feel for that you're feeling sad I'm
feeling a bit nostalgic for Vish Anan
because this actually reminds me a game
he played against Wanga back in the 2019
Grand Swiss a very important event where
Wong how he won it he was able to play
in the candidates after that and if
black castles kingside which Hikaru he's
deliberating right now is he's going to
do it and then there's going to be a
bishop sacrifice we will get even
material but with Bishops of opposite
color very interesting very interesting
David goone sorry we'll break that down
I was going to say in a moment if and
when it happens it does happen we'll see
it on the board Bishop sacrifice Greek
gift kind of interesting spin on it it's
a simply a double attack white wins back
the material so level material now
opposite color Bishops guess he was
sitting next to that game Robert in 2019
in the aisle of man I had a closeup view
of that and it went downhill very
quickly actually for Anand out of the
blue and this is a key move it looks
like a simple Pawn push but nakamura's
intention is to actually activate that
black rook in the corner from A8 down
the board to A6 and to swing it across
the sixth rank a ve very important uh
defensive maneuver there do you even
Rook lift and the answer from Hikaru is
yes apparently so Rook A6 is the idea
that you're pointing at what what are
the Dynamics in this position what are
the different plans for both white and
black break it down for us well white
has a four on two majority on the king
side so when we talk about material
sometimes especially when we're playing
online we see oh same pieces have been
captured but we have different Bishops
Bishops opposite color and we have four
pawns for white to two for black from
the e through the H file and then black
has four on two from the a through D
file so we're not playing on the same
side of the board white would love to
Barrel that F Pawn all the way up but
black is going to stop that on the light
squares thanks to the presence of that
light Square Bishop so white is going
for an attack that move A5 is to give
that Rook some space we often think to
develop our Rook we need to move our
Bishop move our Queen connect our Rooks
but no The Rook is going to lift and
then bch on over to the king side yeah
Rook lifts I find them the hardest thing
in chess when to activate the Rook uh
often we go horizontally but yeah
lifting them up the board across it's
kind of a cheat code it's like a a
Sprint for those Rooks and that's
incoming Abdu satov the fact that he
chose this opening he chose this
variation at least against the Petro and
now he pauses in what is still a
well-known position uh alarm Bells would
have been ringing for me but he does
after a little bit of thought uh choose
to activate his Rook sliding across
putting pressure on black Central Pawn
pinning that pawn he has elicited a
frown from Nakamura as well face number
no I'm not going to guess and uh
Nakamura now I'm expecting him to
continue consistently with the plan he
initiated on the last turn activate that
black rook in the corner Black's Bishop
on light squares Still Remains flexible
maybe nck has a sneaky idea against this
plan that you mentioned at The Rook lift
and sliding over to the king side that
if Hikaru was to indeed go with that
move Rook to A6 maybe white slides up
with his own Rook doubling down on that
Central D5 Pawn David with Rook to B5
which would force and we can visualize
this which would force Black's uh C Pawn
to move forward so really disconnecting
the queenside Rook the black queenside
Rook to be able to come all the way to
the king side so is this a little bit of
a prophylactic move by nbec it is he
spent a little bit of time and he
realized that he can try to push Black's
Pawn to the sixth rank to shut it down
from that Rook that Rook on A6 really
wants to teleport on over to the king
side not going to be so easy you might
lose mat
so White's pieces are quite optimally
placed and Black's pieces all of them
are on the starting rank so you could
see that white has the makings of some
kind of aggressive intentions and attack
and Black's pieces are a bit Frozen even
that Bishop can't move very easily
there's a rook on B1 staring down the
length of the file to that pawn back
there this is not an easy decision for
aaru and we're talking about Rook lifts
for black there are potential Rook lifts
for white as well with the Rook from D1
actually moving to the third Rank and
sliding to the king side the other plan
that comes to my mind would be line up
the bishop and and the Queen on the long
diagonal and sacrifice that E Pawn
trying to Target Black's King as well uh
you did mention earlier that Hikaru
should be pleased with this but you know
what I would want to be white here yeah
uh maybe I'm biased having seen that
game in the a of man from a few years
back but Nakamura does go for the plan
we hinted at and I really love your move
Tanya lift the white Rook on the B file
up the board to B5 pressure blacks pawns
and uh at least ask some questions over
there satov he's again pausing great
potential for some kind of mutual
attacks later on end games I'll mention
usually should be pretty safe for black
because White's queenside pawns are
isolated I think uh White need there we
go move on the board nice prediction but
white needs to play energetically here
white needs to keep the Queens on white
needs to play for dynamism uh especially
with these opposite color Bishops and
heavy pieces and we often think about
Pro provocative moves as ones where you
just invite some bad decision here the
move Pawn C7 to C6 I promise you the
engines will approve of it but it does
shut down an idea so it doesn't actually
gain anything towards the evaluation but
it takes away the critical idea that
aaru is relying on with his move A5 Rook
A6 so C6 very natural defending but nck
will slide his own Rook back to the
third rank just like you were saying
Tanya he will try to use that Rook lift
and then when he moves his Queen out the
way the Rook will come over to the king
side we really do have an attack in the
making and look at that move Rook C6
hitting the White Queen yeah he's trying
to make sure that the black Rook doesn't
get hemmed in blocked in on the sixth
rank like you said Pawn to C6 very
healthy maybe the best move according to
the engine but from a human point of
view it blocks your own plans and you're
always reluctant to play ugly moves uh
like that one so okay an attack against
the White Queen uh but this might be a
pawn sacrifice uh depending on where
white moves his Queen this time because
black will find it extremely difficult
now to guard all of his pawns the black
Central Pawn on D5 the black a pawn out
there on the queen side uh one of those
two will most likely drop he's playing
energetically here himself Nakamura and
playing for counterplay this is no more
intuitive chest this is calculation
right because black is inviting white to
first pick up that pawn on A5 the first
threat is clear that you move the queen
Hikaru wants to take the pawn on the
second rank that C2 Pawn will be
captured but there is that Central D5
Pawn hanging after that is Hikaru trying
to get that initiative going we often
talk about it in different color complex
opposite color Bishop it's all about
trying to get to your opponent's king
creating attack will that give Black's
Queen enough time to jump into play
towards White's King yeah the black
queen eventually can jump in and a pawn
sacrifice here isn't the end of the
world because of the presence of
opposite color Bishops and if a rook
lands on C2 you have activity
compensating for a potential Pawn
deficit and these top players they love
doing just that they'd rather be a pawn
down with active pieces then be even
material with passive pieces so Queen D3
says you know what I could have taken
that pawn on A5 a move ago but that
would have allowed a rook to land on C2
and then you can take this Pawn on D5
and go up a pawn you're very happy but
Queen H4 T you you were calling for
Queen activity the A2 Pawn will be loose
the F2 Pawn is hanging there already
ideas that are going to regain black
that material so I really like the
decision from no backck don't grab that
A5 Pawn the D just keep that pressure
the threat is often stronger than the
execution yeah and right now black has a
dilemma you cannot save both so which
one do you try to keep on the board uh
it's actually almost possible to keep
the D Pawn on the board uh unless you
play this move I was going to say Bishop
to E6 but now the B Pawn drops after
satoro has gained material he's a porn
up now end games might be favorable for
him and uh this weakness still on the
board but Queen to H4 is all about
activity Nakamura great instructive play
here he is going active with his pieces
watch out for this black Rook as well
later joining the action and yeah not
easy the C2 Pawn A2 Pawn always weak for
white as well it wasn't so long ago that
Maxim vrab won his first game against
Hikaru Nakamura where he stole a pawn
and he said Hikaru prove it and Hikaru
right now he has activity but if not can
somehow coordinate his pieces well
particularly his dark squore Bishop
which is sitting at home that extra Pawn
can make its presence felt especially
because a Black's Rook Pawn over there
it's stranded it's isolated so you need
to be very careful but for now there's
some Dynamic play here that actually is
in hark Caro's favor hiar Nakamura
literally doesn't care about his pawns
he is going for peace activity right now
that Queen which is on the king side can
even eventually slide over to the queen
side and start targeting White's weak
Bonds on the other side of the board to
me it just looks like uh not just the
position on the board but also the body
language that we're seeing a very
different Hikaru from the one who was
struggling in the round robin to the
kind of results that he's had today this
is super chill mode Hikaru yeah there's
a spring in his step he's rocking back
and forth in the chair I wish I had that
amount of energy right now he's been
playing for four or five hours how does
he find it butth it must be just uh that
momentum of those wins he's been having
today Nakamura and healthy position I
don't know about you guys but I'm a bit
materialistic I really admire players
like Nakamura who can just throw pawns
away and literally not care just uh yeah
it looks like he's holding the balance
just with uh this activity it feels
uncomfortable for me to be down a pawn
like this because I'm always thinking
when will I get that pawn back how can I
attack something whereas hararo is
ignoring all of that he's just putting
his pieces on good squares perhaps now
his Queen will venture on over to the
other side of the board and we see him
grabbing his Queen offering a queen
trade Bishop's the opposite color even
if you're down a pawn which I'm not sure
you will be after the queen trade those
often have draw Tendencies so I think
hiar understands the fundamentals of
this position and he's saying Queen
trade that helps he go towards that half
Point yeah and uh if the White Queen now
takes the black queen on nakamura's
terms then Black's Bishop opens up on
the diagonal hits a white Rook feels
like I mean I can't even count how many
weak pawns each side has right now but
eventually things will level up or even
if they don't black with the opposite
color Bishops should guide the game
towards safety I think this last
decision should be the Clincher he's uh
now left the opening he's equalized and
that is step one when you have black in
any game at the top level when you start
with the black pieces in a mini match
which is a best of two you're going to
get that final white in the game to
equalize without literally without any
trouble out of the opening I mean Hikaru
just made this look very smooth is that
a bit of a psychological Victory
definitely as especially knowing his
opponent Abdu satarov just wants to
fight wants to win wants to attack and
he'll find it frustrating if he's
neutralized this easily um that being
said of course game two will be no
foregone conclusion maybe we shouldn't
assume that this will be a draw even
though that looks most likely right now
uh but yeah it looks like Nakamura
should be the happy of the two players
with the outcome of the early stages of
this Clash but David you you made the
video about Nock and his endgame so he
can probably exit the queen Traer Pawn
up at least for the moment do you see
any chances that he can at least prolong
the game because often times these top
players they're not so upset when their
opponents make a draw they're more upset
when they don't even uh put up a fight
for winning chances so is there a way
for nordbeck to keep some activity some
pressure some chances alive yeah maybe
we have to dive in and try and figure
out how uh he keeps these winning
chances alive and what's going through
his mind as he has a really long think
here at 2 minutes and uh the problem is
the first problem at least is there
there's a threat on two different pawns
firstly this C2 Pawn indirectly def
defended Now by The Black Queen and uh
yeah if the black Rook takes I was going
to say the second Pawn up for grabs is
on E5 and he ignores that threat because
he counterattacks against the black rook
and some calculation to be done here
black has a choice of taking the Queens
off or taking the Rooks off and which
one to go for is the big question um any
choices any instincts here guys I'm
going to let Robert on that but one
thing I want to point out is that you
always have to watch out for Black's
move D Pawn moving forward to D four
because it will hit the Rook on C3 or
whichever piece is on C3 at that moment
and Target that A2 pawn and this is a
trick that white always needs to be
aware it's true because the A2 Pawn if
that one's captured there will be no
more extra material no more advantage
and one more thing I'm going to point
out is it's good that black is down a PA
because there's a Escape Square for that
King there's LT there's no back rank
check me but white on the other end if
we actually do see a queen trade right
now and the D Rook takes back so you
don't drop a pawn we see a trade of
Rooks on the C file not now Rook to be
although Rook B3 that's could still
probably just be a draw if we trade off
the Rooks but the point is that Rook can
just slide to B8 to B1 and there are
back rank issues for white yeah big back
rank issues and you could maybe start
with a move Pawn to D4 for example uh
just to avoid white from blocking and as
you say Rob probably a draw but why
calculate this Pawn to D4 Force the
white Rook away cover the square and
actually this would be a losing blunder
for white already so really tempting
Nakamura is trying to calculate this
because the back rank simply cannot be
guarded this would be winning for black
either you win the white bishop or you
deliver Checkmate due to the lack of
lift the lack of breathing space for the
white king stuck behind its own pawns uh
so I actually really Advocate right now
that forcing line Queen takes Queen and
uh Now Pawn to D4 after a trade of Rooks
as well not coming in yet but Pawn D4
first actually it might be white on the
back foot here trying to make the draw
and how are you fighting this uh D3 I
think I just attack your Pawn because
your Rook is a bit slow as black to get
to the first Rank and I am about to take
your Pawn so I think with the opposite
color Bishops white even if there's some
danger it shouldn't be too bad but I
would maybe start liking Black's chances
there especially when I look at the
Hikaru Nakamura sitting with the black
pieces and the momentum he's had in this
event yeah I really prefer Black's
position Pawn to C5 maybe keep the
winning chances alive Bishop to F5
coming push those pawns and uh White is
passive so Hikaru maybe there's other
ways to do it guiding this game towards
safety he could also of course trade off
the Rooks and he's likely fine there too
but but can he get ambitious Hikaru can
he turn the momentum surprisingly in his
favor despite being down a porn when
Nakamura gets the opportunity he
definitely does get ambitious and this
could be that shot right now that we are
talking about the very direct approach
of takes takes takes take takes push
that pawn to D4 and uh try to get some
advantage in that position Hikaru in the
think tank about a three minute think
right now this is what is going through
his mind are the any other Alternatives
that he could be considering he reaches
out and he goes for The Rook trade first
so the Queens still on the board look at
Hikaru he just continues sacrificing
material yeah porns are overrated open
lines are much uh Stronger currency
these days in this economic climate you
want to open lines for the Rooks if
White's Queen goes and takes that black
C Pawn Black's Rook slides to C8 with
gain of tempo infiltrates and yeah
really really active here who cares
about those pawns Robert I do why I'm
just trying to figure out why white
can't take those Pawns I'm sure n's
doing the same like if I steal the pawn
in front of the queen and then steal the
a pawn after that that actually forces
black to prove that he has everything
calculated under control because I take
on A5 what's your next decision Rook
takes C2 doesn't actually carry a threat
behind it and you actually see the EV
bar starting to creep up in White's
favor you are up two pawns even if I
lose the E5 Pawn I have this outside
pass Pawn to work with and I would now
much prefer White's position as compared
to the earlier ones yeah maybe was
getting carried away I kind of forgot
for a second that the H Pawn had
disappeared I was doing a quick count I
thought oh it's level material again but
NOP White's a porn up and uh it's most
importantly uh this D Pawn is stuck it's
unable to advance white keeps it under
lock and key the D4 square and is
controlled and therefore White's Bishop
Superior to its counterpart so actually
maybe you should call the bluff maybe
you have to call the bluff here and he
doesn't he trusts his opponent Abdu
sattorov and uh he shifts his Rook
instead now black is able to trade
Queens on his terms and look at the pawn
Avalanche here when black takes back
three really strong pawns this could
easily turn in Black's favor have to
sator really needs to pull the reverse
gear pull the break and try to make a
draw
now just well this is getting exciting H
Nakamura with a queen trade but
definitely trying for more in this end
game and we've got Levy in Toronto Levy
do you think Hikaru can make something
out of this
position if there's a player that's
going to be able to make something out
of this position it's probably going to
be hikaro this you can't really ask for
much better he has a position of
stability he doesn't have to have any
sort of chaotic tactical complicated
games and he also doesn't have to have
an end game if you guys remember he lost
I think not one but two end games to
Norbeck and he lost an end game earlier
today Knight versus Bishop this dreaded
Knight versus Bishop so right now it's
opposite colored Bishops it's just about
the safest endgame uh that you can have
guys I want to ask you a fun question
like they just served dinner here in
Toronto and and you know the smell is
like all over how are you guys surviving
it's like almost midnight in Norway how
you guys doing I'm doing all right but
the question isn't really how we're
surviving it's how is Hikaru surviving
and I know you're not the Hikaru face
Whisperer like Danny is but when you
look at him right now it seems like he's
in his streamer mode and I think for a
change he realizes that he controls his
own destiny Levy have you noticed it on
the ground that hikaro seems to be a
different person than he was even
earlier this
morning then earlier this morning
maybe I mean obviously he's a bit
happier the day hasn't gotone much
better than it could have uh defeating
lvic having Magnus take down fua and
then watching that transpire uh and then
obviously winning the fifth and sixth
place match uh and now he's in this
final game I think if he stabilizes the
confidence is going to Skyrocket because
he actually was very close to beating
noer Beck in the head-to-head it was
probably the most dominant match hikaro
had he won the first game if we remember
and then the second game he was
completely like okay he wasn't
completely winning but he was much
better we see the players trading a lot
of pieces I think this one's over pretty
soon what do you guys think yeah it
looks that way with the aons traded off
that we might be seeing a draw in this
one and do you think that does affect uh
a player psychologically in a best of
two you've got only one white and we
were discussing this in the studio and I
want to get your take on this that
drawing so comfortably with the black
pieces does that send a message to your
opponent for sure and I I think it's a
lot easier to sit here and say oh just
get over the previous match or oh the
previous match doesn't the momentum is
overstated or something along those
lines I I think there is definitely
something to be said for the fact that
noer just had this crazy match versus
Fabiano which ultimately didn't go his
way in Armageddon and hikaru's back from
the dead winning two matches today so if
nobec can't get anything with white when
he just blew Fabby off the board in
their first rapid game not the
Armageddon but at least in the first
rapid game um I think it's I think it
sends a huge message but they do still
have to play another game and opening
predictions what do we think is going to
be the opening that Karo chooses when he
gets white in the
second that's a big one what opening
would the car we go with Smith Mora
Gambit maybe just learning from
experience it's worked well for him
today that's true something Mimi that's
my uh prediction Levy I think I remember
someone else saying that about Hikaru
was it Magnus who said that Hikaru might
play some more Mimi openings well lby
thanks so much much and we'll check in
with you later right now we see that um
Black's Rook has been attacked C3 and it
feels like it's actually the first time
that hikaru's slowed down the last few
moves were blitzed out still down upon
bit opposite color Bishops how close is
this to a draw it feels very close I
think we're all talking now as if it's a
foregone conclusion that this should be
a draw and yes objectively it should but
Nakamura can try a few things he'll
create the first pass Pawn the one thing
Nakamura has to watch out for as well is
that he doesn't want to get a situation
where black creates a pass Pawn it's
easily blocked and White's able to start
pushing forward his own pawns white
still has the four versus to majority on
the right half the king side of the
board so if Rooks remain that could be a
bit of an issue later on so Nakamura
he's maybe just working out now which
Pawn to push later on first get his Rook
out the way whether he can get away with
trading Rooks whether that get guides
him towards safety once he's decided
upon that I think we'll see him Blitz
out a flurry of moves and uh he should
be relatively safe well the one thing I
think that he has to watch out for is
that whites pawns don't Avalanche up the
board because uh you have four pawns for
White and the E through the H file and
we know that white is up one Pawn but
it's kind of like you're up two pawns on
one side of the board and down one Pawn
in the middle so I think for ner Beck
look at him he has got his head in his
hands he's not just saying okay whatever
it's a draw let's go into game two he's
really trying to work see what chances
do I have here can I push my kingside
pawns the F Pawn H3 followed by G4
let's eens I was actually going to bring
up this move this Rook E4 which actually
forces The Rook trades in a way that
white doesn't have that four versus two
majority that David was earlier pointing
out black can also push that C5 Pawn all
the way to C4 just putting everything on
the light squ and it just feels like an
easier hole this way yeah I'm
disappointed uh by this decision because
I wanted to see a full fight even in the
end game even though it should
eventually be a draw but I think it's a
good practical decision from makaru
cynical just trade off and uh it's a
position he knows how to manage here
yeah no Prospect of pass pawns for Abdu
satoro or not sufficient pass pawns you
need often two of them either connected
or far separated uh in opposite color
bbang games and look at this full
blockade on the light squares black king
coming should be a draw I say should
because I'm never 100% sure but uh yeah
I trust taru here and I feel like when I
play positions just like this somehow
that white king ends up on D4 hitting
both of my pawns at once and I can't
protect them because they don't have a
pawn push to protect it so hiard does
need to be a bit careful here because
the next few moves from norback might be
king F1 King E2 try to get the king up
to E3 and so I think that Hikaru I mean
he knows that he's within that drawing
territory both players probably do but
he needs to be careful and he needs to
be accurate not to allow the white king
to too quickly run to the center the
defensive setup for Black would be like
you said your Bishop can't be on D5 that
Central Square when the king lands on D4
my dream is to get my Bishop on D3 so
that when there it's more active
defending the two pawns and try to keep
it together from there is that something
that Hikaru can start thinking about
it's a long maneuver but if you have
time go D7 go to the queen side on A4 C2
and D3 it's definitely possible uh
that's a great defensive post for the
bishop that being said it would not keep
an eye on the king side so I don't know
if white can create a past H Pawn that's
where white has uh an advantage right
now push the G Pawn push the HB create
one there then use the white king I
don't know where you come around you
come around the whole board act as a
distraction black hle just kind of wait
wait wait I don't think there'll be a
breakthrough but you have to be 100%
sure actually the more I look at it the
more this Rook trade decision uh it's
got more risk attached than uh
previously thought and it is an
opportunity for nir to push a little bit
but maybe Hikaru has worked it out I
mean at some point he consider trading
even more pieces it is an opposite color
Bishop ending a pawn push up to F6 at
some moment could be in the cards but
you have to be very careful as we've all
been talking about is where to place
that Bishop for whoa here comes the
white king and so he can push he's
giving up the E5 Pawn but this is a
clever try from nir if that black king
takes the pawn the bishop delivers a
check and wins the G7 Pawn then we have
outside pass Pawn for white so do not go
and take that E5 Pawn I think that gives
white some chances really really clever
here and Nakamura he was reaching for a
pawn there will it be the F Pawn G Pawn
he's calculating he's trying to work
something out and uh he's still got a
bunch of time he just drops his Bishop
back maintaining uh the current position
he thinks he's got the ideal defensive
setup it is slightly unclear what white
is doing next and uh if white ever
throws the G Pawn forward maybe then you
can take a pawn and some complications
but you might be able to force even more
pawns off the board okay we're going to
find out this is a check doesn't even
pause he just immediately takes it and
Hikaru is looking for the king to move
forward but n back before giving a check
he takes away the key F4 Square from
black king and is this something that
Hikaru missed he did miss it what an
unexpected Choice when someone gives up
a pawn and can win one right back you
expect him to do that but nck understood
that position was probably actually
quite an easy draw for hikaro King
activity when in the end game you use
your King as a weapon instead of having
to sit in the corner and defend it now
that King is helpful and black pushes
that g Pawn one square forward maybe all
pawns on light Square sounds good a dark
Square Bishop can attack it then white
will just start pushing the H Pawn at
some moment not going to be easy to stop
wow the evaluation bar might say 0.0
might say it's just a draw but this is a
beautiful move this this is a spanner in
the works Hikaru no chance he spotted
this I don't think any of us spotted
this this was really ingenious from Abdu
satoro big practical problems it's all
about White's H Pawn watch out for it to
become a future Queen it's got a clear
path forward some checks threatened as
well I actually think hikarin might be
panicking internally here uh he's
keeping a poker face but this is not
easy anymore I love that last move it's
quite the yaka in the position because
black is expecting white to give a check
and grab the G7 PA
but not back doesn't go with that he
stops Black's counter play first and
such an instructive moment as well and
look at Hikaru he can suddenly feel the
pressure we've got the evalar saying
everything's under control but it really
doesn't matter because you're thinking
about that H Pawn which is going to
start queening once you push the G7 Pawn
to G6 which will be forced after Bishop
to D4 no matter the result of this game
hikaro is going to be like that King G5
move that was sick that shows the talent
of Noir beaar just when we all you
probably even hikaro was writing the
game off as a draw suddenly there are
chances here and really if you push that
gwn an outside pass Pawn will happen in
just two moves it's going to be very
difficult to stop because Black's King
we like a centralized King you and King
of the Hill good for you this is chess
and the white king is actually helping
escort a pass Pawn up the board I'm
worried for hikaro right now suddenly
the margin for era is Tiny he needs to
be super accurate Hikaru to hold the
balance and his clock is ticking Down
Under 2 minutes it's the most simplified
of positions it's opposite color Bishops
it looks so drawn superficially until
you get deeper and you heard the exhale
there his breath is quickening his heart
is beating he knows he is in trouble in
Practical terms it's not easy to defend
at all that was the first time Hikaru
with his head Shake in this game he's
been bobbing he's been looking chill and
confident but suddenly things have
changed the Dynamics have changed and it
all comes down to this one move that
white just made King to G5 so easy to
miss and you made that series on nbe's
end game and I think these are those
moments that point that out yeah
simplified position but he spots
everything he knows what uh makes the
opponent most uncomfortable and look at
this Hikaru he's down to 1 minute oh my
God he's panicking he's biting his hand
and right now he can't bite his time
because we see the obvious plan and for
Hikaru he struggled down in that bullet
time scrambled mode over the board chest
this week so he sees it can go back I
think no keep up the pace right now
Bishop D4 and wow hiar pushes F5 but the
EV bar is going all the way up Hikaru
he's let it slip or has he sometimes
computers aren't to be trusted in these
types of positions but he's simply given
away a pawn for free sooner or later
white will create a past H Pawn anyway
white will trade off one of the double
death pawns for Black's remaining G pawn
and here it comes okay the evaluation
bar drops back
down is Hikaru going to be able to hold
this one really clever move he's coming
round with his Bishop to keep an eye on
the H5 Square just in case the white
king wants to reot itself wow this one
is somewhere between a a win and a draw
for white it's a two result game but how
close are how big are the winning
chances it's Tanya's idea now about to
happen that Bishop is going to C2 and D3
to protect both pawns at the same time
and I think what nck just missed when he
pushed his H Pawn he should have made
this move first because Black's Bishop
would not have been in time to wrap
around this way and hikaru's found it
he's found this defensive setup and
whether he holds it's a different story
but this is the correct plan by him and
now the bishop defends but from a very
active spot you can keep an eye on both
these pawns but had nbec played that
king move before pushing the pawn
Black's Bishop would have been on the
defense from the very inactive C6 Square
oh and another mistake by Hikaru he
gives up the E4 Pawn King to E5 he's two
pawns down now Hikaru he thought it was
zuk Swang he thought any move he made
would have worsened his position but it
was better to keep the Pawn just drop
back with the black king nothing too
much to worry about there instead he's
given ground he's given a second pawn
and white will eventually create two
pass pawns that's right because at the
moment there's zero pass pawns that G7
Pawn deals with both but as ner backck
wraps his King up to G5 pushes F6 he can
force that g Pawn off the board and it's
an f and an H Pawn that he can March
forward unfortunately for Hikaru just
when it looked like he was about to hold
he's slipping all right so let's slow
down here the winning plan for white is
to get two pass spawns then again we see
the evalar drop down it looks like
that's what he wants to do he wants to
play F6 next don't you get the position
that you've been wanting all along with
the move F6 now oo but the bishop might
be able to guard along the diagonal I'm
not sure what he could have done
differently this looks so natural it
looked pretty much winning the only plan
available to white but maybe there was
something else or maybe the evaluation
bar is tricking us being deceptive and
uh Hikaru he's hoping just along the
light squares he'll be able to blockade
perhaps the white king and this is now
only recognized it might have been the
case because the Evo bar went down maybe
the king had to run back towards the
queen side to keep the bishop tied down
that C4 Pawn this was the most logical
plan but Hikaru maybe he's worked out
that this is still holdable because his
King and Bishop they keep both of
White's pawns Frozen and look at this he
set up a blockade along the diagonal
Black's Bishop cuts across some vital
squares and uh both of the white pawns
because they're disconnected need to
bypass those squares but uh wow this is
really classy I think he's got a
fortress now Nakamura and the lean back
he thinks it too he knows he has tricked
abdor potentially and he set up a
drawing uh a drawing position here I
don't know what expression number that
is but the expression definitely says
that he's confident of the Fortress the
hole that he's built and black sking is
shouldering white sking stopping it from
penetrating uh black Camp here King from
D5 takes away the D4 square and if
White's King starts marching along the
dark squares on the king side black king
will follow along on the light squares
towards the king side so taking away key
squares of entry from White hair uh n
back it's also I think uh he's realizing
it as well that it's impossible to break
through now and he's probably frustrated
because he likely believed that he was
winning and it appears for maybe like
one turn he was and that's why the
engine bar can be so misleading where
you think oh it's just an easy win the
the bar is all the way up and the most
logical plan is the one he went for it's
not working out for him he still has a
big lead on the clock but there are no
more tricks up his sleeve no more tricks
and uh yeah he looks just in disbelief
right now it does look I mean all chess
logic dictates that white should be
winning two extra pawns you've done the
hard work but chess can be unfair like
that certain end games especially
opposite color Bishops they have this
drawish tendency you cannot bypass the
light squares you don't have enough
attacking ammunition here and he's
trying to go the long way around but
this will not change anything the black
king will eventually shoulder off the
white king and we'll just see some
maneuvering between the Bishops no
progress to be made as long as Nakamura
doesn't remove his Bishop from this
diagonal and doesn't break his defensive
formation he is pretty much guaranteed a
draw here it's going to go in the end
game books where the opposite color
Bishops means even two extra pawns it
doesn't help you get the job done and
now the black king can just go backwards
even if you were able to push your F
Pawn to F6 you're not making any more
progress from there it's just one of
these things where the presence of
opposite C Bishop gives you drawing
chances despite being significant
material down yeah he drops suspish back
he's done it Nakamura he doesn't need to
I kind of calculate anymore he knows
exactly what he needs to do White's
tried everything pretty much and
evaluation bar should be ignored this is
a draw hiari just shuffling around with
the bishop and he will once start moving
back with the King when White's King
steps up to F4 all that black needs to
do in this position is to make sure that
the white king doesn't cross over the
boundary doesn't go F4 G5 f F6 as long
as you've got these key squares under
control plaque is doing fine and Hikaru
is just blitzing out the defense to
Perfection here we'll have to take a
deeper dive later but it's almost making
me wonder if there was some like Horizon
effect issue with the engine where maybe
hi car's defensive setup it didn't have
the flaw that we initially thought we
will dive more into that later but for
now he is playing Perfect Defense his
Bishop is just going back and forth and
as you said as soon as the white king
starts venturing up towards that Bishop
then the black king will sit back but
that's a draw we've got a draw and that
means Hikaru can be relieved because
Abdu satro really did uh set up quite
the problems for Hikaru in this one
despite an opening where it felt like
Hikaru was neutralized easily amazing
fight there in the end he never gives up
if there's even a sliver of a chance to
play for a win no de ABD star will do
just that and hikara had his back
against the wall he was down to one
minute on the clock yet he still
survived and we see nck walking off as
the players will fight it at in the
second
rapid game which will be coming up David
it started slow and in the end ended
with a draw but nbec had his chances he
certainly had his chances Nakamura uses
up another of his nine lives on this
game to survive with black eventually
getting the desired result it was a draw
but uh yeah it was definitely abdor
putting the pressure on and here we are
in this with nbec Hikaru Nakamura only
one of them will go through to the
semi-finals David what was the key
moment in this round one yeah I'm still
trying to figure out how white could
have won that game this is one of the
hardest end games to analyze I think you
need hours to break it down but I'm
going to try my best and it I just want
to point out this one moment where abdor
put pressure on when it looked like the
game was guaranteed to flow towards a
draw here instead of a bishop check
allowing the black king in allowing
black to perhaps trade off a bunch of
Pawns with a draw Abus found the cunning
move King to G E5 and this did elicit a
blunder a mistake from Nakamura scared
now of a bishop check and of this Pawn
marching forward he decided to give up
material Pawn to F5 and if we fast
forward later the moment the engine
dropped was a important one here white
pushed his Pawn to H5 but actually he
should have crossed the barrier first it
was important to have the King on the
other side for example marching the king
back and into E5 first and if black
continues to wait now we see that white
is able to create a pass pawn and now
King is on the right side sooner or
later you'll push your Pawn to F5 sooner
or later you might even bring the king
across to G5 and both pawns combined
mean that the Fortress is not standing
for black very difficult to analyze this
one very difficult to see in advance but
Abdus sator small missed opportunity
even at this point it still looks like
it almost is a draw for black so for nck
he gave himself chances that's all you
can ask for I don't really think he'll
be disappointed about missing that win
no he did his best he carved something
out of nothing nearly squeezed water
from that stone in the end uh there's
not much you can do against such stoic
defense yeah completely agree with that
I think nck has a lot to be proud of for
creating what he did in that end game
but right now there's no time to be
proud of anything because there will be
another game coming up the Sun is
setting in Toronto and the sun will set
either on nbec or hikaru's path to the
[Music]
semi-finals
sh
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things and then we have B he uh did beat
you in the Grand Final in the most
recent tournament so yeah know not only
um did he beat me he actually beat me in
consecutive matches um it seems that
he's s of regained his confidence which
is really good to see he'll be like top
three tough opponent for sure I really
like Maxi I like his chess he has like
clear weaknesses and strengths but his
strengths are are things that he does
better than anyone else he was my
teammate in European Championship we
cannot really tell each other everything
but we try to be as much as friend as
very Dynamic player very T tactical
tactically sharp and you never get
boring positions against him I I think
he's changes openings and he seems to
have a little bit of momentum behind him
in the last few events so I think he's a
he's sort of a bit of a wild card if he
plays well he's a very dangerous player
if he doesn't it could be a short event
for him but um again I think the form
will matter a
lot
[Music]
w
oh
ches Kate national festival is on from
February 16th to the 19th it's all
happening in Charlotte North Carolina
join chess.com and chess kid for over
theboard tournaments Levy daa and KY
will be there what are you waiting for
use the command Festival in the chat for
all the details and right now we cannot
wait for game two to start between
Hikaru Nakamura and and NC Abdu satov
the first game it's clear it's going to
be a big big fight between these two
players and it will all come down to
what is hikaru's mindset he's got the
final white of the mini match will he go
for more Kaa finds
out here with hikaro Nakamura what's
your reaction after that first game yeah
I mean it was a typical Petro game I
mean I was a little bit worse uh but I I
think I played some pretty standard
moves and we got to this end game which
turned out to be a little bit trickier
than I thought it was when I played
rookie for at the start but I I don't
think the result was ever in doubt I
mean it looked unpleasant I'm down two
pawns but unless the computer shows
something special there was nothing
nothing for white so it's a good good
draw were you stressed on the clock at
all at some point there well I mean the
thing is I assumed the end game was a
draw when I was down the um when I'm
down the what's it two pawns I guess
there that when he has a double F pawns
but the thing is initially I thought I
had a force draw after King G5 with this
um F6 King G6 F5 so I spent a a lot of
time on this and concluded it didn't
work so I went for a different line I
mean maybe maybe it's still still is a
draw with perfect play who knows but uh
I thought what I did made sense then
it's just a matter of knowing the
technique to block off the white king
and it's opposite color Bishop so what
to do so you've had a great day so far
uh what will it be about now in the next
game and how's your confident heading
into that one I mean I think this was
the best game I've played the whole
tournament actually it's the only game
where I think I was under pressure and I
played a complete game so I feel pretty
good um but you know snow to's very
strong obviously and I just have to take
it one move at a time so it's like this
for you now it's just going upwards well
I mean I I didn't expect to be playing
at this point so yeah it's all it's all
good all right thanks for the talk hiar
best of luck in next one thank you all
right hiar Nakamura getting ready for
game two back to you
guys Hikaru says it's the best game he's
played so far David Robert would you
agree with that uh let's hope Hikaru
doesn't check the engine before this
next game uh it's always nice to feel
that you've defended well but yeah
engines make mockery of all of us
uh ultimately he did uh a good job of
Defending and he got the desired result
and a lot of players don't like actually
looking at the engine during a
tournament because they're like if I
have more games to play I don't want to
be distracted about what could have been
it's all about what lies ahead so for
hiar Nakamura what lies ahead is one
more chance to make it to the
semi-finals we can't believe I was
saying that considering how unlikely it
was yet here he is and here he goes and
let's hope not back was not watching
that interview cuz it can be a little
bit of a mind Zone to hear your opponent
see and say that he is getting into the
Zone with his best game so far and this
is where we are we see Wesley s Magnus
Carson already through to the
semi-finals whoever wins this match goes
into the semi-finals joins Wesley Magnus
and uh it will be between nbec Abdu
satro harkar Nakamura and join Fabiano
Carana Fabi Carana who is already in and
it will be between these two one of them
makes it true one will be eliminated so
this match it really comes down to the
next game will it go down to the wi will
it be an Armageddon that will decide the
fourth
semi-finalist Armageddon we all love an
Armageddon but that will extend our
night I don't know David what do you
think I mean it's midnight now here in
Oslo we haven't eaten for S hours it's
been a long day but we want more chess
and uh you know Armageddon I think
Hikaru has a bone to pick in the arm
again against NC so I think it's a very
likely outcome we are going to get more
chest well at least one more rapid game
and we might even get another Armageddon
to end uh the day and uh we spoke to
Hikaru earlier Kaa also caught up with
nbec all right that was game one nbec
how do you feel after that one yeah it
was interesting game um I got an
advantage but um he kind of um survived
there in the end game so yeah feeling
good and looking forward to uh to play
good CH yeah so hearu he struggled in
the tournament but today he's had a good
day so what do you expect from game to
here and uh you know the the results and
what will happen if you know he wins or
you win um you know I I just want to uh
concentrate on playing good chess and uh
yeah um whatever happens I I'm I'm I'm
glad that you know i' I made it
uh to to that point right well
semi-finals is at stake good luck in the
next game thank you for joining us yeah
it is a lot at stake when game two
starts shortly back to you guys
absolutely Ka so much on the line uh in
this match and for Wesley they're going
to be big questions once we get done
with this Wesley finished at Pole
Position after the round robin so he's
going to have the opportunity to pick
his opponent for the semi-finals and
it's going to be between Fabby and the
winner of this match not a happy Choice
yeah this isn't like picking somebody
and kickball in The Recess deck this is
like do you pick Fabby or n Becker
Nakamura they're all tough oh and this
one is going to be a tough game as well
Hikaru Nakamura takes it on with the
white pieces we are expecting the king
spawn opening it is one E4 nck replies
uh back with E5 are we going to see a
Berlin No we see the main line Spanish
one of the main lines of the royal Lopez
opening and Hikaru just defends his Pawn
here we see a slow maneuvering battle
we've seen multiple uh of these openings
especially featuring Abdu satarov he
seems to like the tension with all the
pieces still on the board he played like
this against Maxim Vash grav earlier
today he did get into a bit of a tough
spot but he won that match so he's
probably has fond memories in this line
and he now Strikes Out strikes forward I
should say on the queen side forcing hi
car's Bishop back and now he strikes in
the center with D5 so it's kind of like
a marshall uh but it hasn't really
opened up in the same way yeah and we
see a trade of Pawns and someone made a
bit of a sound there I think it was
Hikaru maybe now just debating which way
to recapture in the center this is odd
because normally automatically the top
players just recapture in the center
with a pawn and they want to establish
some influence on those Central squares
keep space uh keep kind of pieces on the
board if possible but yeah OD moment to
pause I must say hikara Nakamura unless
he's got some magical preparation up his
sleeve that he's just trying to re uh
recall right now
yes so it will be with the pawn or the
Knight that Hikaru decides to capture he
chooses the Knight I'm surprised as well
David because usually white does take it
with the pawn that knight from D2 can
reroute itself targeting the central
squares via F1 WIA G3 or E3 this offers
additional trades in the position and uh
nbec accepts it wow does hiar just want
to go to Armageddon because he's
offering a queen trade right now and I
wonder if that's what had hikaro pausing
do I really want to keep this game going
should I go to armagedon the queen trade
is offered will hikaro just try to make
a simple draw it's actually quite level
at the moment it's never a simple draw
when you're playing against NBC he
decided not to go for any Berlin lines
he's not trading off pieces easily the
Queens are still on the board he says
you want to trade my queen take it my
Rook comes onto the open file but he
does eventually go for it and I think
they're going to be a bunch of trades on
the D line yeah we might see a draw
offer I I do think that's enough play
left there's enough pieces left to cause
some problems on a good day if with a
helping hand from the opponent but uh it
does feel like both players are
peacefully inclined right now hikaru's
night capture that was the signal he
wants Armageddon chess he doesn't want a
prolonged battle where his opponent had
prepared uh deeply and yeah this one
very level with the Queens off and the
Armageddon worked at Perfection against
Maxim VRA so perhaps Hikaru feeling good
about his Armageddon chances and um and
there we see a lot of Trades will happen
on the only only open line on the board
also symmetrical Pond structure uh let's
say this Do's going to Armageddon and
I'm still thinking about what is
happening in westley's mind right now
because he does have to decide his
opponent today do you think Magnus is
actually quite happy about finishing
second and not having to go through any
of that of picking an opponent when
you've a really tough choice to make I
think it depends who wins this match
right here because if Hikaru wins I feel
like Wesley he has a really tough choice
in his hands usually you think and I
don't want to play Hikaru but Wesley
beat hkar in this event and he lost to
Fabian the only person he lost to so for
Wesley so it's not going to be easy a
choice and if Nord debeck wins I think
then it's easier I think Wesley will
pick the youngster no offense meant
towards him he's such a great champion
of the game he won the world rapid
Champion just a couple years ago but
when you're choosing between Fabby and
narbeck I think you just want to avoid
Fabby for the time being yeah and I
think you're right it's going to be more
complicated for him to pick between
Hikaru and Fabby because that's a tough
choice uh David tough choice and shout
out to Wesley if you're watching I'm
pretty sure he is Hey Wesley just uh as
he learns who his potential opponent is
going to be and uh in the meantime
Nakamura drops the Knight back and yeah
this one just so level right now no Rook
trades for now so the game still ongoing
but you can tell on hikaru's face he's
not too thrilled no attack in this
position no dynamism at all it's very
much a static positional fight and even
a grinder like me is struggling to get
too thrilled about this one that can't
be good news for us when you say that
David the one idea that I see for white
is to try to get to the queen Side by
pushing the a pawn but I think the
problem with that is the only player
who's going to be happy will be NC
because if white does the team Matic A4
black has the option to actually push
that B Pawn one step ahead and black
might be the one who's creating
weaknesses on white screen side yeah
there aren't really threats it's you
even A4 doesn't have an immediate threat
attached to it and for nir he can bring
his King closer to the center he has his
Center completely under control so
you're right Tanya that if hikaro is
inclined to play for more to play for a
win he might choose to operate on the
queen side with an a pawn push or a B
Pawn push but he plays a simple quiet F3
I I don't know I mean maybe he's
tricking us maybe he's tricking nck you
know getting him to into a sense of
complacency but it looks very very even
that's Hikaru expression number don't
know what but it's expression that says
hey let's go to Armageddon King F7 is he
going to play some copycat chess with
King F2 he's been doing a bit of CopyCat
chess it's totally symmetrical almost
symmetrical at least on the uh King side
right now why not bring the king closer
to the center when in doubt improve your
pieces there's no calculation to be done
and uh yeah a bit of a frown from
Nakamura it's either the most kind of
cunning deep deception ever where he's
just lulling us and his opponent into a
false sense of security or he still is
peacefully inclined but um yeah just
hard to imagine too much going wrong for
either side here any trades of any
pieces and we get closer to the draw
there's one advice that the I think
every top player has given in every
interview and which is don't take any of
hikaru's Expressions too seriously you
just never know what's really going on
in his mind would you agree with that
it's not so much his Expressions it's
just the moves that he's playing on the
board and in combination with the
Expressions I think that tells the full
story I'm just trying to contextualize
it he hasn't played ambitiously in this
game he had an opportunity to keep
Queens on the board by taking with a
pawn earlier instead he took with a
knight and then traded the Queens off so
I just don't see what he's aiming for I
think quite objectively narbeck has not
struggled at all in this game and hikaro
is the one who's spending a bit of time
so if hikaro continues to let this drag
on maybe nck changes his mind he's like
no longer am I just playing for a draw
with black I don't care about the Mantra
that win with white draw with black hey
why not play on a little bit there's no
real risk yeah and uh I'm struggling to
find things to say about this position
exactly uh right now Hikaru does Play
Copy catches he does bring his King
closer to the center there's one issue
in Black's position there's only one
real imbalance uh to speak of right now
and that is this Pawn that juts out on
B5 okay nck gains space on the king side
but this Pawn can be a bit of a Target
but as tan mentioned if you ever go for
it it can also be a bit of a battering
ram and this would favor Black who will
now hold the key to the bile and uh any
pawn trades the black Rooks will
activate black is the one who will be
capturing and on his terms so uh I'm uh
also not a big fan of this Black Knight
I'm slightly surprised he didn't just
try to move it out the way try to throw
the black C Pawn forward gain even more
space on that flank but uh Pawn to H5
noncommittal I think we'll see Hikaru
continue with his plan maybe trade off a
set of Bishops maybe move the Knight out
the way trade off the Rooks and uh yes
that's assuming that hikaro is happy
with the draw but I think this position
doesn't uh lend itself to anything more
and he decided not to trade the Rooks he
put that Knight back on D2 to interpose
the Rooks and so if hiar wants to draw
yeah he can go and just trade off all
the pieces but if he plays on I like
your knight A5 idea for black I think
that you can start trying to push pawns
forward make a little progress bring a
rook to B8 potentially play this B4 move
on your own valtion that Bishop on C2
it's on the wrong diagonal if you could
pick it up and move it next to the king
and then play A4 suddenly we're talking
about some pressure on the queen side
but for now it feels like only black uh
can perhaps play for a little something
and hi car is down almost 3 minutes
right now nbec spawn structures spawn
formation is the one that has more
Mobility flexibility he can start
looking at expanding on the queen side
getting that Knight out of the way
pushing the C Pawn or as he is doing on
the king side as well with H5 perhaps
the G Pawn can start marching down the
board and looking at some opening up of
lines on the king side as well Hikaru
shuffling around with the King no clear
plan that we can see for white in this
position it's clear that Hikaru would be
happy with taking this to the Armageddon
and if it was to get to that stage is
there a favorite given the form that
we're seeing by these two players well
the chess Gods tend to punish people who
play for draws with white from my
experience playing for a draw like this
uh if that's what he's doing uh might
not be great for his chess Karma hiar
Nakamura but yeah I mean he's so good
he's turned around his Armageddon luck
today and uh maybe with this uh strategy
that he's showing in this game he's
backing himself there he's confident
that he would be able to defeat Abdu
stov in the Armageddon well the best
players they create their own luck
that's what it's always said and for
someone like hikaro it's not better
lucky than good it's best lucky and good
and he has been both just here today in
the champion chestor finals and for
narbeck he's one of the best endgame
players I mean his age may just be 19
but his experience is quite extensive
you've done videos on this David and I
feel like Nock has played better than
AAR in end games and he makes this
Knight A5 Mo I don't think that Nock
just wants a draw he's like let's let's
feel this out a little bit hiar Prov
that you can hold this yeah wow not
about getting uh ambitious he's not
giving a nod to that draw the Armageddon
just yet we've got Dany in Toronto
joining us Danny what do you think what
are the chances of this one going down
to the
w i I think the chances are actually
pretty high based on the last comments
Robert just made that whether Hikaru
wanted a draw or not I think Notre Beck
is uh is confident in the end game when
the Queens come off everyone's been
talking about it we all love David
Howell's video on the young magician in
the endgame but I had to hop in because
you guys were spending so much time
trying to translate hik Caro's facial
expressions again and just say that you
guys forgot it was actually hikaro
number 67 which is I just want to prove
Danny wrong which I predicted hikaro
would win in regulations so he's just
making sure we get to Armageddon no
matter what that that was that was it
that's why it was so hard to translate
so I came to tell you that I appreciate
that Danny you're not just a strong
chestler but a great translator and well
can you translate the last few moves and
the tensions in the playing Hall if
hikaro wanted to draw he could have
trade off the pieces so what is hikaro
doing here what's his aim did you speak
to him at all during the
break no we didn't have a chance to
catch up he did catch up with Ka
obviously you saw that interview and he
said he was confident he said he thought
the last game was the best game he had
played all tournament right that he felt
like it was a pretty complete effort to
be able to defend a worse position I
think a lot of players feel that way
they almost feel better when they hold a
position than they do where they just
blow someone off the board so I'm
surprised what I do know is hikaro came
into the playing Hall early right he was
more ready than than anybody ready to
rock and and that's why I made the joke
that I think he heard my prediction that
I thought he would win in regulation and
this was not this was not the most
ambitious hikaro we've ever seen with
the white pieces even though when he
first played the anti- Berlin I was like
okay no he doesn't want want to draw
because zaro could have played the
mainline Berlin right if he wanted a
draw he didn't he played D3 I I I don't
know I mean I'm I'm kind of a little bit
surprised by where the game's going and
uh Danny you predicted that he would win
in regulation time if this is a draw as
we predict and it does go to Armageddon
are you still backing your
man yeah I still think so I think uh
Hikaru is on the way up I think Kaa did
the Kaaya did the motion when she was
standing in this exact position and and
I agree with her I think that hikaru's
trajectory is up but I'll say this if I
was in Notre Beck's shoes or if I was
his coach I would say take advantage of
this opportunity right here right now
Hikaru thought playing the white pieces
he thought he was playing with house
money he sort of traded queens and just
look at the ebal bar just slowly but
surely it's it's not anything but if I'm
notter Beck I'm like look I might have
an opportunity to push here a little bit
I'm not just going to accept Armageddon
right now and that while this one goes
on uh tell us what's going on in Toronto
right now are the other players watching
the action uh what's the WIP like there
yeah we it's funny it's a bit I think I
feel like we're all a little subdued
from what has been such a long very
dramatic day I mean we were hanging out
with Fabby and and Magnus pillow on the
couch had my head on the pillow and and
then levie was there and no one was
saying anything and then Fabby and Levy
decided to go do some content so they're
upstairs shooting some video that
everyone's going to see over the next
few days I have no idea what they're
doing and uh K's working on his next
chessable course not sure if I can spoil
that but he's already working on one for
C3 Sicilian and I was all alone and you
guys were talking about the show and I'm
like I'm going to go I'm going to go
talk to them I'm just sitting here
watching on the couch so that's why I'm
here so thanks for letting me be here I
was lonely Danny you're on the ground
you're having all the fun now you know
how we feel in the studio watching you
guys just kill it there in Toronto uh
but this one this end game goes on and
we'll keep checking in with you Danny
keep us posted on all the drama that's
happening there and what the players are
getting up right all right see you later
all right so this position nck we were
talking about perhaps is he going to try
for more in this end game the Knight has
found itself quite ahead a white picks
up the B5 Pawn the C3 Pawn will be
picked up Queen side has been cleared
off is that closer to a draw now yes is
the simple answer I think he was relying
on some tricks nybeck here uh because
white is vulnerable to checks on the
back rank but White's King does have a
safe Square White's pieces on the second
rank as well slightly vulnerable the
problem is white has got with one key
piece the heaviest piece the major piece
it is the rook and I think here one
black check won't be sufficient white KN
can even drop back and trade off for
Black's Knight Knight to B1 might well
be hikaru's next move in under any
circumstances and uh this one is
fizzling out it's all about tactics if
there's nothing concrete which there
isn't right now it's a draw and for nck
if he wanted to play on he needed pawns
on the queen side as well here after the
move Rook to A2 there is a pin along the
second rank here but the move Bishop C5
can exploit the pin on the other king so
there is really a lot of tactics in the
air here and Hikaru he's shaking his
head a little bit but without material
remaining all the pawns on the same side
of the board it should be a quality and
this line that you're pointing out seems
quite forcing I don't know David if you
can pull up the analysis board and
actually just look into that because it
feels like after the move Bishop C5 uh
few options for the players how does how
do the trades end up and we're seeing
we're seeing another move actually yeah
we're seeing another move here I think
Hikaru was slightly afraid of Rook takes
Bishop now he could play Rook takes
Bishop check as well and when the black
king moves uh the issue is in this
position if you trade everything off the
white king feels slightly uncomfortable
you've got to be careful where you step
for example the Black Knight could come
in this would have been deadly for
example with a fork of course he avoided
all of this sikar Nakamura let's catch
up with the game he found a far clearer
way to simplify and here we see
everything being traded off yes it's a
bishop versus knight imbalance But
ultimately it shouldn't be enough White
simply step back defend everything with
this rook and unless you're pinning and
winning on the second rank which I don't
think you are this one should be a draw
any moment and this is why the presence
of Pawns on both flanks would have been
advantageous for black because if you
could just put a pawn for each side
somewhere on the c or b files black
would be better Bishops do well with
long range pieces unfortunately not
enough material remains for black to
have any chances I do think that this is
a draw and yes it is it is H Nakamura it
looked like he was a man on a mission
and the mission is get to Armageddon and
it does this one goes down to the wire
two draws the players immediately have
to submit their bids and it almost feels
like Hikaru was ready with what he
wanted to bid just turns around he's
filling that in not a back about to give
in his bid oh is Hikaru going to stick
to strategy to try and get the black
pieces well he's been doing it every
single time it's been his last chance
Dance all day and well he has his bid
ready I do think he wants black but n
has shown that he wants white so maybe
Hikaru will actually have a higher bid
than we expect yeah who knows and that's
hard body language to read Hikaru I
haven't seen him that devoid of energy
in a long time it has been a marathon
day for both of them but one final push
ahead and uh you need some strong mental
fortitude to be able to pull through
this one so much on the line and at
stake here for the players uh going into
the armagedon one of these two it will
be the end of the road for them after
the Armageddon one player will make it
to the semi-finals and the race will
continue the pressure it's maximum right
now you have your last life as we see
this is the survival stage it is one to
one Fabiana Carana joined Wesley so and
Magnus Carlson in the semi-finals Wesley
will get first pick of his opponent will
he choose Fabiano or will he choose the
winner of this match we don't know who
that winner is because nck against
Nakamura that's going to overtime I'm
gonna say one more time Westley cannot
be happy about the fact that he actually
has to choose his opponent it just is so
so many Mind Games there to take that
into your own hands I would never be
able to take that decision normally it
would be great you pick your opponent
pick your adventure do what you want but
when you're playing the top players in
the world it's picking your evils and uh
it's not going to be easy ahead Wesley's
going to be watching this next game with
a lot of
interest we are waiting for the amagad
as the second one ended in a draw it was
quite a peace fight David start to
finish what did you think about it yeah
it was an equal fight but it did feel
like Abdu satov was the one trying to
make it happen make the magic happen on
the board and Hikaru was the one
cynically trying to shut things down I
just want to highlight one moment that
declared his intentions and fair play to
the youngster uh the USC here for
playing on he could simply have brought
his Knight into C4 this position would
surely fizzle out towards a draw too
symmetrical and no imbalances but he
tried something it didn't quite work out
there was nothing in the position to
start with But Here by playing C5 he
showed his ambitious intentions and
actually at least in Practical terms
some small advantages for black to hope
for actually the moment it was secured
as a draw was here where he played the
move Knight to A4 pawns disappearing if
he'd wanted to play on for a win maybe
he would have elected Bishop to D7 but
in the end it was him putting the
pressure on Hikaru neutralized him it
was a very equal game and for n he
didn't have a worst position for a
single move in that two- game mini match
he must be feeling pretty good from that
standard yeah he was clearly the one uh
kind of showing better form there and
just with one or two accurate moves in
the first game maybe he'd already be
through so pros and cons for both
players wow pros and cons for both
players and it comes down to the sudden
Deb the big big the ultimate Armageddon
and it's between Hikaru Nakamura and
nbec Abdus Sato we will be back with
more bids and subscribers stay with us
as we bring you some very cool behind
the scen
[Music]
footage if you could list your three
goals that you hope to achieve in 20203
Magnus Carlson is looking ahead to yet
another year with exciting chess but
first let's go back to 2022 I would say
on the board it was mostly Pretty good
overall um I think it was one of mine
better years he definitely seemed
focused at the board as the 32-year-old
finished the Year by winning back the
rapid and Blitz world championship
titles was relief uh a part of what you
felt there uh heading into a year where
you will give away your your classical
title the timing is perfect like if
there was one time that I really uh that
I really wanted of those titles would
been now but yeah it just gave me gave
me joy and like still when I I think
about it
makes me smile uh it was a really great
moment and joy is exactly what the
world's best chess player wants more of
in
2023 just want to you know to play and
have fun and I feel like that's true
more than in a long time especially now
that I have these rapid and Blitz W
titles though I can just relax and have
fun I think I look at it at least
sometimes a little more philosophically
then before that you know if I have a
bad event I have a bad event then I'll
hit back in the next
[Music]
one number one is win a game with 1 V3
okay and second is to have fun and uh
third one is to win a game from minus 10
position that's for the
tour a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
the
it's night time and it's cold in Toronto
but it's heating up inside the playing
Arena as the battle is on for the final
semifinalist of the Champions chest off
finals and it's time for the sudden
death between hiccup and n and Robert
Hikaru has had quite the history with
armagedon this event so far it was
mostly down and now it's going up
because hiar Nakamura has seen himself
in five Armageddon he finally got a win
with the black pieces against Maxim Vash
lra he's a survivor he's not going to
give up this is the survival stage and
it might be his last Armageddon if he
can't get the job done I see black black
black black as picks by Hikaru Nakamura
on this stage is he going going to try
to get the black pieces let's find out
with
Ka the most exciting armor get on bid so
far in the CCT finals you guys go ahead
and turn your boards how L will you go
948 versus 935 oh that's close n be you
will play with the black pieces how are
you feeling right now yeah I feel like
um I had experience playing with white
so yeah let's try black and white pieces
car are you kind of happy with the
result here doesn't matter I've had so
many blacks Whit let's just arm again
let see what happens so one game to
decide who goes through to the
semifinals uh are you um promising some
excitement for the fans right now I mean
we'll see I've played so many games
today at this point I just I'll just
play moves that's all I'm thinking about
awesome best of luck you guys in this
armagon game back to the
studio o God that was such a close bit
and guys Hikaru is saying that it
doesn't matter he gets white but I think
it does matter I think he wanted the
black pieces I think he was surprised
surprised by N's bid because nirc has
shown a tendency to bid a higher number
to get white he bid 14 minutes 58
seconds against fabbi just to get the
white pieces and here he got lower than
hikaro it's a surprise yeah nock's
decision there was clearly influenced by
that final game we saw that ball draw
that uh kind of game where nothing
happened he maybe sensed that Hikaru
wasn't as high on energy and he says now
Hikaru you have to beat me you have to
try and do better than that and yeah nck
changing his strategy on the Fly
interesting will it work
very interesting and we got a scenario
at our hands that we haven't seen before
Hikaru Nakamura will start the
Armageddon with the white pieces and
we've got Danny joining us from Toronto
Danny what do you make of that Hikaru
with white how how do you think that's
going to go I'm I'm excited I mean I
feel like at this point we would have
not have seen everything if aaro didn't
get white in in an Armageddon right so
now we'll have seen it all no matter
what happens I'm excited to see it and
Levy you got something to show us here
too yeah uh first of all we're selling
this sponsor space right here so if
anybody wants to get yeah this is this
is genius stuff we got to get a a
Coca-Cola a great idea yeah there you go
shout out to production they had this
idea 9:35 that's a big bid Hikaru gets
to play White and he's got all this
momentum and he's going to be up five
and a half minutes against you do we
like the bid what are we what are we
thinking yeah it's interesting I mean I
I think putting Hikaru in in in the
chair to have a must win is a chair that
he hasn't been in yet right he's been on
the black side of it but from that
perspective I mean I don't know that I
like my chances there David and Robert
you were saying you feel like Notre Beck
was maybe in slightly better form I
don't even know if I agree with that I
feel like HIC Caro's form was phenomenal
in the first game it took really great
form to hold that as black and he
basically just had no ambition as white
so I also noticed something in that
interview hikaro had a little bit of
that I literally don't care Vibe which I
actually think is where he's better so
the fact that he's a little bit like
whatever makes me think he's even more
dangerous right now he didn't seem
stressed at all yeah it was like smiling
this this the last game of the day
period for both but it's I mean they one
of them has to win one of them is
leaving the tournament so yeah he was in
surprisingly good and and not like
overly focused Spirits maybe he
literally doesn't care we don't know I
guess we're going to find
out we will find out uh I'm going to
disagree with you guys I think Hikaru
cares a lot about what's happening and
with the bid that we saw I don't think
he's too happy that he ended up with the
white pieces but we will find out guys
we'll uh we'll see you in sometime a big
big Armageddon coming up there nck uh
he's going to with black and he needs
only a draw to get into the semi-finals
how is he going to try to keep things
solid on the board well no landed the
first surprise with his bid but hikaro
has been surprised with people all event
with his opening choices I don't even
know what to tell you that hikaro will
play normally people stick to a narrow
repertoire hikaru's thrown out
everything under the sun yeah and we
talked about Hikaru yes he hasn't played
whiten and Armageddon but today he's had
two pretty much must-win situations with
white first against lavic where he
needed to land the first punch in the
first match of the day and uh then
against Maxi Vash gra where he lost with
black needed to with win with white and
demand he did achieve it so today of all
days it feels like the perfect time to
get those white pieces to get the extra
time and if he can keep that going
ReDiscover his earlier energy yeah he
might be uh loving those extra minutes
wow big fight coming up and in terms of
opening approach which is so important
in these armag gens to try to get your
opponent to think early on burn the
clock what can we expect from these two
well I've never seen n invest that much
time in the opening it feels like he's
always confident well prepared he just
feels like he's in Rhythm so for Hikaru
it's one of those weird balancing acts
how do I pressure him on the clock but
also make sure that I keep things going
on the board and not take too many risks
Nery backck punished mvl earlier today
it feels like forever ago he crushed him
with black he checkmated him so he can
win with the black pieces yeah he can
certainly win with the black pieces
that's why hikaru's opening choice is
the most important thing right now if
Hikaru plays anything like we saw in
that last game if he plays anything
predictable I think nck will land a
flurry of quick moves and might be the
favorite but if Hikaru can surprise
launch another surprise maybe a Mimi
opening then Anything Can Happen will we
see a Mimi opening by Hikaru we'll find
out in just a few moments Let's uh take
a look at our bracket because this is
the match that decides our final our
fourth
semi-finalist bestle so Magnus Carlson
Fabiano Carana are already in whoever
wins this Armageddon goes is the fourth
player and Wesley so will pick between
the winner of this match and Fabiano
Carana to challenge in the semi-finals
we will get to that later today but
right now this is the battle it really
looked like Hikaru his approach in the
second rapid game that this is where he
wanted to be this is the match that he
was hoping for does that mean Advantage
Hikaru he gets what he wanted well I do
appreciate what Danny said how that
tough defense is often worth more than
even winning a game where someone makes
some huge mistakes so hikaro he's been
able to dig deep he's been winning all
day today he had a bad event overall it
would see him but he's won all day yeah
and uh remember it is Hikaru he wins 40
games in a row 45 games in a row he just
needs to win this one right now now
they've had two draws you can run but
you can't hide from a decisive result in
this format and it is a go time
handshakes and we are off it's a king's
porn opening it's E4 E5 yet again which
variation is Hikaru going to go for
again this slow assistant with Pawn to
D3 and much more aggressive this time he
throws the pawn forward two squares
white controls the center a bind all
pieces guaranteed to remain on the board
for a while now and uh I'm liking the
approach here Robert I play this from
the black side growing up as I mentioned
earlier and I always hated playing
against this particular move order from
White because you've got this clamp this
bind we talked about the moroi bind
against the Sicilian Defense here the C4
and E4 pawns make sure that black can't
lash out with D5 and so that light score
Bishop for black it's not going to have
the easiest home but I kind of like what
nck just did he threw his Knight forward
and he actually put the question Naru
yeah he's trying to force the issue
normally when you want to play for a
draw when you don't have time you want
to actually make things more concrete
more tactical then it's easier to
calculate you don't want that tension
difficult strategic decisions on every
turn he's saying trade my night or don't
trade my KN either way my next couple of
moose are going to be obvious and uh he
plugging blocking up a square that white
maybe wanted to use for his own points
interesting decision definitely Nakamura
the first one to think here I would take
that Knight I enjoy giving my opponent
double pawns and clearly hikaro feels
the same way in these kind of time
controls because double pawns they're
frustrating you have to handle them in
the middle game but then the end game
those are bad because they can't help
you create a pass Pawn but right now
nybeck challenges that night in the
center Hikaru spending more time thus
far then norre it's a double pawn and it
also gives Hikaru the majority on the
king side to get more flexibility to get
the pawn rolling right like the F Pawn
can arrive on F4 eventually the G Pawn
can start marching down the board so
even though you've traded out one set of
minor pieces you've caused an imbalance
in the pawn structure and for the player
who's playing for the win in a must-win
situation that's a good outcome that's a
good outcome but normally you want to
keep uh keep as many pieces on the board
as possible here it's a dilemma to trade
the remaining set of knights or to keep
them on the board he takes them off and
uh he could have retreated but that
would have cost some time it's purely
about Bishops it's purely about those
Pawn pushes you mentioned Tanya and I
wouldn't be surprised if in the next
couple of moves Hikaru starts muring
forward on the side he's stronger oo he
actually pushes on the queen side
instead that was super surprising to me
he's gaining space but that's the side
where black kind of has five against
four Pawn advantage and F Pawn push that
seemed the most logical but it's a good
type of move to distract your opponent
not in terms of anything ontour but now
n there like what is he actually aiming
for and N shuts that down quickly so
great reaction to a decision that was a
little unclear yeah it's slightly
simplified now this equation this
position even and uh I don't like it
from Hikaru I think maybe keeping the
knights on actually just adding a little
bit of extra spice for later on uh would
have been uh would have been my
preference at least but Hikaru he's
extremely good here he's extremely good
in general when it comes to deciding
porn structures knowing when to
stabilize when to switch the pace and
it's about whether Abdu satov can
maintain this tension he actually
flinches first and captures Pawn
structure changing evolving on every
single move because that pawn on D4 it's
a double Pawn but it's about to be a
pass Pawn hiar has no choice but to give
up the pawn in front of it look at that
Queen H4 is there a sacrific on H3 in
some of these positions that hiar has to
keep an eye out for yeah watch out
because if the white king is stripped of
its shelter there might be Perpetual
checks there might be draws which would
favor black but the speed with which he
played that one abdor just you could see
the emphasis he put on that move it just
scares the opponent at the very minimum
so impressive by nck right now and it's
uh the potential threats on the king
side that you're pointing out but also
combine that with that Central D Pawn
which can be defended by its best friend
like you say Robert the C Pawn moving
one step ahead C5 the D Pawn when it
moves forward the bishop will open up uh
and I see the evalar says everything is
fine it's all level I'm starting to like
Black's position just a little bit more
yeah Engineers as well mhm Pawn to C5 I
think you should play it lock out this
before it's too late and not only that
but I think his intentions by putting
his Queen on H4 might even be to attack
on the king side later watch out for F5
pushing that pawn maybe even G5 G4
playing on this flank nock's locked down
the position essentially this is a weak
Pawn rendering this bishop passive on B3
and white is therefore playing down a
piece wow he plays F5 first I'm slightly
surprised by this one because now C5
brings this bishop back to life Renewed
Energy suddenly and wow a big
opportunity for nakamuro I think a bit
of haste there a bit more patience would
have given black a dream position
instead my peter growing up always that
haste makes waste and this seems like a
wasted opportunity because F5 you're
lashing out but it may be too soon that
C5 responds is a great one for hikara if
black had played C5 instead I didn't see
an active plan for hiar who needs a win
let's remind everybody a draw it allows
not back abusar to sail through the
semis and c5s on the board but not he
expected all this yeah he expected to
all of this but suddenly it's really
irrational the pawn structure also ideas
of Simply taking a pawn establishing a
passer he plays f for Nakamura f for
forward again and he's happily allowing
a trade of Pawns in the center because
White's Rook is getting active it's
creeping in so many weaknesses for black
suddenly this is turning Nakamura should
be thrilled by the developments here
absolutely I really like the idea of nck
stopping all the player with his own
seon moving forward and now again it's a
game where Hikaru can suddenly start
fighting for Advantage and look at that
the valbar keeps moving in his favor
after that last move it's hits The Rook
allowing White's Rook to step forward to
E6 targeting the C6 weakness I think no
dear Beck abdar likes to solve
positional problems in tactical ways
there are number of top players who do
this if that Rook steps forward he might
push his G Pawn he may be going for the
white king that C6 Pawn it's vulnerable
but maybe you give it up to just go for
the attack I think Robert you're
forgetting that this is an Armageddon
white has to play for a win here yeah G5
that's crazy but that's the thing the
position may already call for it if you
sit passively in defend that may not
actually increase your chances of
survive throwing pawns forward going
after the white king that actually may
be giving black a better chance because
there are threats against the white king
yeah he doesn't know how to play for a
draw Abdu sator if you don't know how to
play for a draw if you don't want to
play solid why not play aggressively and
I love your move Robert as you mentioned
playing passively defending this Pawn
this would only give white time to bring
this Rook into action and once it starts
swinging over no no more attack the
white King Super safe for eternity and
one-sided traffic too many weaknesses
longterm white will simply win so go on
the attack it might be now or never for
Abdus satoro and uh this Pawn push it is
a poison Pawn as well because of this
doubled uh attack this bishop loose and
he goes for it wow Abdu sakov is not
backing down he needs only a draw but
he's going all out for the attack now
these guys of course don't have the
evalar like we do how do you think he is
evaluating nbec is evaluating this
position the proper evaluation is messy
it's looking very unclear it's Dynamic
chances for black but a positional I
don't even want to say Advantage almost
positionally winning for white the
double pawns are bad in the center the
C6 Pawn is weak the A6 Pawn can be
targeted but G5 it's really a great idea
to throw some a wrench in the position
not Danny I see you though there buddy
but just to cause chaos and I think not
back he can be that agent of chaos that
Gotham City
fears smoothly done robertt love it
loving the name drops KY feels left out
though though now and uh Nakamura he
needs to adapt to this new landscape he
needs to suddenly adjust defend
potentially for a few moves if white
does defend longterm he is winning so uh
he's wisely investing his time that
being said the time difference that was
around 6 minutes to start with is now
down to only three such Speedy actions
there from Abdu satoro I'm expecting
Nakamura with haste to bring his rook in
the corner over to defend his King but
even if he was to slide that Rook he
does end up losing the F4 pawn and uh
what's the idea that is white just
aiming at picking up the Queens Side
Pawn in Pawns in return one thing is
clear right white can't really open up
the F line you take on G5 you can't
allow the queen to jump in with the
check on F2 hikaro he's really thinking
a lot here because Rook F1 the move that
you're pointing out seems like the
obvious choice but perhaps what's the
followup after Pawn into Pawn it's such
a good question cuz even following it up
with The Rook takes Pawn on C6 I think
in many of these positions black can
slide a rook to E8 and start taking over
this open file and perhaps this is the
wrong moment for it but the point is
that black is bring another aggressive
piece into the attack I am curious what
the better move was rather than Rook to
E8 but in some of the other positions
Rook E8 may be the move that satisfies
Black's chances yeah I think this uh is
definitely the human approach who cares
if the eval Bar says it's winning for
white humans will not defend this one
cold bloodly and uh he does bring his
Rook across to E1 instead I was going to
say Pawn pushes maybe D3 open up this
Bishop's route into D4 maybe F3 blow
open the king side instead Nakamura just
tries to block everything up look at
this blocked on a dart Square for now
blocked on the dart Square although
maybe he should throw this por off the
board right now and uh this one is still
chaotic nybeck ooh I'm not sure about
this uh shift in Gears Rook to F6 maybe
it was time throw this Pawn off the
board threaten to bring this bishop in
with some checks if the White Queen had
taken throw the other paor off the board
as well and now White's King is in
serious trouble but instead trading
pieces when you're down longterm
strategically who cares if you're upper
porn for now too many weaknesses I don't
like this last move I don't like it
either and for hikaro he has a couple
choices he can just trade on the spot or
he can give a back ranked check the
black king is caught in the corner
Black's Rook can still backtrack and it
probably will to f8 but Advantage Hikaru
I mean he isn't up that much time
anymore but his position does seem to be
improving if NC does fall back with the
Rook Hikaru can trade on the A8 Square
forcing NC's only remaining Rook to
quite a passive position and then he can
start activating the other Rook the
other remaining Rook to take the spot on
E6 targeting the queen side bonds uh not
about thinking now is there is there
anything else to think about uh is there
an alternative to actually falling back
I think you have to Tanya it's not a
nice move you're basically accepting as
well that you've lost a bit of time The
Rook just came from f8 hardest thing in
as a human is to retreat admit you've
made a bit of a mistake I think he might
have underestimated to this one nybeck
he was assuming the Rooks will be traded
on his own terms but yeah Rooks coming
off Queens coming off that would only
help white you're CAU a rock in a hard
play because if you trade off all the
Rooks you think oh my position uh looks
pretty bad because the end games will
all be terrible for me so he does go
Rook f8 to not trade all the Rooks off
but if you keep a rook on the board
after I thought you going trade on a
eight a white Rook would still land on
E6 to be active but now this is not
Beck's opportunity and he decides not to
go with Rook F6 I think he didn't like
the outcome of that obviously Hikaru
would have never repeated but instead he
goes with Rook to see it I think D3 has
to happen you have to push the D Pawn
you have to activate your dark Squad
Bishop he does it he does it before it's
too late I'm really surprised I must
admit Hikaru nakur repeating the
position once a draw of course doesn't
suit him he wouldn't have repeated a
third time but I don't know maybe he was
just trying to play Mind Games he could
have just played objectively there Rook
takes rook in the corner looks so
natural and suddenly it's a bit more
messy with all these Rooks remaining it
should be time sooner or later for
White's King to shuffle into the corner
but uh suddenly the black Bishop
Unleashed do you think that Hikaru was
automatically expecting nck to repeat
with Rook to F6 in that position I guess
so because all not needs is a draw but
this moment here is a big one because
that King H1 move is quite clever no
longer does Bishop D4 come with check
which makes it less tempting it's still
might be a good move but instead he
sizing with Queen G3 I love it such a
good decision if the Queens get traded
that white king is now the one that's
stuck in the corner there could be back
rank checkm ideas that save black
because otherwise that C6 Pawn is quite
tender yeah beautiful move and actually
nbec will not take the White Queen he
wants to force white to take on his
terms because as you mentioned Robert
this king is now caged forever simply No
Way Out The Pawn on G3 holds the key to
that King's escape and always going to
be threats against it long term so uh
right now I think both sides will just
keep their Queens on these squares
forever and uh try to just nudge the
other one say please take me please take
me and uh hikaru's doing it on his terms
Rook to F1 do not take the Queens if
you're nobec because suddenly this Pawn
is loose this Pawn is loose this Pawn is
loose and these weaknesses will come
back to haunt black can he trade Queens
though and then put a rook on E8 like
can he just say all right you're going
to take one of my pawns he can't take
both at the same time and as long as I
control this open file I'm going to have
some good chances he actually does it
with the queen C the board so David you
are correct keeping the queen on the
square trade on your own terms that's
what n is going for and if you take that
C6 Pawn a rook May land on E2 and
suddenly it's white that's in huge
trouble yeah suddenly he'll regret not
capturing this Pawn earlier when he had
the opportunity uh CaRu and the clock's
really ticking down now this is getting
dramatic on the board as you mentioned
Robert this e file is priceless right
now it's the hottest commodity in town
the black Rook if it gets in could be
disaster for white every move in chess
has its own set of consequences Hikaru
moves one of the Rooks from the e file
and immediately nbec uses the
opportunity to trade off a set of Rooks
he does give up the F4 Pawn but that D
Pawn is just so strong on the board to
me despite the evalar against stting
level
I'm starting to like Black's chances
here black is definitely better in fact
if you trade Queens it's not even just
about the D Pawn anymore Bishop C3 at
the end that Bishop has been stationed
near the black king as a Defender now
it's going to go into the offensive mode
and go to C3 the B4 Pawn is loose after
that C5 is dropping and if you do
nothing the D Pawn then can push
successfully and white will have to
sacrifice a piece wow he has to play
rotates Pawn here giving up his pride
and joy the B Pawn suddenly hikaru's
earlier move A4 looks just uh a bit
foolish this is weak this pawn and yeah
I think this is almost guaranteed to be
safe for black key moment he needs to
just trade Queens maybe he's looking for
the attack here nbec maybe he wants to
drop his Queen back keep the tension but
uh yeah if he takes Queens he should be
safe he should have enough time to make
this draw he does it Queen's off the
board a very practical decision here
nbec needing only a draw he does go in
with the line great call by Robert there
jumps in with the bishop he's going to
trade that D Pawn for a very key B Pawn
which would have given Hikaru
counterplay had he managed to get B5 in
so nbec just kills all of those ideas on
the queen side and Hikaru winced I think
he missed this move from a distance what
you get to the position like oh Bishop
C3 that's there the B4 Pawn is loose but
from far away that move seemed
impossible because the black king did
have so many white pieces around it now
this looks like with material whittling
down hikaru's time it's uh more than
nybeck by 2 minutes but n has plenty of
time to reach move 60 where they get 1
second increment yeah it will started
going wrong for Hikaru when he retreated
when he tried to repeat the position
once he surely would have known that
taking in the corner making full use of
his opponent's mistake would have given
him better chances but he was trying to
play mind games when it was unnecessary
and nbec never gives into Mind Games
he's so confident uh just undaunted
forever and okay now he's trying to cut
off the black King's advance but look at
that black dewn ready to pounce look at
the white cawn disappearing black is
better have we spoken about this NC's
mental fortitude he doesn't let a player
get into his head and it could come down
to that defining moment where Hikaru
just thought that nbec is going to
repeat automatically needing only a draw
but immediately declining that and since
then it's been momentum nbec Abdus satov
and Hikaru is in big trouble he has to
win this game and the only way I think
he can do that is the clock right now
but 3 minutes and 36 seconds they're
already on move 36 and some of these
moves are be quite easy Bishop takes C5
for black is almost premm movable the
dwn can go up the board and something
like there's a checkm attack where you
actually have to calculate I feel like
this is actually pretty easy by super GM
standards for nbec at this stage yeah
look at the body language he was bobbing
his head normally we see that from
Hikaru this time it was from nbec and uh
he was doing a bit of a flex a bit of a
stretch there he's feeling confident
he's getting ready actually for the
scramble uh when it becomes thick and
fast and he has to move quickly I don't
even know how to hustle here for Hikaru
maybe give a check with the bishop maybe
Advance the king throw Whit kingside
pawns forward but it looks full on here
I think KY needs a new line of merch is
that a Coe calculation over eoe end
games over everything because that's
where nyback abdar thrives again and
again we see him play these fine
technical end games he almost beat hiar
in the first game of the match he beat
him in their previous Armageddon Tanya
right now it's all nck and you can see
it on Hikaru and look at the confidence
with which nck is busting out those
moves and Hikaru is just not able to
play those Mind Games those
psychological battle and now it's just
been fizzled out into a pawn up end game
for nck a rook Pawn end game this has to
finish in NC's favor Hikaru on the brink
of elimination even if you throw away
Black's a pawn even if you throw away
Black's D Pawn still an elementary draw
and he's giving out Hikaru is almost
giving up he's exasperated he's been
going at this all day today he's been on
that last life and N debeck may be the
person who puts the dagger in him
because nobody else has been able to and
here we go black getting the Rook out of
the way ready to advaned pawns iaru is
asking questions of the black king
forcing net to spend a bit of time the
white King has to start start advancing
okay now pushing this Pawn even if black
just goes passive brings The Rook to the
back rank no way through there we go
this is guaranteed to be safe now for
nobec even without his two points the A
and D pawns it's a dead draw but he has
them so he can put his Rook behind one
of them and then you know one gets lost
you put your Rook behind the other the
king for white will have to sit
passively this is a very easy draw for
NCA buar that means hikara Nakamura is
about to be eliminated from the field it
looks like these are the last few moves
in the last few moments of Hikaru
Nakamura in the Champions chest star
finals in Toronto and nbec he gets that
Rook behind the pawn he can give up both
the A and the D Pawn as the black king
marches towards White spawns Hikaru
Nakamura there's nothing to be done he
is trying he gets the rook in he wants
to try and threaten a check on G7 but
even if you grab the 87 Pawn it's not
going to be enough nbec doesn't even
allow that the Rooks are going to be
traded cuz the G4 Pawn is hanging this
is a draw coming up and the final hope
for Hikaru goes away with that G4 Pawn
falling off the board yeah not much more
to be said nock's defended perfectly
he's uh guided this game safely towards
a draw yeah this one is pretty much over
flagging is the only way but look at the
time he still has two and a half minutes
Abdu sator we've just passed move 60
zero chance we'll see King versus King
Nakamura is
out n Abdus he does it he goes through
to the semifinals in the armagedon
taking down world number three harkar
Nakamura what a performance by the
19-year-old usbek Phenom and he's the
one who will be fighting it out in the
Champions chest continuing his battle
there Hikaru he really fought hard today
and it all came down down to this one
yeah hikaro is the Heart of a Lion I
mean the fact that he was even at this
point today is a miracle but it's a
miracle of his own doing and the kid
from usbekistan he is a national hero
he's won them Olympic gold medals and
now he remains in this tournament
beating hikaro after losing earlier to
Fabian Carana you enough cannot be said
of him the future is bright the present
may also be quite bright there's a lot
of money at stake for him he is
surviving and advancing what a game what
a performance what an Armageddon few
would have bet David against Hikaru in
an Armageddon seeing his performance
today seeing him come back in those
matches earlier on and nbe gets the job
done what impressed you the most about
this game so many impressive things
nock's speed his uh aggression even in a
situation where a draw suited him he
actually did have a bit of a shaky patch
in the middle of that game but once he
got a chance he pounced on it and I just
want to highlight the One Missed
opportunity for Hikaru Nakamura I think
a bad psychological decision in the end
in what was uh a difficult position of
course but it was here nbec the only
small mistake in the whole game Rook to
F6 did allow a check and here Nakamura
instead of pouncing and capitalizing on
this opportunity trading off the Rooks
in the corner and then lifting his
remaining Rook into the game winning
potentially this C6 Pawn with a good
long-term Advantage he dropped back he
repeated the position back where he came
from allowing Abdu sator ABD satov to
correct his mistake no more Rook F6 no
more mistake in move there Rook to C8
instead and it was here Pawn to D3
really powerful unleashing the black
bishop and then this move Queen to g3o
closing the cage around the white king
and ultimately securing a level position
every single move with purpose from n
beara he did not give hikaro that second
chance and for hiar it was tough because
trading pieces when you need a win
that's a difficult decision to make he
made the wrong one and nck he made him
pay incredibly impressive Chess By nbec
Abdu satro just going for the most
dynamic options the most combative play
in an Armageddon where he needs only a
draw he was not going for any kind of
solid situations always a difficult call
and now it's going to be a difficult
call for Wesley so who is in po position
going in to the semi-finals and he has
to pick between Fabby and nbec and at
the start of this amagat and we spoke
about this and you said if nbec makes it
through Wesley will perhaps go for nbec
but after that crushing Armageddon the
style that NCA shown how easy is this
decision for uh Wesley well Wesley was
undefeated until he played a certain
somebody and that somebody was Fabiano
Carana so if you're Wesley so you don't
really want to pick you're choosing
between two difficult options but you
pick the kid you picked nirc abaro you
say my experience should pay off and
he's probably pretty tired after that
very long and challenging armagan that
we just saw yeah it feels like Wesley so
he's in a chess position now with two
possible moves either he pi picks a move
he knows very well Fabiano Carana but he
knows it might lead to complications or
he just takes a stab into the dark into
the unknown and picks Abdu satoro I mean
at this point everyone's just super
strong everyone's bang in form and for
Wesley I don't envy his choice at all oh
I absolutely agree with you David I
think uh the happy guy here is Magnus
Carlson says I don't have to do anything
I'm just waiting for my opponent I will
play whoever comes on but for Wesley
there is a big decision but right now
the man of the moment it is not a back
what uh what a game what a finish by him
and he is with Danny at the desk in
Toronto yeah thank you T like you said
the man of the moment and he is with us
here at the desk Notre Beck Abdus turov
gets the job done in Armageddon fashion
I want to just throw to the conversation
you were you and I were having before we
were here you played Rook F6 take us
into your emotions there you knew it was
a mistake you're you must have been
nervous and then Hikaru gave you that
second chance and you didn't repeat it
take us just through how you were
feeling in that moment and and how big
the nerves were there yeah in general I
I Tred to play very aggressively against
saru specifically because you know he is
um he doesn't like to to to Def to
defend I think um you know especially in
armagedon
um you know it's hard to defend so I
needed to you know just attack him so um
yeah it worked out well and um yeah
playing Rook F6 I I didn't like my
position after Rook E8 rook f8 and of
course he should have traded The Rook
Rook A8 Rook A8 and I think rookie six
was strong and um yeah I think white was
better there but after he played rookie
6 no I didn't I I I didn't made um same
mistakes so Rook play Rook C8
I have a question for you uh how much of
the decision to play Black in the
Armageddon was about the fact that you
wanted to play Black because you just
played White against Fabiano and how
much of it was also taking black away
from Hikaru which is like his main
weapon in
armag yeah um was it mostly about you or
was a little bit also about no mostly
about of course me because um when I
played against him with white um I I
didn't get any like any advantage out of
opening with white so you know I it was
a miracle to to to win that end game so
you know I
just um reconsidered my decision and
okay chose chose the black pieces I mean
I I bet I beat 935 which is uh which is
low for me we were a little scared yeah
but you got the job done so got the job
done man so uh you lost the first two
matches and then soared all the way
through what has been working the best
for you especially against the strong
field also psychology a little bit there
you lost the two matches made it all the
way through here what's actually working
the
best yeah actually in the first day um
it was tough day because although I
played decent chess um it it wasn't
enough to to score a point um you know I
lost to Ali Rea and uh um I made a two
draws with Magnus and headed head to
armagon there I didn't have
like much of a chance so yeah I felt
like I have to I have to get into shape
and um you know just um uh refresh my my
mind very good regardless of what
happens from here you're in the
semi-finals but you just beat Hikaru
Nakamura for the second time here in
Toronto and you and I were talking about
the fact that you grew up on chess.com
you were nine years old watching The
Legend how much is that a big part of
what you feel right now beating someone
who you grew grew up watching just beat
everybody in front of you so how much do
you need to keep your nerves together
when you're going against someone like
that yeah it's
definitely definitely tough um
because you know Hikari is a
especially emotional player I
mean uh you know I can't um keep my
Impressions with me because you know
it's
like
it's very different playing against yaru
for me um so yeah it's um I tried my
best well you tried your best and uh the
best possible result happened man you
should be feeling great I know you got a
lot more chess ahead here and I know
you're not done but congratulations on
what was an incredible performance an
incredible day and we're now going to
throw it over to Kaa who's catching up
with hikaro
Nakamura all right Hikaru Nakamura is
here he is now knocked out of the
tournament and how will you sum up this
day car yeah I mean it's better than I
expected um from the start I mean like
ultimately it came down to one critical
game and I mean my bid was bad clearly
um and I didn't get what I wanted out of
the opening uh so yeah that's how it
goes maybe I had some chance in the
middle game to trade Rooks on A8 and
play on but I think always he had a too
much counter playay with his D3 Queen G3
and all these other ideas so yeah maybe
I could have done something a little bit
better but overall I don't think it was
ever really there so that's just how it
goes fans super disappointed to see you
knocked out how do you feel about it I
mean it came down to Armageddon I mean I
again like obviously I lost match so so
whatever I say people will take it very
negatively but I mean I just don't think
the format's very good I think the
notion that you have matches decided
after two games on an Armageddon where
really I mean for lack of better way of
putting as a coin flip I just just don't
like um and you know it doesn't matter
whether it's my match or other matches I
just feel like considering the amount of
prize money that there is um there
should be more games there should be
something a little bit different so so
yeah it's what it is but but but as I
said I mean considering how poorly I
played every day except today I'm not
going to be super unhappy about the
result and obviously coming in to the
tournament as one of the big big
favorites struggling the first few days
here do you take some pride in uh sort
of the mental resilience to come back
with a much better day today yeah I mean
as as I said I think that I played very
very badly I mean maybe the results
weren't as bad as a play but I miss a
lot of basic concepts and tactics
throughout the first couple of days even
today I think I missed something like
against mvl but uh I think it's a good
sign that even when I'm not playing very
well I still I still had a pretty decent
result I mean I I know you can say I'm a
big favorite but I actually I I don't
think anybody is a big favorite simply
because of the limited amount of games I
think there's going to be a lot of
variant I mean even for Magnus for
example um like I know it was in the
preliminary but I mean he played Wesley
drew two games and just he didn't win
the Armageddon game and or he lost the
Armageddon game I think it wasn't just
like that like I mean that's why Magnus
lost so I me so few games there's a lot
of variance I mean I don't think
anybody's is a big favorite but still I
I do expect Magnus to win if he if he
plays well now um what does dair's
future hold for you now what are your
plans going forwards the next few weeks
um no real plans I'll be going going
home I'll be spending time with my
family uh unlike some of the other
players I'm not going to usbekistan for
for the world rapid and Blitz so
probably relax my family for a bit and
then um and then I have something in
February in Bundesliga and then
candidates in April but pretty much go
back to the regular routine just
streaming doing all the usual stuff and
um it's not not that big of a deal well
Life's good and before the tournament
you did say that you wanted to sort of
check out Toronto before the candidates
to you know check out restaurants other
stuff uh have you been able to do all of
that not so much I mean it's been very
cold and considering I'm from Florida
I'm not really enjoying the weather that
much but I think that at the end of the
day um you know I have some idea of the
area and where I want to be for the
candidates so I I feel pretty good and
as I said after after what happened in
this event the first first couple of
days I mean finishing in what fifth or
something when I very EAS could have
been seventh or eighth I mean really
probably should have been uh I'm not I'm
not going to complain and so it'll be
exciting to watch what happens in the
final final couple of matches four
players left what do you predict for the
CCT finals now well I mean I think it's
still the same format right two games on
armagedon so tomorrow will'll be best
out of four games possible armag they
changed the format okay so now they
change it to four yeah okay I mean yeah
I think best of four gives Magnus a big
advantage over everybody else I think
best of two I I actually would give
Wesley pretty good chance say I think um
but best of four I think Magnus has to
be the the big favorite just cuz if he
plays the quality chest that he usually
does or four games I mean it' be very
surprising if anybody can hold him to
four draws so Magnus is the favorite but
I mean if I have to root for somebody
I'm I'm going to be rooting for Wesley
okayu thank you for the entertainment
and for sharing your thoughts sure no
problem all right hiar Nakamura I know
the fans are disappointed he is knocked
out back to the
[Music]
studio and the fans will miss hkar
Nakamura for sure and as you can see
right there Abdus saurov sends home the
most viewed chess streamer on the planet
and we still have uh some big things to
figure out though at the end of this
very long very exciting survival stage
day we still don't know who's going to
play who in the semifinals as we do now
extend the matches to Four game matches
versus two and the guy who has
everyone's Fate In His Hands I guess if
you will is now with us Wesley so yeah
wait before you even say who you're
playing what did you think of the match
we just saw there between Hikaru and and
Notre Beck you think gotam the most
viewed streamer in the planet YouTuber
streamer YouTuber and streamers are
different I think it's it's definitely
until you start that's right that's
right well Anish quit right well I was I
was very impressed by the fact that you
know he came back from behind obviously
he didn't have the first a very good
first three days but uh he had to win
all three matches today and uh he very
nearly made it so I'm very impressed by
the fighting Spirit to come back it's
very difficult but he seems to be in
good spirits and I'm sure he'll bounce
back very strongly yeah uh yeah was
watching mostly the I was watching that
all the Armageddon games yeah so very
very impressive stuff well we want to
get more thoughts from you but we also
want to dive right into the big question
and so it's time for you to choose your
opponent Fabiana Carana or Notre Beck
abaturov who you playing I pick Magnus
oh you're picking Magnus Magnus you see
that no I'm just kidding
the
rules Wesley if he can let's make it
happen
no no
okay okay who who do who do you have
well it's a very tough decision
obviously there are no easy opponents
but you don't really want to play
against the number one or the number two
player in the world in the semi-finals
so I'm picking my boy n backck yeah he's
really a dangerous opponent I've been
watching him he's very aggressive very
tactical uh he's a great fighter and
he's very tricky but between him and
Fabiano I have to choose him got it that
makes sense I mean it was a it it was
binary right it was it was one or the
other it it was zero or one or Magnus
apparently or we got to check the r if
that's legally binding I mean I think it
makes a lot of sense um how's your
experience like what what is the emotion
that you get when you're experienced
playing against norre have you played
him mostly online because of just the
last few years uh actually we we were
teammates in the recently uh World rapid
team in in dusel DF uh organized by
Vadim and sponsored by Vadim Rosenstein
W our master so we were in the same team
so we actually did the training camp
before that so we did some training uh
in person we played a lot of Blitz Games
we also played a lot of practice games
uh in
person and I'm just going to jump in
there for a second that is really
interesting CU now in modern times we're
doing a lot more team chess events it's
it's good and bad for you guys cuz you
it's it's fun cuz you get to play on a
team which is fun for the fans but it's
a little bit dangerous right cuz you
play a lot of training games right right
which are not official now you have to
play n you're back in a semi-final here
so do you like it or do you dislike it
cuz I feel like chess used to be a lot
more secretive yeah I love it yeah it's
one I think it's one unfortunate thing
personally that chess is very
individualistic it seems like you're
super isolated all the time but if you
look at any other sport maybe except
tennis or something it's usually a team
sport so you like uh I grow a lot when
when I work with with other players you
know I I adopt their ideas you know I
get views and stuff so I much prefer a
team I would prefer it actually if every
single tournament was a team event over
individual event I'm put you on a spot
here Wesley who's up in that so you
played a lot of games Blitz rapid who's
up are you up or is
he score no one's counting no one's
counting but but I'm I think I'm doing
pretty well recently like I beat him
yesterday okay and also we played in
Berlin uh I managed to beat him also
there okay but uh it's uh I think we
also played online I don't remember who
won but it's definitely better than my
results against
Fabiano so that's one thing for sure
also I'm very excited to see a c versus
C match you know okay one thing I look
forward to so I I can't I can't deny
that that we're all looking forward well
you couldn't hear the end of hikaru's
interview but uh he said he thought that
now that the matches moved to Four game
matches he thinks Magnus is maybe even
more of a favorite but if he had to root
for someone he said he's rooting for you
so your thought your thoughts quickly on
both those comments the longer format
makes Magnus more of a favorite and your
thoughts on hikaro rooting for you no
he's completely correct and that's very
kind of him to say but you know why he
said that I was like literally two feet
away I was watching him
okay
scripted he had no choice I was I was
watching I was in I stand next to hikaro
all the time that doesn't make him say
nice things about me so I don't know
what you have going for you but okay
that's that's good he seems to be in a
good mood I'm very happy that you know
even though he uh he didn't make it
today at least he still finished tied
for fifth six yeah and I'm sure he you
know he's a very impressive player like
I'm very impressed by the way he played
in Norway also in is of man and uh this
tourament is just not for him but I I
think he's completely right like yeah
that's one of the reasons why I took uh
D against Magnus with the white pieces
yesterday because uh the more games you
play I think the more chances the
stronger player has to out play you but
but also um compared to last year now
the format's a bit different because uh
what happens the first day
doesn't car over carry over yeah so you
can lose three Z and then it's okay yeah
that's true so Wesley but it's Fab's
problem not it's Fab's problem not your
problem at least right now against
Magnus you got a problem named named
Notre Becca at her off so all right
thank you so much Lesley you're amazing
we can't wait to see what happens for
the rest of the event maybe we'll be
talking to you again after after other
Victorious matches we'll see yeah I'm
very excited I'm a bit disappointed by
how I playing armaga today but it's good
practice hopefully tomorrow play better
yeah well no one's really been that
disappointed with your play so far so I
think you're going to carry over a lot
of momentum wish you the best of luck
much and we'll see you tomorrow really
appreciate guys all right everybody was
Wesley so you heard him he chose his
opponent that means we have Clarity in
our bracket that's right it'll be Wesley
so versus Notre Becka duat turov and
Magnus Carlson versus Fabiana Carana
which means we have some things to break
down because Wesley so the guy who had
the best record through the round robin
stage set the seeds in the semi-finals
so let's talk real quick and give our
thoughts on these matchups you heard
Wesley say he chose Notre Beck I think
he had Sound Logic he's like at the end
of the day as hot as the kid is I don't
want to play the world number one or
world number two Levy yeah your thoughts
on that well let's put it this way if
Fabiano was the second highest rated
chess player in the world but the last
eight matches all went to Wesley and
Rapid Wesley probably would have chosen
Fabiano because he has his number but I
think I think Fabiano's done pretty well
against Wesley I think there's a little
bit of like look if I don't have to I'm
not going to type of situation and noer
still has to prove himself y so that's
why KY give your thoughts on Carana
Carlson the other one yeah that's a
heated matchup obviously I mean it's
another one of the world Championship
things Fab's going to try to redeem
himself there you know Carlson he was
mad he was like hey you know what uh you
picked against me twice what he said to
me then he was like uh coming to you
right about that so it was funny but
Carlson's just going to try to you know
do what he does best and try to be the
go and win this thing all the way out
it's four matches or four games so with
that being said it's GNA be really
difficult for Fabby but at the same time
if he plays the way he was playing I
think he'll have a good chance as well
equal as well I also wanted to say about
uh what' you call him NY the mystical
drag that's a nice name versus uh w Sano
like Serrano versus the Magic Dragon the
magic endgame dragon now that's crazy
the guy wins a lot of end games sick
pretty nice good I you know I'm just
goingon to say I think it's overblown I
think I think uh I I fall for this
myself like Carlson Carana the battle of
the cars you know uh we're always like
oh World Championship 20 you know 2018
that was 2018 man all over again 2018
was crazy man was it's going to be
2057 they're going to be they're going
to be in the retirement home or
hopefully not yet we're going to be
we're going to be crying and we're going
to be like
2018 like that Vince McMahon meme you
know where he's just like yeah been 2018
that was crazy no but I I mean that's
that's fair to say but also I think part
of the reason is that chess has only
gotten faster since 2018 we see more big
events with these types of time controls
but what was the storyline of 2018 it
was that Fabian Carana didn't lose in
classical he lost in the fast time
control so I think that there's a reason
that conversation continues to come up
and we have yet to seen Fabby beat
Magnus in a big rapid match I mean so
again we're here we're talking about it
so it just never happened yet what do
you do if you're if you're in his head
you know I got to be I got to do I got
to maybe wear a different shirt you know
what I mean like we might hit the gym or
something you know whatever he needs to
do he got to do it now maybe take a shot
or two before maybe don't do that okay
don't take yeah maybe we can he needs to
do something different Danny because it
that's the only way that I'm going to do
what did you say Insanity to uh do the
same thing over and over expect
different result right of course we got
to do something different here Danny I'm
a be mag well the thing is Fabiano
didn't lose an eddon Also let's keep
that in mind right it was hikaro who had
so many Armageddon and he did say in in
a two game rapid match at this level if
you get to an Armageddon it really is a
coin coin flip uh Magnus beat Fabiano in
this particular tournament with a very
convincing game with the black pieces
where he played the NYU defense right he
played e496 he played an offbeat opening
he immediately turned the game into
total chaos and Fabiano had to make a
lot of important decisions that already
had a high level of impact on the
position and he made incorrect decisions
and Magnus won that game with that you
know the queen sack at the end with the
it was a very convincing game so Fabiano
has some work to do because you know
will Magnus solidify now because he has
so many more games that wasn't just one
game now he they have to play like eight
games potentially against each other
maybe 10 games because semi-finals are
two days long y so it's interesting to
see will will Magnus tighten up or is he
G to just go all out play whatever he
wants and free style and just try to put
you know take Fabby out quickly yeah
we're going to find out we still have a
lot of things to find out can you
believe it we're having a lot of fun and
there's still four more days ahead and
guess what there's still more chess for
you to watch today this may have been
the longest chess broadcast for you in
the history of your viewing Online
Career fans but guess what if you missed
the Armageddon battle between Magnus and
hikaro from a couple days ago you should
head over to our YouTube channel and
check it out with some some bonus
features some analysis and some
commentary by someone named da nitki
there's a lot of good things about that
video I uh I think you might want to
head over and check that out but all
right for the whole crew obviously the
team in Oso shout out to them for
staying up super late Tanya David Hess
and everyone over there for everyone
here there's a lot of people working
hard to bring it Levy KY myself this is
awesome we're going to see you tomorrow
it's the first day of the semi-finals
longer matches four players are still
standing here in Toronto it's the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and we'll be
back and we'll see you then
Hikaru has to win this match wow the
black king he walks into a night
for he's in the net he's in the net he
walked right into the net Bishop can and
they know it they know it Magnus Carlson
gets the job done takes it to Armageddon
ala is flagged Magnus Carlson gets the
win alira peruja eliminated oh oh my God
he misses it Maxi misses it game set
matchar Nakamura he wins the Armageddon
NC Abdus satov he does it he goes
through to the semifinals in the
[Music]
Armageddon
sh
[Music]